foreign
is a javascript-based software stack for
creating Dynamic web pages and online
applications main application can be
developed in one language for both
server side and client-side execution
because all components of mean stack
support JavaScript programming hello
everyone and welcome to Simply learns
YouTube channel I hope you are doing
well today we will be taking you through
the mean stack full course this means
tactful course is designed to help you
understand the most widely used concepts
of mongodb angularjs express.js and
node.js in an exciting manner in mean
stack we use angular framework you can
also go for react full codes after
learning angular the link for reactful
codes and mean stack full codes will be
in the description box
in this full course you will also learn
about mongodb how to install and use the
database after we will also learn about
node and Express in detail and then
angular in the end of this full course
you will be able to understand and
deploy mean stack
before we begin let me tell you guys
that we have regular updates on
programming videos so if you are a
programmer and want to learn something
then consider getting subscribed to our
YouTube channel and press the Bell
to never simply learn so without further
Ado let's begin and see what's in it for
you
first we will see the introduction to
this full course and then we'll see what
is mongodb after that we'll see
comparison between mongodb and MySQL
moving ahead we'll see what is expressed
JS after that we will see get and post
methods in express.js after that we'll
see what is middleware after that we'll
see how to connect client-side to the
server side moving ahead we'll see what
is angularjs features of angularjs and
the companies that are using angularjs
moving ahead we'll see how to install
node.js on a Windows machine and we'll
see overview of a node.js
after that we'll see what is node.js npm
moving ahead we'll see how to build
node.js rest API using node.js
and in last we'll see how to connect
node.js to mongodb so let's start this
course over to our training expert so
what exactly is mongodb
it is a document oriented nosql database
it was initially released in August 27
2009.
mongodb replaces the concept of rows of
conventional relational data models with
something called documents it offers
developers the flexibility to work with
evolving data models since its document
based mongodb allows embedded documents
arrays and represents complex
hierarchical relationships using a
single record it is also schema free
which means that the keys defined in the
document are not fixed as a result
massive data migrations can be ruled out
but you must be wondering when there's
something like SQL why is nosql or
mongodb used
there are a few reasons why mongodb is
widely used
first up is flexibility
mongodb's notion of documents that can
contain sub-documents nested in complex
hierarchies is really expressive and
flexible
flexible query model a user can
selectively index some part of a
document or a query based on attribute
values regular expressions or ranges
next up is native aggregation native
aggregation allows its users to extract
and transform data from mongodb and
either load them in a new format or
export it from mongodb to other data
sources it makes it extremely compatible
lastly as mentioned earlier the schema
free model now applications get the
power and responsibility to interpret
different properties in different ways
now that you know what mongodb is and
why exactly it's used let's have a look
at the characteristics of mongodb
firstly it's a general purpose database
now mongodb can serve heterogeneous
loads and multiple purposes within an
application
again it has a flexible schema design
document oriented approaches with
non-defined attributes that can be
modified on the Fly is a key contrast
between mongodb and any other relational
database
next up is scalability and load
balancing it's built to scale both
vertically but most importantly
horizontally using sharding an architect
can share load between different
instances and Achieve both read and
write scalability
when it comes to load balancing this
happens automatically and transparently
to the user by the sharp balancer
again we have aggregation framework now
mongodb offers an extract transform and
load framework that eliminates the need
for complex data Pipelines
native replication now data will get
replicated across a replica set without
complicated setup
security features both authentication
and authorization are taken into account
in mongodb
next up is Json now Json is widely used
across the web for front-end and API
communication and as such it's easier
when the database is also compatible
with the same protocol
lastly we have mapreduce now again
mapreduce is an excellent tool to build
data pipelines and mongodb uses
mapreduce readily now let's quickly have
a look at the working of mongodb
data is stored in documents with the
help of key value pairs now the data is
stored in the bson format at the back
end mongodb converts Json data into a
binary format known as bson
mongodb also makes provision for nested
data now all of these documents are
stored in a collection these collections
hold multiple documents and since
mongodb is schema less the documents in
one collection need not be similar now
again these collections are stored in
the entire mongodb database as mentioned
earlier mongodb makes provision for
nested data this makes fetching of data
extremely efficient when compared to
other databases now you must be
wondering where exactly mongodb can be
applied or used so let me help you with
that several areas of Technologies use
mongodb as their dbms currently some of
them are Internet of Things mobile
applications real-time analysis
personalization and catalog management
and content management
now all said and done let's look at some
of the companies that use mongodb
currently
companies like Toyota sap AstraZeneca
Adobe Verizon Cisco Barclays and Google
among others readily deploy mongodb as
their database management system in this
video I'm gonna help you install and set
up mongodb on your Windows system
you will have to navigate to the
official mongodb website
and here you can see
software
so go ahead and click on community
server under software
and you can see that the current version
is 4.4.4 and the platform is Windows and
make sure that the package is MSI all
right now go ahead and press download
so this could take a while
all right so once it's downloaded
go ahead and install it
now since it's already installed on my
system uh the installation process will
be different but you just need to follow
the steps there and finally install it
so once you're done with the
installation you can go to your C drive
and here you can click on program files
and you can see that mongodb is
installed and inside of it you have the
server folder and then you have the 4.4
folder and then you have the bin folder
right so here you have the application
that is your [ __ ] and the mongod
applications both are executable files
now the [ __ ] D file or the application
is the Daemon process now this is the
background process that makes sure you
retrieve the data from the database
access the data so it does all the
background tasks so after the
installation now you need to create a
path to this file by doing this you
don't have to always go to the bin
folder and then execute the file you can
directly execute the file on your
command prompt right so for that let's
just
go to our environment variables
but before that let's just uh
copy this path
right
and here under the user variable section
click on path and say edit
and go ahead and just paste it right
I've already pasted mine so just go
ahead and paste it and click on OK
and
say okay
right so now you've created the path
successfully now let's head to our
Command Prompt and run the [ __ ] file so
here you can just directly type [ __ ]
since the path has already been created
so just go ahead and say [ __ ]
[Music]
and here you can see that your [ __ ]
server has been generated
and with this you know that you're in
mongodb has been successfully installed
and your server is up and running right
so just for confirmation let's see if
there are any databases and how much
space they've occupied so you can right
now just type show DBS
and when you click on it it says admin
config and localhost and all of it is
zero so with that you have successfully
installed mongodb on your system and
it's up and running
all right in this particular tutorial we
will be learning what mongodb is all
about and their advantages and some
practical demonstrations so let's get
started now
so here in mogodb we would like to
discuss about what is a mobile DB so as
we know the mongodb is known to be
called a traditional
document based database okay which
stores the data in a document
okay nosql means it doesn't say is like
no to SQL instead it says not only SQL
that means
it is not only SQL but it is supporting
the other approaches too
okay so the document based when you talk
about it actually represents the typical
hierarchical relationship using the
single records that means how the
records are related with each other so
that's how exactly it represents and it
is a pure schema free environment so
that you really do not need to have
schema before you go and develop this
program so it is a pure schema less
involvement due to that it is giving you
far more better flexibility when you
talk about completely unorganized
environment
so what is nosql so the huge idea about
a nosql so it is completely into the
non-relational database like
traditionally if you see any
non-relational database you talk about a
typical nosql uh it's purely into the
document base here no SQL does not use
any tables like in rows and columns a
traditional rdpps approach if you see
there they are using a complete table
structure like they talk about columns
they talk about rows and are all about
so here in nosql it stores the
relationship data in the documents so
the different type of nosql databases
are available like you talk about called
document based you talk about key value
base you talk about white column based
and graph based different options are
available for the nosql but the one
which we are using it mongodb it is a
purely document based database
now here we would like to go ahead with
some demonstrations like talking about
like how mongodb installation works and
the other aspects
okay everyone so now we're gonna start
working on the first option called
mongodb installation
okay see mongodb installation is very
simple if you open a website and go for
this website name called
um
download
if you talk about mobile DB download
you're gonna see the official website
called mongodb Community download is
available
when you click here
so you can see it is taking the current
version to 4.4.6
Mac OS and by default detected my
platform however you can select depends
on which platform you have it and after
that you will be clicking on this
download
okay so it'll get ready for if you are
from Windows
I would say in this Windows you can
select appropriate option like two
options are available you can talk about
MSI or talk about zip my recommendation
is you can stick to the zip power
portion because it won't start any
mongodb Services behind the scene
that is really helpful because you
really do not want more video to be
there running unnecessary even if it is
not required my situation is to stick to
the zip file so here once the bongodb is
there so you will be seeing that two
files available inside of mongodb folder
inside the bin so once you download the
zip you will find two different type of
files are available let me mention those
so inside the build folder you will see
two files one is called mongod
okay the other file which is available
called Momo
mogudes to basically start a mongod
server and the [ __ ] T Mobile is
actually the client which will connect
with the Bongo d clear so if you are in
Windows environment so once your Insight
is bin folder of your zip file you will
get the mongodb so you have to double
click on this it'll start a new command
prompt
so you do not need to do anything
further just minimize this command
prompt and go inside the bin folder
again and click on the another binary
file called MoGo so it will get start as
a client
okay since I'm using the MacBook here
the concept is little different about
how mongodb can be used
okay so this is just a basic way of how
the mode is being used into your code
okay everyone so now as we are in the
Macbook so here to start mode we have a
very special way to start with so here
I'll start with my terminal and here I
would like to paste on very simple
command to start my mongodb database
that is called mongodb
and after that you have to say hyphen
iPhone DB path it is a place where your
database will be starting and one more
important thing I forgot to mention like
would not start automatically inside
your
Windows machine unless inside your C
drive you have to create a new folder
name called data and under this you have
to create a new folder in equal DB
because automatically when the mode
starts it looks inside the C drive data
inside a DB folder there your all
records will get stored so do not forgot
whenever you're trying to use the mongod
so you must make have you must have this
particular fold structure in place in
your local machine otherwise this is not
gonna start every time you start your
mongodb without this
location it automatically terminates So
to avoid those make sure that you have
this data DP folder ready with you
however you can also change the location
of this particular folder structure for
which we will discuss it little later on
but as of now we can see I'm giving my
location that is called hyphen iPhone DB
path slash data DB I hit enter you can
see now my mobile DB is starting now and
since it's stuck so I have to start the
new terminal now
from so here I open the another tab
and type [ __ ]
and the multi-type mode now you can see
it is now connected with my mongodb and
now it is ready
that's the first thing you need to
remember
okay now to check
which are the databases are available to
you so you can just type show DBS
so it will show you the number of
databases which are already there inside
your existing
newly installed mongodb
but you can go back and create new
database too here you can see some
databases are already present however
you go back and create the new databases
into your system
and to create this database
we have very simple option available
here name call
use
simply DB
if I say use simplydb it automatically
creates this database and take you
inside let's see now you can see you say
you simply DB it automatically creates
though it is not there but automatically
takes you in while creating those
okay so that means your current database
name called simplydb so if you are not
sure which database you are in we can
just type DBS
or DB
and it will show you that your current
database is simply DB
that's it so your database is set and we
are all good to go ahead with our next
level development
hello everybody and welcome back in a
previous videos you have seen like how
to create a database and how to identify
whether my database is there or not so
if you remember previously we have
created our database using use keyword
so if I just see my databases which we
have created is last time so how we can
check this out we can say
show
space DBS
okay so you can see we have a got
database list but we do not have any
database which we have created last time
is registered here the quite surprising
because when we have created our
database it should be listed here but it
is not let's do one more time I'm saying
use
uh asset DB
and I'm saying switch to sldb now when I
say once again show DBS
so I still don't see my databases listed
here there is a reason the reason is
according to the momodb rule unless we
have minimum one
record or collection is stored inside my
mongodb it really can't show in the list
now I want to tell you about a few
important things
now
here when we talk about called mongodb
in this mongodb compared to the
relational database here the table which
is actually in rdbms it is called here
it is called
collection
okay
DB is still called DB here
okay that means the database will be
still called database but row what you
use this word in a traditional rdbm is
here it is known as called document
if you remember I told you like it is a
document based database so here every
single record what you try to insert it
is not called
a typical row it is instead called a
document so every table is called
collection and every single row it is
called
document that's what exactly the
difference is
okay
now here once it is ready we will go
ahead and talk about our next feature
now
well we have to basically go and create
a new collection okay so what you can
say DB Dot
create
collection and here I can pass my
collection name I can say
demo
collection so once it is done
I can see it is collection is created in
typical language I can say the table is
created and now when I try to see same
show DBS
foreign
is now listed
okay that's how exactly it works so the
very simplest way of how we use in my
code
well in our previous examples we have
seen like how we can create a collection
and we can give the name and I can see
the details are listed when I say show
DBS but there's a again another
alternative option available where you
can just do that without even saying DB
dot create collection
well
if I want to create a collection I
really don't need this particular
functionality called create collection I
can directly use this statement name
called DB Dot
DB dot SL
udent
dot insert and here we would like to add
the property like a name and here we can
say
admin
now what is that meaning is when you say
DB dot SL student dot insert
can I hit enter you can see this
uninserted one and surprisingly when you
try to say
press enter you will see this SL student
is not a collection which we have
created earlier
so what this line does this line not
only create the collection for you but
also add a record inside with this
property called name because that is a
mongodb and mongodb is always following
the Json based structure and due to that
it goes with the key and value pairs
so DB is a predefined keyword SL student
is a collection name insert is a command
through which you are trying to insert
the record
now to check how many collections are
there
okay so we have one property call show
collections when I say show collections
I can list down those number of
collections or else I can set tables in
a typical rdbms language which are there
added in my system
so as a student in which I can see the
record is inserted so if I want to
confirm I can simply say
DB Dot SL
udent DOT fine find is a function
through which I can list out those
number of Records which are added I say
file and you can see that the records
are
received at the same time when I say DB
dot the name call Demo correction
okay
db.democollection dot find
I'll find no record reason because this
collection was created but there was no
record which was inserted in
but you will see when I
write this command called SL
student.insert it not only create a new
collection for me but also insert the
record into my table also called a
collection
that's where exactly it is giving you
the advantage when you want the
collections to be created along with the
data this is the way how you can really
do this
clear but
whenever you talk about DB dot create
collection many people always think
about what is the significance of having
this DB dot create collection look DB
dot create collection is having its own
significance we never recommend this
technique
okay to create a collection because when
you create a collection you always bring
some restrictions some terminology which
missed out whenever you talk about this
line
so having this DB dot create collection
you can also offer some
additional capping which is not possible
when you use TP Dot
collection input result so you might be
thinking what those cappings you're
talking about let me try to brief you
when I say DB Dot
create
collection and here we are providing the
first name call support student
okay when I say student
so after this student additional
parameters what we can pass is this when
I say
capped colon
true
what do we say cap cool and true so you
are enabling the capping after that the
next parameter I'm gonna pass that is
now is called size
in this size we are providing the size
suppose I am saying 5 to
4 and also we are saying two double
eight zero that is the size of 5 MB and
here we are giving call Max colon
five what exactly that meaning is see
the meaning is very simple whenever we
try to bring this great collection
option so capping through means you are
enabling the capping so what does that
meaning is it is trying to say in this
particular collection name called
student
maximum number of
documents
can be either five or less than five
clear and the collective size of
documents cannot be increased to more
than 5 MB that means you're trying to
say either by adding the total number of
five records the collective size of five
document will reach to 5 MB okay or else
the maximum number of five documents can
be is stored so whichever fills earlier
you may have a total number of four
documents which are pretty heavy and
they
reach to the size 5 MB and beyond that
the next document won't be added or else
you can have the five documents which
has not yet even reached so any option
will help you to achieve this
so that's where exactly you can offer
the capping but this is only possible
when the user is trying to say DB dot
create collection this option is not
possible when you're trying to use this
so that's the benefit of having this DB
dot create collection and this is what
we always recommend
well now we would like to talk about our
next feature here inside the same
mongodb so we now know how to create a
collection how to create a database and
how to switch from one database to the
other database
now we will tell you like how to insert
a document so far we have already seen
how to insert a document inside the
mongodb now we would like to also show
you how we can insert the documents
using multiple techniques
so remember one thing
MoGo TV comes with two different type of
documents
one is called relational document and
second is called embedded document
mostly while working with mongodb we
always recommend you to use embedded
documents because that helps you to
scale up your application without any
hurdle
okay the embedded documents means what
that means the
uh I would say the parent record as well
as the child records both stores in the
same location
fine so how exactly that is let's take a
look about this example
here we would like to insert some
records by saying DB Dot
student I do not have a student
collection or I'm just telling you DB
dot student
Dot
insert
here we would like to add some records
what I'm trying to say the registration
number
registration number I'm just saying
uh one two three four you can give
anything now the next one we will talk
about call name
this name we can say
student one
followed by the next one I'm talking
about which course the student has
registered so we can say
course inside this course we would like
to say the course name let's say
course name we are given the course name
call
MCA
okay followed by another property called
duration
okay I'm giving this duration
is called
three
years like that
after that
this curly braces is closing that means
see the idea is like you see the course
is an embedded document because from
course you have about few more
properties like in course name and
duration
I am closing this and starting the
another property and that is called
address
okay
sorry let me remove from here and from
address and address we can say one more
curly basis
and inside this address we can say City
I'm giving the name called what
Bangalore
the another one we are using that is
called state
[Music]
um
let me remove this state
colon
ke
okay and the third property we're using
that is what is called country
here is saying IE that is called India
so it is closing here
okay and it is closing here so the inner
document and how to document both are
closed hit enter and now you can see the
records are inserted one thing you might
notice
the course
and the address these two are embedded
documents and they do not have any
primary key of its own instead the
course and address both are directly
dependent on
the student object
or the student database so
I will say student have the registration
number
fine
and the primary key so the primary key
will be associated with the most outer
document and the inner documents are
directly
associated associated with them and now
when I try to say DB Dot
student
dot find
you can see now the records are
fetched
I can understand many of you are
thinking every time
while adding the record we do not add
any object ID
and here you might have observed and
there also your option then what exactly
that ID is now let me brief you this ID
is nothing but a unique primary key your
mongodb has offered you
that means mongodb says whichever data
you are inserting it so by default with
every single document
mogodb will associate this by default
property called underscore ID which you
can't even ignore
however you can overwrite
I haven't provided any
underscore ID is a property because this
is a predefined property associated with
every single mongodb document if you
want to override it you can overwrite
from this value to any value because if
you do not pass any value
this value will be automatically
provided that is a typical hexadecimal
value however if you want to override it
you can override the value of underscore
ID but you can't change the key name
let's try with some
another record so same record if I try
to add
let's go
I'm using call
student2 and here I'm saying one two
three four five here if I want to
override it I can just say underscore ID
colon I can give the value called what
one zero one
this you need to remember for I'm
overriding this value with 1 0 1 now
adding it now records are added now let
me call find now you see this time the
records when I fetched so in this record
the first record contains a default
underscore ID in a second record it is
the one which I have provided
and remember one thing in mongodb you
really can't offer any property other
than underscore ID as a primary key
here there is no concept of having the
cons like a composite key which you used
to do in Tradition
rdbms here you have only underscore ID
and this is the only property which you
can override it else by default the new
value will be given to you so this is
the first way of how the insert document
has been done we'll be telling you the
another ways where the other documents
are also added Okay so
in the previous examples you have seen
like how we can add the records but I
also tell you there is another
alternative options are available if you
want to insert the records in a bulk
that option is also possible in mongodb
how we can do let's try to understand
here
here we would like to use one very
simple concept for one
my
EMP equal to now starting with
a typical object like this and after
that I mean adding this and within this
I'm adding the first property called EMP
ID
colon one
after this okay now you can see it is
not understanding because that is a
challenge when we talk about call uh you
know the logical part
because you go with multiple lines it is
not supporting however you have to
follow the same lines now
empid1 and we just give the second
property called EMP name
so
amp ID just
remove this I just say EMP ID and I say
amp
Name colon
admin
okay adding it here
so
first record here again I'm adding
another one I'll call
amp ID column two
okay and now
colon
manager
okay again
column three
and
colon
Cuba
added
okay and this curly process is closing
after this
your square bracket is also closing and
once it is done it will come down and
say DB
Dot
new amp
dot insert
okay and here you pass the name of the
object called my AFB
and you can see now it is telling you n
inserted three that is known called work
insert we are inserting multiple records
in a single shot
see how easy it is for you
okay now you simply use DB dot The
Collection name is what your new AP
dot find
and you can see now quality records are
inserted with its default object ID
okay so that is a really nice idea to
have
the ID to be provided
okay remember this statement
so you understood finally how we can
add the records in a book going forward
we will also talk about which is related
to your update as well as delete in your
upcoming demos okay but here that is the
first thing which you realize it how we
can perform those kind of operations in
very very simple and straightforward
manner okay everyone so now we have got
three records with us and in case if I
am planning to perform update on any of
my records how will I do this now so we
have a predefined functions available
name called update function let's see
how this update function can really work
so we use this statement name called DB
dot what is my collection name which is
known as call a new EMP new EMP
okay dot
update
okay so what I will do I will say DB dot
new EMP Dot
update here
okay now when we talk about call update
we have a
statement available
okay what is that that is called
EMP ID we call EMP name so we say
wherever the EMP ID is this I want to
change what the name how can I do this
now very simple uh
to perform this what I would like to do
now I want to basically add few more
records to give you some more better
idea
uh you can see now here we have a call
admin ID name
so I just do one thing I just change the
IDS
one two three I just say four
ISO five
message six
okay and I
call this
again the three records are inserted now
let me try to call find now we have
total number of
six records are available where admin is
repeated manager is repeated QA is
repeated
now let me try to update the record
okay now I want to say DB Dot
new EMP
eror
Dot
update here I would like to perform the
property like in what
uh
name as a EMP name
amp Name colon if I say admin
okay
so I just close that and I use another
curly braces with dollar
set that means you want to set the new
value here we are giving
EMP name
okay what I want to do I say wherever
the name is admin change to what
admin new that name I want to change it
close this close this
and run
now you can see it is saying n match to
one
and the record fields are updated like
this let me check
well here I will see uh the value called
admin new is updated but I have one more
admin called admin it is not changed and
there is something which you need to
notice
what you need to notice is notice is
like when you try to perform update so
what mongodb does it starts from the top
find the first record
change the value or modify the value and
come out from the loop it doesn't carry
forward its search process for the next
level of results and there is something
which is
ideally want to do that so in case if
you are planning to change those values
multiple times so what you need to do
let's take a look here in the similar
example here we have a called name admin
second property vehicle called manager
let's try to say
the managers are repeated twice we just
want to change to
new underscore
manager and I want to update multiple
values so what I will do here
I will put comma and say
multi
colon should
okay same multicolon true that you want
to say hey I want to update multiple
search or multiple repetitions hit enter
just now you can say it is saying and
match to and modify 2 that means two
records formed and two records are
modified let's check
there we go we have got new manager is
updated in both the location
that's something which is really awesome
because this is how you try to perform
the multiple changes
well in our previous examples you see
like how we can perform the update part
but we have a one more beautiful feature
available inside the mongodb and that is
called how exactly we can perform absurd
clear let's talk about absurd upset is a
combinations of update and insert let me
try to show you one magic here
here
when we talk about called update part
you see now
here we are trying to say
uh
this point
yeah you see about multi-true we have
used
now here
this multi-true
is we're trying to update but let's talk
about something called manager 2.
enter now you can see it is saying no
records formed
clear now no records formed
but there's one concept available name
called absurd absurd means if I try to
perform up certain means if the records
are not available it'll insert the
record
I want to show you one simple example
now here we are using multi-truth
okay so as I can see we're using
something called name and we're
performing this update part
so in this update part we are using this
dollar set new manager so here rather
than using multi-truth
we are saying
obstruction
when I say upset rule so what happened
now they say and matched 0 and up
inserted 2 and modified with ID this
that means when I try to call this find
function you will be seeing now we have
a god
the another record has been added are we
clear now
as a new record
so upsa does what upset says like if the
records are found
I will update it if it is not I will
insert it that means if I try to call
the same thing manager 2
fine it is added as a new manager now if
I just try to say
uh
not manage it to have a call QA
okay and here we're saying EMP equal to
new
underscore QA
and now you can see it is saying
unmatched one and I've sorted 0 and
modified one so it is clearly telling
you like hey I did not find any uh
inserted part but yes I matched one
record I found one record and the one
record is updated now that is very very
beneficial feature when you really want
to perform absurd so that is a
update plus insert
very important feature that depends on
the requirement if you want to add you
can certainly add this so the way we
have tried to add this upserted part we
can also try to perform the delete part
also
okay so mongodb also helps you to
perform the delete part and how you'll
be trying to add it now let's try to
understand here in my code if I were to
perform any delete path I have this
statement name called DB
dot the option we are using it that is
also collection name EMP
sorry
dot we have option name for remove
in this remove we would like to offer
the property
okay and what we're talking about now
here let's try to add the ID here or the
name which you would like to import so I
want to say like EMP name admin new so
we just say
okay name
okay
and then scoreboard
admin name
okay EMP name admin name when I say
remove
we can see it is record removing the
first record
so you can see now the records are
removed
fine because there is only one admin is
available
okay now in a similar way if I try to
remove
the property call a new underscore
manager new underscore
manage it hit enter now you can see the
three records are removed so it's not
like update which removes only one sorry
update only one record it can also
eliminate more than one records at the
same time
that's the benefit of remove so now you
can see we have already implemented some
records
as I seen earlier like we have performed
the delete part now
when I try to say DB
Dot
new EMP dot find
three records are available with me
three four and six
now when it comes to C insert part we
have seen update part we have seen
delete part we have seen now it's time
to basically fetch the records
so find function we've already seen But
in find function we also have some
conditions so called queries so in case
if you want to limit the number of
Records into your application you can
also do that let's see DB
Dot
uh new EMP
Dot
find
clear now so in find you can also
pick up the specific records too like
when I'm saying dot find and here we can
just say name
colon
admin
sorry
here to put curly braces
it says there is no record with the name
called admin
because it is the EMP name not a name so
let me change back to
now I can say it finds one record so
like that you can also apply a condition
okay enter your code now in a similar
line if you really don't want to offer
any condition
okay but you want to limit the number of
Records to be shown so you have this
function available name call
limit
2 2 means only two records now you can
see though I have three records but it
is only showing me two records because I
have limit those number of Records into
my code
also we can perform sorting in case if
you want to perform the Sorting in
ascending and descending order that also
you can also do so here rather than
saying limit
with this put this option name called
sort and in this sort on which property
you want to sort it that also you can
mention so we can just say PMP name
okay and using ascending button or
descending order so you can just say
um minus one well you got descending
order
hit
now I can see it is showing in a
descending order now if I just say
minus 1 if you just say one that is
showing you in an ascending order so you
can pick up the specific property we
have on which you can tell it should be
either on descending order or ascending
order so that option really works very
fine
okay
so that's like how you can perform the
queries but remember one thing you can
also
search the records based on the embedded
columns too because if you see in a
previous records we have
some records added okay that is let me
try to say show
collections
our call SL student
and student
okay DB Dot
Dot
find
okay
you can see we have records which are
embedded records now if you want to
search the records based on their
embedded properties like I'm talking
about address this is about property
name called City
fine so if you would like to pick up
those records these are also possible
so how you can do this very simple so
you say TV DOT
student
Dot
find
okay so inside this file you can provide
the specific properties like my
outermost property name is called what
address so we are using this option
called
address dot dot city so we say City
are we clear colon I'm giving the city
name called what Bangalore
okay let me close this
and that's it
okay so we have to start passing
another curly places here hit enter and
you can see now I find two records
because both the records belong to what
Bangalore so I'm getting this City
Bangalore with me
that's really awesome like you can also
pass the city accordingly
a part of that we also have
the other details also
okay in which you can have the
conditions based on less than greater
than or whatever values you would like
to make it is available and possible
okay so that's how the conditions are
satisfied
so suppose if you would like to pick the
users
I'll be clear where the range which you
would like to consider so those are also
possible like you can see we have this
property name called what amp ID3 and 6.
I just want to pick up only those
records whose ID is greater than what
two so what I can say DB
dot new EMP okay dot find
and inside this file we can say
the property okay so what's property
we're using empid we are saying EMP ID
here colon here we'll be using dollar GT
GC stands for what greater than colon
we're giving the value called what one
why close this
run we can see you have received three
records three four and six
in case if I just look forward for
higher than 5
you will see only one record so greater
than
let's call GT
okay
same option if I just say LT
you can see we have found
two records so less than greater than
okay so that's how exactly you offer it
okay and also you can provide the
condition so called limit as I can say
find amp ID the way we provide it so
here I will not use listed
okay instead I'll be providing another
property let me show you what
so here in empid whatever we have taken
so let me try to take the property call
file and here we are providing EMP
ID and then
we're using another curly braces we'll
be using Dollar in is very important
property Dollar in Colon here you
provide the details I'm saying uh inside
so the property is three four six we are
saying three
comma 6.
close this
and you can see we got two records
which matched with three and six that's
the benefit of having
this okay everyone so in our previous
example we have already seen lot many
activities this time we are trying to
offer you something very interesting
feature and that is known is called
working with indexing see mongodb is one
of the most popular tool
and one of the reason why it is very
popular because it is having the
facility of having indexing now what
exactly the index does so friends main
job of having this index is to basically
give you the concept of like how uh one
particular uh document which is huge
document in case if you would like to
perform any sort of indexing inside this
how you will be applying this
so to apply indexing into my code let's
try to understand why index is really
required without indexing and with
indexing how you'll be making a
difference into the code
so to make it happen we would like to
insert some records
to confirm
okay
so what I will do is in Step number one
previous records if I see I have a got
four six three four one depends on what
earlier records we had it so we had a
call
new EMP
so DB dot new EMP
dot find
so we have total number of three records
are available so it's okay we can have
this three records with me
now let me try to apply indexing without
indexing if I want to find the result
what outcome I'm gonna receive so to
know about how much time it gonna be
taking if if I have a got large number
of records with me I'll be using this
statement name called DB
dot the name is called New EMP
Dot
explain and here I will be using one
predefined functionality called
execution starts
foreign
we'll be using the first property here
okay and
what user would like to find it that you
need to basically offer it so we are
giving the name called EMP name
colon give the name call
QA
okay let's close
okay now when I pressed hit enter
execution stats is a predefined
functionalities which will tell me
when the query was executed what exactly
the query plan was hit enter and now you
can see a lot of details
are available with me
like you can see
pass query winning plan and everything
one thing you need to Remember by
default
here when I try to run it says and
return one
Advance one need time total everything
it is showing me but one important thing
which you will see here
is
total number of documents is scanned
so it is telling me total number of
document examined is 3. clear now
and return one that means one result is
returned and the total number of
documents examines three in order to
find this record
just imagine a use case here
when I say total number of documents
examine 3 in case if I ever got millions
of records with me that means to search
the record it will examine all the
Millions number of Records to search the
result which certainly gonna be taking
huge amount of time
and that's where exactly when you try to
search the record
fine when you have no indexing is
available
okay so you need to understand one
important thing is
by default index is applied on your
underscore ID DB Dot
new EMP
um
yeah DB dot newmp dot
when I say DB dot new emp.getindex is a
predefined function it tells me like hey
by default index is applied or
underscore ID
that's the fact because by default index
is applied on underscore ID not on the
other properties
so I need to identify which of the
properties are required to be get
indexes mongodb advantages it is
supporting multi-column indexes and
that's what exactly we would like to see
so let's see in our next demo now we
will try to apply indexing on our own
property
okay so to apply the index what we need
to do we have to say DB
Dot
certainly we will be talking about
called collection name call
um new EMP
Dot
create index
here you have to pass two things number
one
on which property you would like to
apply
okay and it has to be ascending or
descending so I am trying to apply on
EMP
and I want the index to be applied on
ascending order
okay so here
colon one
hit enter you can see now it is telling
me like uh number of indexes before 1
and number of indexes after two that
means earlier index was available only
on one particular property now it is
applied on two properties if you want
you can check now you can see there's
another property is added called EMP
underscore
now if I try to execute a similar query
which I executed earlier
now you'll be seeing there's a different
statistics all together
here if I see
in my code
See it'll tell you total document
examined one see now earlier the number
of document examined were three but
since this index is applied not is
telling me the total number of document
examined is one so performance is
certainly improved
so to search your document it won't be
searching the complete
collections
okay rather it will search what only
that particular column in which it is
actually applied for
so that's the benefit in fact I would
say when you will be using these kind of
indexes into your code
okay so hope we all are clear and
understood about this concept so let's
go ahead and get the simply minted into
our system
well this is the first way of how the
index can be applied so you can also
apply index on multiple properties
clear so that we will show you one by
one how it is
okay everybody so we have already seen
in our previous example how we have
applied indexes in our existing mongodb
application
so it is also a possibilities where we
want to also apply the index on other
number of properties too as you can see
in our existing database
okay an existing collection my
collection name is new EMP which
contains two different properties one is
called amp ID in second called EMP name
just now we have applied index on our
EMP name but in case if I want to apply
index on EMP ID I'll be using the same
technique okay let's try to apply index
on the same
so first of all get indexes I'm having
this index applied on two different
property now we would like to say DB
dot create
index and here in this DB dot create
index we can just
I will say DB dot collection name so our
collection name is called New EMP new
EMP
dot create index first parameter is
certainly the name of which property we
are applying so here we are saying EMP
ID
and in this EMP ID we will just offer it
has to be ascending or descending let me
decide descending order
so we're saying
-1
okay now let's press enter and check the
status okay now you can see earlier
indexes which we have created that was
two and now it turns to three so it is
very clear that index is improving now
let's check this out
uh DB Dot
newmp.getindexes now we have a total
number of three indexes are available
so you can apply index or n number of
columns if you want
okay at the same time the way we have
created the index in case if I want to
drop an index so we can also drop so
what we can do DB dot new EMP
dot drop index
drop
index
and in this drop index we have to
provide
which particular index we would like to
draw
remember this point in case if you're
planning to drop any sort of index so
you need to provide which index so you
should have that particular index name
okay so here we are providing my index
name so it should not be uh I would say
the traditional name called EMP ID no it
has to EMP ID
underscore minus 1 or
EMP name underscore one so this should
be the name I'm saying EMP
in case if you try this
you see it is saying index not found
with the EMP name because internally it
maintains with this name
let's try this out we'll say EMP name
underscore one let's try
and now you can see new index was 3 okay
1.
okay
now you can see we have a call empid and
underscore ID
so now we have
only two indexes left there is no EMP
name anymore this is how exactly you can
drop the indexes so it is very simple
and straightforward way of how
in mongodb you can perform your
activities hello everybody and welcome
back
in a previous examples of mobodb you
might have considered
we have used lot many operations in our
last video we have seen how to utilize
uh indexing into our code now in our
next journey of our mongodb we will see
how aggregation Works see in mobodb
aggregation plays a vital role and
aggregation comes with so many handy
functions with mongodb which will help
you to perform
and to apply some very simple code
Snippets into your ongoing
uh I would say the requirement which can
make your query so much seamless now we
will see how this aggregation really
works and to work on an aggregation we
have taken some default database name
called aggregate DB and here we have a
call student as a by default collection
in which we have some set of records are
already added
now if I just want to apply aggregation
now I would like to tell you about what
exactly the aggregation is see ideally
when you talk about called aggregation
okay so aggregation is nothing but a
call aggregate like rdbms if you see
vertical aggregation there so the Unix
command like you talk about shell
pipeline means the possibility to
execute an operation on some input and
use that output as an input for the next
command
that means the output of one particular
execution becomes an input for others
so mongodb also supports same kind of
concept in aggregation framework the
summary type of functionalities are
available which we will see one by one
into our next code
okay now here we want to confirm about a
few important things now here let me try
to bring some of the important well
known
I would say the functionalities of our
aggregation framework first we use a
term name called dollar project
the project is basically designed for
select
specific
specific Fields Donald project is
designed to select what is specific
fields from a collection we used to talk
about called what
dollar match the match is responsible to
filter out the operations
are we clear now it is designed to
filtering out the operations
you talk about dollar group
talk about dollar group so it does the
actual aggregation fine we talk about
call Dollar sort
okay it basically sort the document
okay like that there's so many
operations that are available which we
will see one by one in our aggregation
Behavior now my first example the one
which I want to execute I have a call
student record with me which contains a
student name okay the section
and the marks and the subject on which
subject the person or the student
disappeared now here my first
requirement is we want to filter
data based on a Section 8 because
students belong to different sections as
you can see now it is they belong to the
different section section A B C D so I
just want to filter the data based on a
section A
okay so for filter out I would like to
use dollar match let's see how it works
so I just would like to filter out only
those students who belong to the section
A
so how we would like to use it now I
will say DB Dot
student Dot
Aggregate and inside this we would like
to use this
square brackets and then curly braces
and then use
dollar
match
with this I would like to use another
curly braces
and I say
section
8.
okay and I close this close this close
the square bracket close this
okay so DB dot student dot aggregate
aggregate should be always associate
match is not the aggregate functionality
section a hit enter and you can see now
it lists down all those students who
belong to the section 8.
okay very simple and straightforward
example
now we would like to use the second
example so we want to find out all the
records where the section is a and we
are using and operator Max is greater
than 80 there are so many students who
have a different marks like 1790 and
whatever
so we want to use both the conditions
together so how are you going to be
using this now remember not only the
section A but also marks were greater
than 80. so similar thing we have a call
match
okay after this match we are starting
this curling braces
okay so after this match we would like
to bring and
we say dollar
and and again colon
again we are starting this square
bracket now
okay we talk about what
section A
number one and after this the first
curly braces we would like to use marks
we say
marks colon and once again
we would like to start curly braces and
here we use
dollar GT that is called what a greater
than colon
80.
okay all are closed so you see like here
we have got this square bracket in noun
brackets
so
what else is left
so we have a call 80 we are using
another curly braces needs to be closed
here
and then
square bracket
okay and followed by again curly braces
green curly braces
again
square bracket again round brackets
okay
let's see where it is going on
so we're using this DB dot
student.aggregate we'll use this
yeah square bracket then curling braces
then we use
dollar match
okay after the dollar match
we are using another curly braces and we
have a call and operator after this and
we have a call
risk of square bracket then curly braces
section A
outer section is getting closed we are
using another curly braces marks colon
dollar GT
okay and we are using what colon
80. after that we are closing this
and using two more curly which is called
bracket in this
okay so this where exactly you can
utilize that so DB dot student dot
Aggregate and like this it will be able
to get it now okay so in a previous
example that was the only missing point
was after this
uh this dollar match we didn't apply
this curly braces
that was only missing point which was
there and now we have applied another
code is giving me this outcome and I
have only one user who's scoring greater
than 80. well that was the first thing
which we have it now
along with this I would like to go ahead
and talk about few more things now I
just would like to bring selective
Fields not all the fields like as you
can see we have a call student name
section marks everything I'm getting it
so I really don't want to bring all the
properties from this document I would
like to selectively take specific
property so
let's talk about how we can use this so
we'll be using project you remember
about project is responsible to select a
specific record
so I just use this statement name called
DB
Dot
student okay dot
I click it we're using it now after that
square bracket
then curl replaces now we are trying to
say dollar
project
what you would like to use the dollar
project and colon we are trying to use
student name
okay colon
okay remember one thing one means I want
to zero means I don't want so whichever
property will be enabling it by giving
the one as a digit that means it is
it is expected to be displayed so I'm
saying one
comma I'm saying section
colon 1 okay and I'm also
looking forward for marks
colon one
that's it so now
we can see now I am once again picking
up only those like student section and
marks now if I go back and remove some
properties like I only want
student and section you can see I have
only students and sections are used
here if I just use this statement name
call
underscore ID column 0.
now you can see only
the names and sections are visible ID is
not because I really don't want ID by
default ID is shown but if I says 0 that
means the ID will not be visible here so
like that you can select
The Columns or the properties
accordingly that was the one way now
another thing I would like to use
what if you want to find out the student
name section and marks from student once
again we want to find out this token
name section and marks from the student
collection where the section is a
okay so here it will be the combinations
of match as well as the project
how we can use this let's take a look
towards my implementation
if you see the previous one what we have
used here
you remember about we have used this
statement called aggregate match
okay so now we would like to go back and
utilize
after this total match
this is a curly basis I'm giving
section
colon
a
okay section colon a and after this I'll
close this
okay and close this again
I'm opening it up by using this option
call
project dollar
project we are picking up the project
right now and here with this colon
symbol we can use again and say
student name
foreign
Name colon we are using one
comma
section colon 1
and
1.
Max colon 1 and now
closing this
now I can see I got those so the
requirement was
we want to find out the student name
section and marks from student
collection with a section is a so you
are not only using the match
okay but also using what the selective
details like this you can implement it
okay that's where exactly the projection
really works so projection gives you lot
many opportunities which you can utilize
it for your own and also it comes with
lot many predefined functions like in
some AVG and all so let's talk about
those functionalities too
so this is the first thing which we have
seen aggregations are taken place now in
case if you would like to perform the
group like if I want to find out a total
marks
Group by okay section like each and
every section I would like to confirm
the total marks in every section then
how will I basically do that
so let's try to get this example also
so here
let me try to
go back
and we will not be using match here
because I would like to use the group
part
so
after this curly basis we want to use
dollar
group
okay that is called Group by in rdbm is
how you use it here we use this curly
braces again here we are passing this
underscore ID
okay you have to provide underscore ID
in a group because you cannot skip it
that part you need to be always remember
you really can't skip dollar ID whenever
you're trying to talk about code group
this is a compulsory field you need to
have it after that
Now using this
section
in this section
we are saying dollar
section
because we would like to make it on a
section basis
after this
closing
and here we are using what
total marks
colon here curly braces
again
uh dollar
sum
okay colon on which we have I want to
use it marks so I can say dollar
marks
naming convention is very important
because it is a JavaScript so it is a
case sensitive
okay then
and you can see now section wide I'm
able to get all the marks
isn't this an amazing that's where
exactly the aggregations are playing
very important role while retrieving
such kind of Records
so hope you are clear about how we
utilize this together
so in a previous example we got it like
how we are basically taking this marks
in my application fine so we are clear
about how we are picking that up but
what in case if I would like to take a
marks for the specific section
so it is also possible so we'll be using
the same group but only thing is what
will be bringing the match between
because here we are trying to get the
all the section marks but if you would
like to bring it only for the specific
section we know it variable what we need
to do so here
before I talk about call Dollar group we
can use one more curly braces here
okay so we can use this option called
dollar match
okay and here we are using this
uh option called section A
sorry
here in dollar match we are giving this
call
section
colon here we're giving
closing this
closing this
followed by
the other areas like in group which you
want to start now
so you can start with this curly braces
hit enter and you can see now only the
specific section we are able to receive
the records
and that's very simple now
okay so that's where exactly you would
like to perform and there's another
option like in case if you would like to
perform at an average suppose if you
want to fetch the count of student in
each section and total marks and average
marks as well is so total marks as well
as the average marks you want to get it
so how are you able to take it now
so it is very simple as you have seen
earlier also into our code how we have
taken called group underscore ID section
talking about section
total marks with the sum we are also
using this after that we can also use
the average
Okay so
this is we have taken group underscore
ID sum
so here onwards we will start
so when we say sum marks after that we
can just put curly braces
and we can just use count
okay and after this we will be using
this column
curly basis and use
dollar
sub
okay colon one
okay and after that I'll put
comma here and we use
average
and inside this average I will use
in curly braces we can say dollar AVG
okay colon of what
dollar
marks
very simple
so curly process is closed
okay so total how many three curly
braces will be closed
one square bracket and all brackets and
now you can see you got the average
markings in each and every section
so just imagine how easy it is for you
to deal with the aggregations so
aggregation seems to be very very simple
approach provided by mobo TV that really
create a difference of how the
aggregation changes the way how you
react
okay everybody so after going through uh
the idea of like how we can utilize
the concept of
aggregation it's time to talk about like
how
when it works with mogodb mobile DB is
properly known for
I will say for replication that is
called high availability and that
feature comes by default with mongodb
you really don't need to install any
software for this because it is a
built-in feature for the mongodb so when
you download that it comes along with
this so no additional
configuration setup is really required
when it comes to the mongodb part okay
so let's get started and talk about how
mobile DB can offer the replication see
the idea behind the application is what
the idea application is like you are
replicating it
okay
so when I talk about course application
you are replicating your data to wait
the multiple child so here in mongodb we
have one concept available
okay that is known as master
okay and
slaves
okay Master is one and there will be
multiple sleeves okay so these slaves
where your records are actually stored
and this is a master which will be
responsible to replicate the data to all
its Childs when the request comes due to
that in case I have one particular
node fails so automatically the data
will be taken from the another nodes
that's the beauty of having this master
and node slave process so to make this
possible we have a very simple option
available
concept like call mongodb Atlas so there
we can go and get our cluster ready so
here we start with the concept name
called [ __ ]
DB Atlas
let's search for mongodb Atlas and here
I see mongodb Atlas database as a
service see this is a free tool it's the
cloud environment where you really don't
need to install mobodb in your local
machine it is a cloud-based mongodb
support which is free to use with a
limited amount of space but yes for the
testing purpose it is the best suitable
so I can start with the start free or
else I can say the login here
okay from there onwards I can go ahead
now it is getting ready
now this is a place from where you can
start working on your cluster see as
I've told you like initially when you
will be working on this
mobile DB it will ask you to create a
cluster
initially
okay since I already have a cluster with
me
okay so I really don't need to create it
and as a free tier it will not allow me
to have more than one cluster setup
ready
so if I say create a new cluster
okay and I say by default AWS
okay another red closed on this
notification AWS you can select any
other cloud provider and uh
8GB Ram Cloud backup cluster name you
can see now it is taking me
0.54 per hour reason being because I
already have a cluster with me hence
more than one cluster is not allowed in
a free tier cluster so I have to cancel
this but
you can go and create a cluster the way
it was offered there so if you want to
create you can just go ahead and do
nothing just select by default AWS
select your location okay give the name
of the cluster you want to give anything
you can give it here otherwise let it be
the by default name cluster and say
create cluster it will take a while
minimum two to three minutes depends on
the availability it creates a cluster
for you and your cluster once it is
ready it looks like that
Okay so
here in this application you have to go
back and understand what is there any
questions when I click on cluster zero
you can see now here we have got three
nodes available one is called primary
node which is called Master as I
suggested earlier
and no viable called sleeves
automatically when the Clusters are
created inside this mongodb by default
it will be three node cluster where the
one will be the primary in two will be
secondary
based on your package whichever you have
taken it you can increase the number of
nodes later on but as a free I am gonna
get or I will be receiving total number
of three nodes available here so record
whichever will be stored it will get
stored automatically in both the nodes
secondary nodes and from the primary I
can insert the record in secondaries I
can read the records remember you can't
insert records into the secondaries you
can only insert a record only in your
privacy course secondaries are not
allowed
to insert
so this is your replica set okay these
are the nodes which are available to you
so when you click on this primary here
you will see
it is telling you know today well no
data available no data available nothing
is there because I haven't stored any
records as such
so I just go back to my cluster
so initially I would like to go back and
create few things now okay I would like
to go back and set up few initial things
at a time of creating the cluster
because when you cluster is created
clear now so in that point of time no
setting is configured you have to do few
settings now first setting is you have
to put it and remember the steps First
Step will be your network access so in
network access you have to go and you
have to say add IP address and in this
add IP address you have to select this
option
from which location you would like to
accept
only those IP addresses will be white
listed otherwise what you can do you can
see here in my options I have given
0.0.0 that means all IP addresses are
acceptable so all IP addresses are used
okay so this you have to enable it
otherwise you won't be able to get
this network access from any third party
locations
next you have to talk about call
database access which is required for
you to create a new user there are
already some new users are created but
it is recommended that you to go and
create a new users here
okay so you can go back and add a new
user so by default it is username and
password is given so you can go back and
create a new user when I say add user
you can give the username as well as the
password as per your own convenience so
new user I'm going to create it it is
known is called SL okay user
and here we're giving call
admin
one two three so SL user admin123
remember this will be the username and
password I'm saying add user
new user is automatically added as a
user every one two three
so
once you have provided this network
access database access
next you have to create a new data
so what you need to do when you go back
to your
statement okay network access database
access it will ask you like you want to
create a new database so I just go back
to my project zero will be on an option
equal collections you have to go back
and create a new collection here
now it is retrieving the list of
databases
now you can see there are already some
collections are there my DB is one of
the database which is there demo DB is
there not many databases are there so
you can go back and create some new
database and connect through
so if I just create database I already
have a simple learn DB with me user app
is already when collections are created
so creating a database in correction is
very easy if I give you the quick demo I
say create database give the collection
name call SL demo
okay and give the username call
[Music]
create
now you can see SL demo create it is
there with me so there is no record
right now and once it is there ready so
remember asset demo and employee I'll go
back to my uh
code again project zero
and from here I can say connect
because I want to connect it so to
connect it from because your mongodb is
already there so you want to connect it
through so to connect it through here
very simple option available you can
just click on this
correct option multiple options are
there through [ __ ] share connect your
third party application of the mongodb
compass so since I already have a [ __ ]
shirt with me so Mac OS I have this Mac
OS with me so we can just use this line
okay so if you have a window you can
select your window since I have this Mac
OS I'm selecting this line but I need to
replace with this
you can see this username
okay and you have to give the username
here I will I'll selected this I'll open
my terminal
okay and this is I'm just closing this
I'm opening up
other terminal here
since I want to correct to the [ __ ]
shell now so what I need to do here in
this
I'll just paste that the command which I
have it now
username is
if you remember I told you
you call
some users which you have already
created
let's check
here
SL user
I say
Excel user I hit enter It'll ask me the
password so I've given the password
admin
and now you can see it is connecting
with me to this particular
see
now see it is connecting me to this a
particular replica set you can see in a
logs it is telling you very clearly
okay saying that it is a username 4.2
and you can see it is correcting with
your short cluster the cluster which is
created and this is where exactly I have
it with me
so I'm connecting with this environment
so primary is there so if I just want to
go back and say
show
collections
so I can go back and create a new
collection here
okay so it's up to you now by default
collection which is your employee so I
can say DB Dot
employee Dot
insert
and now here we can just add
um
name
okay
now you can see some exception is raised
so
you understand
foreign
cluster so if I just go back and
go back to my project zero where we have
got
collections
here you will be getting
the
SL demo
employee
loading the documents
if it takes time to get this but this is
where exactly you see the records will
be stored
okay so that's where exactly it works
fine for all of you so we have this
record okay so when I say
show collection so we have a call
employee when I say TV DOT
employee Dot
find
so I can see we have got new collection
name call
this is added right now
okay so like this you have got the first
connection established and the records
has been inserted in this particular
tutorial we will help you to connect
your mongodb
with the front end it is called python
as we know it very well about the
popularity of python in last recent
years it is growing like anything so we
thought why not to offer you this
connectivity where you can have the
mongodb
not in a local environment but in a
cloud environment so here we will tell
you how to create the momodb complete
environment of cluster in your cloud and
we can have this connectivity with our
python which is running local to my
system so I show you what few important
things
one by one so why python mongodb we
understand mongodb is one of the most
important database which is so called
document based database available in
market and it is fantastic phenomenal in
terms of speed and the reliability
it is purely called nosql database okay
and helps you to go schema less
now python is one of the most commonly
user-friendly programming language for
creating a complete web-based framework
so it offers you huge amount of
libraries with flexibility to of
connecting wide variety of applications
so we would like to give you the idea of
like how Python and mongodb works
together
okay so you can use both the products
together to develop
different varieties of applications
which can suit
to different type of ideas now here we
have another very very popular tool
available name called Pi [ __ ] so Pi
[ __ ] is actually the python Library
which is a kind of a driver through
which you will be able to connect with
your mongodb and perform basic
operations whichever you expect
okay so let's go ahead and start working
on those demos okay
so we will start with
creating a mongodb environment with
cluster in one of the very very popular
tool that is known as called mongodb
Atlas so we'll be opening our website
and go here and talk about call
mongodb Atlas
I searched for mongodb Atlas that is
basically the mongodb way called
database as a service I'll be selecting
the first option
and go to the start free because it's
gonna offer you by default some 500 MB
of free space I say sign up with Google
going ahead and selecting this
okay I say accept and say submit
okay so it is starting up now
It'll ask you about a few things I would
rather say to select skip
and continue
well it'll ask you about which
environment you would like to take so I
like to take this shared cluster I say
create cluster now here it will take a
while to get to yourself ready for you
can see it is offering the sandbox of
having five lb of free space
and this mongodb
no backup that is the by default cluster
name you can give the name of the
cluster if you want but Let It Be by
default cluster zero I'm saying create
cluster
so my cluster is being ready so it will
take a while to get your cluster set up
so just wait till the timer cluster is
getting ready so I'll tell you what this
cluster is going to give you by default
to child and one parent so called a one
master and two
a child nodes where your cluster will
get ready
so you really don't need to set up any
kind of cluster in your local
environment and that is the best
environment I would suggest for most of
your development where your time reduce
there will be no software requirement
because sometimes version 2 version
changes
and you can get all the benefits of
clusters
so we're just waiting till the time the
cluster is getting ready so once the
cluster is ready you will be seeing some
options where
will help you to create the Clusters in
your upcoming demos
so friends your cluster is now ready you
can see now in this cluster you have got
this environment so in this environment
you will see there are some options they
have given you one by one build up your
cluster create a first database user add
an IP address multiple options they're
telling you now so how to set up so the
first build of the cluster which we have
anyways done next is called create your
first database user so select this
so it will highlight this area now you
can say like database access
and I'm going to create a first new
database user and new database user
during the username for admin let's keep
very simple username and password admin
one two three so admin admin123
yeah same and say add user
now I can see the user is created now
let's go back to the next option it's
telling me the network access now go
here and say sorry
now see add IP address
and I'll see allow access from anywhere
so that I can take it from anywhere I
say confirm
now it is telling me about a progress I
select this
and tell me about which type of
collections you want
okay so I select this
and inside this I'll be selecting this
call collections
okay and uh it's getting
ready
so it is doing with some options
well two options that will give you load
sample data set add my own data I'll say
add my own data give the database name
SL demo give the collection name EMP or
employee
remember database name SL demo or I can
better give the name called sldb
sldb and employee I say create
that is getting ready
okay so my database and table is ready
that's it so I think
we are all set
with this environment
okay well once it is ready your
collection is also ready I'll go back
and click on my
project zero
and here
yeah so once it is there then I'll be
clicking on this option called
connect
now it will give me the multiple options
how to connect so it will say correct so
the [ __ ] shell or it will say connect
with your application correct using
[ __ ] compass
I'll select
the python
python version 3.11 or later so
certainly I'll be using those version
only
okay and in this I'm having this
so I'll be using this to connect with my
backend
so that's how exactly you have
the setup of mongodb cluster driven so
we are all ready now with our
setup
cluster we have already created earlier
if you remember about we have taken
python 3.11 or later so here if I just
group I can check I have a code
3.8.5 which is Python 3 version which is
available so you can select based on
whichever we have it let's see 3.11 or
later we can say three point
six or later so there'll be no much
difference if I just see even if I just
talk about 0. so there's some change but
here 3.6 or later it is same so I have a
3.8.5
Okay so
I can use the same option so here in my
vscore editor I am using for my
development so here's a simple demo.pi I
have used welcome to check if it is
working fine so yes it is working fine
I'll start working with my first program
with mongodb so I just go back and say
uh demo
py or I can say uh
p y
demo Dot py
okay and here if I want to go back and
start working on the development
remember one thing we need first
dependency called Pi [ __ ]
okay what I need by [ __ ] and for this
we have already installed this
dependency here sometime back this is
how you get installed
okay so we have this statement name
called what pip installed by Momo
that is the first dependency which you
need to download in order to work with
this
Okay so
that's what we have taken this installed
by [ __ ] so if you just see you can go
back and start developing this statement
okay so let's go back and start working
on this step number one you need to
always say import
number one the one dependence which
you've installed is called by [ __ ]
so I can just say pymon go
that is the dependency we have recently
imported
from
okay let me go back and search from next
point so import buy [ __ ]
from
here we are saying by [ __ ]
okay five [ __ ]
and we're also saying import
ant
that's the first thing we need to
remember
okay after that we would like to go back
and use the cluster
so we say cluster
equal to
[ __ ] client and here I'll be passing
the complete values the one which we
have taken
so this complete line
I just take it
go back
and here
I'm pasting it
now here I have to basically replace
this password with admin123
okay and we are all set
okay now
once it is ready we can go ahead and
Define DB equal to
cluster
and provide which database you're
talking about
okay so you remember about we had a
database which was available to us that
is known as call sldb so I can just use
the same sldp there and accordingly I
can use which collection I am correcting
it to so accordingly I can go back and
insert a record okay everybody so I can
see I have got this
file with me going forward I have to
tell see this is what exactly the
connection URL you've received now if
you define which database you're working
on let me say TP equal to
cluster and we have to provide n
double quotes the database name called
sltp if you remember we have used this
after that we have to mention which
collection it was so
collection
equal to DB and here we just give the
name called employee
proposable collection name
so once it is ready then I have to
basically perform some insert operation
so I just say post
okay it's just a name equal to and here
we just provide the properties
like I would say name so
do you know it to the Json based
database so I can just use the name I
say
and once again I can just say
email
and
say
I will enter the email.com
that's it so this is just the data which
I have now I want to insert so I can
certainly say collection dot because I
want to insert only one record you can
see I have one functions coming up
collections.insert1 and plus
post
isn't parameter now we are all done
let's try to run this
so I'll be running this with Python 3 PV
mode demo Dot py
editor
now it's done let's confirm here into my
code I will just go back and check here
inside my
applications I can just go back to my
collections
and in employee
yeah there we go we have got some
records coming up here
okay so these records are nothing but
the one which we have recently inserted
in our application
okay so fantastic so first example is
working perfectly fine how we can have
the records coming from the python and
insert it there like that I can have as
many number of Records I can add it so
how we can basically add if I want to
add more than one records
let's see this now here in increase if I
want to add more than one records so I
can just use compost one if I copy this
URL and paste it below and I say post to
I say
MLG email I might want to at the
redmill.com and rather let's say insert
one I can use insert many and inside
this I'll be using this square brackets
and pass
post
post one or not
close to
that's it
okay so let's change the little name
because it's already there let's insert
yep records are inserted let me verify
once again
by refreshing it
but now we have a total number of three
records are available
yeah there we go the records are added
perfect so like this you can have as
many number of Records you can basically
add it in a similar one The Way We have
basically used this I can also perform
the search part too
okay so in case if you want to perform
the search part we have a very simple
statement available with us what I'll go
here
the way we have added this so
in this I'll just
these records which are added inside my
application I would not execute this
rather
I would like to go back and say
no they are basically commented now and
in fact I would like to use this also
okay I'll go here and
find results
equal to
same collection
dot find if I want to find a name we can
just use
curly braces
name
colon
number two
okay so let me say print
and plus
results
okay let's run this
okay so it will print what the results
follow me
okay so it is just printing what the
cursor object for me saying like hey
this is what the record is available to
me we can also change in case if you do
not think the correct result is coming
up we can also go back and uh
we can use a alternative option that is
called for
okay so what we can do let's take a look
here
we can use for
which is for vacancy result
okay in
other words and print this result
that could be one option through which
you can get the details with you
okay so what you can do you can run this
code again
oh I forgot about this semicolon here
or
build a check
well that was my requirement was so I'm
having this let's try to run this
when I got my result and this is what I
detected which I have available to me so
very simple how you can basically find a
record and how you can basically
retrieve the records at the same time if
you want to have this specific field
rather than all the fields so here in my
code can this result
okay you can just put a square bracket
and tell which field you really want it
now suppose if you just want ID or else
if you want a name you can basically
pick that up
okay so if I just want that ID
like only ID is printed that's it
okay everyone so you have seen like in
my previous code how we were basically
trying to fetch all the records we were
using this fine now in a similar light
you can also have the option available
because see when we used to talk about
confine it gets me a lot many records
fine and because of that we were using
this Loop but in case if you want to
fetch the individual records
I'll be clear so in such cases you
really do not want to use file
you can just use find one so what you
can do is rather than using find I can
also use one more option called
find one and for which
I can come back just to note this all
yeah so here in this case rather than
using this file I can use file
underscore you can see this option
called find one
here we talk about
which are the properties you'd want to
escape and which are the properties you
want so I can just use this option
called underscore
idle
okay cool
zero okay I just removed this
underscore ID 0 and here I just print
what results
that's it let's run
foreign
try to fetch some of the records for you
because if you do not have that ID which
you've overrated it will certainly not
found that depends on what you would
like to take so if I just say
is having some issues but no problem but
you know it very well how it basically
takes
now in a similar line we would like to
also perform one more activity to talk
about delete so for which what I will do
is this I just want to uncomment it
foreign
by my own with name so we already have
this name
email I have it I would like to use
underscore ID
okay
so
we have this property called underscore
ID
colon
one zero one
okay
comma like this
copy the same
using it here
and this time
I'm using one zero two
name and everything
it will be taken let me say
user one
here we try to say user 2.
okay so collections dot many result find
one I'm just deleting it all
and let's try to
execute it first
okay so it's executed going back
okay so I have some records with ID 101
and one zero two
now here
I just delete this and perform some
actions here here we say results
equal to
collection Dot
delete so the options are available
delete one and delete money it totally
depends on what you really want
okay so if I just talk about call delete
one it will be only deleting one record
delete many means where are the matching
records are available you deleted
fine so I'm just using this option
called delete many
okay wherever the property names are
matched quite possible names sometimes
match or whatever it is first day delete
many so the option is up to you now how
you want so the selected name you have
to offer it
whether you want to match it with the
name or whether you want to match it
with the email or whatever it is so that
will be offering me but there's also one
option available where you would like to
delete everything
are we clear so if you're planning to
delete it everything what you can do you
can just leave it as a blank and try to
run this
so collection
dot delete underscore many
let's check
great all records are deleted
so as I've told you earlier also so
delete many means what it will delete
all the records whichever I present in
your code now
clear in a similar one if I want to
perform insert if you remember about
your option called what
insert menu and here
you would like to pass
post one
post Loop let's execute
so it'll add
the records inside this
okay and next time what I want to
perform after adding this record I would
like to perform the update part
okay so what I really wanted my update
let's take a look update means certain
properties I'm looking forward to pick
it updated
okay so in case if I want to check
whether record has to be updated I would
first go and check
whether the record does exist or not
yeah we have two names user one and user
two let's go back and update bar
here
I just say collections
okay dot
update one
update you can see update one here very
simple functionality here we will go
and tell which ID would like to perform
an update so I say underscore ID
column
which ID you want to consider I'm saying
101
okay and what else so I just use another
curriculum basis and I say
sorry dollar
set
and after this
I use this colon use the curly braces
the name
okay and use whatever you want to use it
so suppose this is the user one I'm
saying use it one two three
okay let's see
it is loading and you can see the record
user 150 is updated
perfect so
your code is absolutely working fine so
we talk about either insert you talk
about what update you talk about
anything it works so insert update one
delete one insert one as the name
suggests they'd be taking care about
inserting updating and deleting one one
records but the moment you use many
you'll be performing multiple records so
this is very simple way like how the
python will connect with your Moco TV in
this video we're going to learn about
the differences between MySQL and
mongodb
now I'm sure you must have heard about
these database Management systems but do
you exactly know what set them apart
don't worry I'll help you in this video
first let's look at what exactly is
mongodb
now as you all know mongodb is an open
source document oriented nosql database
it is document based which means that
the data stored is represented in a
hierarchical relationship using a single
record
and also mongodb is schema free which
means there's no set schema to Define
how the data is being stored in the
database this causes lesser data
migrations but what exactly is MySQL
then
now MySQL is an open source relational
database management system unlike
mongodb which is document oriented MySQL
is a relational database system now this
uses something called as a structured
query language and this is used to
access data which is stored in the form
of rows and columns
now as mentioned earlier data here is
stored in the form of tables with rows
and columns and each data field comes
with an index representing the data in
the table
and SQL is developed and maintained by
Oracle
so then what exactly sets them apart so
in the coming section we look at some of
the differences between MySQL and
mongodb depending on certain features
first up is the data structure
now MySQL requires you to Define your
tables and columns before you can store
anything and every row in a table must
have the same columns
in mongodb you just drop the data in
these documents also the data and the
mongodb database is stored in a binary
format called as bson next up we have
schema now as discussed earlier MySQL
requires a set schema to define the
tables in the database now the database
administrator is requested to define a
schema which defines how the different
tables are being stored in the database
now this schema is crucial in case of
MySQL on the other hand mongodb doesn't
require a prior definition of a schema
next up is languages
MySQL uses the structured query language
to perform actions on the database it is
used to retrieve data add data update
create a new data set Etc in case of
mongodb it supports the Json query
language to work with data next up is
foreign keys now MySQL supports the
usage of foreign Keys now if you don't
know what exactly a foreign key is then
SQL uses foreign keys to link one table
to another now these foreign Keys make
data retrieval easy especially when
there are multiple tables interlinked
with one another in case of mongodb
there's no support for foreign keys
next up is replication now MySQL
supports the Master Slave and the master
master application in this setup data
set from one master database server can
be copied to other servers
in case of mongodb
it uses something called a sharding now
sharding allows partitioning of data
across multiple servers using a Shard
key don't worry if you're not able to
understand these Concepts well in the
coming videos we'll explain these
Concepts in detail
next up is scalability now SQL database
can be scaled vertically while mongodb
can be scaled both vertically and
horizontally now horizontal scaling
means scaling by adding more machines to
your pool of resources while vertical
scaling refers to scaling by adding more
power like for example CPU or Ram moving
ahead let's look at performance now
MySQL is optimized for high performance
joins across multiple tables while
mongodb is optimized for write
performance
talking about Community Support some of
the popular GitHub repositories on MySQL
currently are MySQL JS MySQL and then
there's MySQL server and at the time of
writing there were about 222
000 repositories on GitHub with 7
million comments for MySQL in case of
mongodb a few popular GitHub
repositories are mongodb [ __ ] and
Doctrine mongodb and at the time of
writing there were about 177 000
repositories with about 923 000 comments
according to Google Trends MySQL is
largely used compared to mongodb
so now the question arises which one
should you choose
well if your application requires
multi-road transactions like for example
in accounting system then a relational
database would be more ideal
but if you're using mongodb then it is
more suitable for real-time analytics
content management Internet of Things
mobile applications and so on also MySQL
is a great choice if you have structured
data and need a traditional relational
database
in case of mongodb it is an ideal choice
if you have an unstructured set of data
so you could pick your choice and if
you're partial towards one dbms let us
know in the comment section below as to
why you like that particular dbms
node.js is a file JavaScript runtime
environment but it does not support
request handling functions HTTP methods
or serving files so express.js comes
into the picture Express makes the
node.js code easier as Express provides
a wide range of features to develop both
web and mobile applications it is used
to build single page multi-page and
hybrid page web applications as Express
is written in JavaScript it is very easy
to understand for the developers who
know JavaScript until now Express is the
most popular framework of node.js
you must have heard about mean stack in
web development right where e stands for
express.js
it is a back-end part of main stack it
manages routing HTTP methods sessions
error handling Etc
let's see what express.js is
express.js is a node.js framework
designed to build apis web applications
cross platform mobile apps quickly and
easily
it is very high performance fast
lightweight and unopeniated that is
there is no structural way to write a
code Xbox does not force you to write a
code in a fixed manner
express.js is used as a server-side
scripting language
let's see the need for express.js but
before that let me give you an example
if you have to write a rest API using
the core modules of node.js and the same
using the framework express.js you will
realize that with the help of express it
will take 5 to 10 times less code and
time
that was the reason behind creating
express.js framework for node.js
express.js is time efficient fast money
efficient very easy to learn and
asynchronous let's see the features of
express.js for server-side development
with the features of node.js XP saves a
lot of time middleware middleware is a
request Handler that has access to the
application's request response cycle
routing this refers to how an
application's endpoints URLs respond to
client requests
templating
it provides templating engines to build
Dynamic content on the web pages by
creating HTML templates on the server
debugging Express makes it easier as it
identifies the exact part where bugs are
let's see the advantages of express.js
Express is unopeniated and we can
customize it and use it as per our needs
as it is written in JavaScript a single
language is used for front-end back-end
development Express is fast to link it
with databases like MySQL mongodb Etc
let's see the disadvantages the
disadvantage of express.js is that there
is no structural way to organize things
sometimes the code becomes
non-understandable
there are so many issues with callbacks
the error messages that will come are
very challenging to understand
now we'll see the companies that are
using express.js the major companies are
IBM Uber eBay PayPal essential Fox
Sports Netflix LinkedIn
as per the nlib.com there are more than
34 300 companies that are using
express.js
now I think you guys have a brief idea
about Express as it is a lightweight
framework that gives functionalities to
make node.js easy
express.js is trending so much because
it is helping so many developers to save
their time it is so awesome that most of
the companies are moving towards it
if you know JavaScript and node.js the
framework explains what you should know
to strengthen your coding skills
now here
you'll find downloads
you can download node from here
and install it but if you find any
difficulties downloading node.js you can
click on the link in the right corner to
see how to download node.js
now let's see the version for node to
verify here I am using visual studio
code you can go and search it and simply
download vs code
after opening your Visual Studio code
will look like this
here
you will find a terminal click on it
the terminal window will open
here we will write node
hyphen B
this will show us the latest version of
node.js
now we need to update the npm which is
node packet manager this bundle consists
of all the repositories and packages
required for development purposes to do
that npm install npm globally
NVM installed
PM hyphen
globally
this will download all the npm packages
globally now let's create Express for
that first we need to create a separate
folder where we will keep all the
modules and files of express.js
let's claim this TLS
you can open the terminal by clicking on
the shortcut also by pressing Ctrl and
back tag that will open the terminal for
you
let's make a folder mkdir
this is a command that is used to create
a folder on the terminal then we will
write our file name I will write Express
by
simply learn
enter
here you can see the file name expressed
by simply learn has been created
you can also click here
and enter your file name
m.js
press enter
as you can see a new file has been
created
now we need to install a package manager
that is npm we will write a npm command
open your terminal again
write a command
npm
in it
enter
enter version enter description and
description you can write Express
tutorial
bye
simply on enter
key repository if you have your git
repository you can add yours enter
enter author
relearn
license enter
press yes
after this
you can see npm created a Json file
now we will finally install express.js
we will write npm
install
Express
enter
now as you can see our Express is
installed in our system
let's open the app.js that we have
created earlier
now we will create a express application
with the help of Express functions that
we can do by requiring the express
modules let's create a first program
first
constant
press
require
Express
in this line we are requiring the
express module
const
a name equals to function
Express
dot get
to get the file
request response
to get the request and the response
of the user
machine
we will need to pass callback function
here
let's write
response send
this message will be shown
in the server welcome
to
2 will come to Simply learn
now here
we will write a port number where the
message will be shown to us add dot
lesson
4000 you can write anything
here also we are passing the Callback
function
and soul
DOT log in control log we will see the
message in the console
listening to Port
number
four thousand
and close this line
save this
let's run it open your terminal new
terminal
now to run this file
we need to go to the express
folder
CD
Express
by simply learn
we are now in a simply learn folder
now the easiest way is to write the file
name write node
space the file name app.js
enter
now you can see it is printing our
message listening to Port 4000 now we
will see a message on the server
open your Chrome
type localhost 4000
press enter
and here we go a message is successfully
displayed welcome to Simply learn
get in post method are the standard HTTP
request used to create traced apis
get in post methods are used to send and
receive significant amount of data
the client sends a request in the form
of Json file and with the help of HTTP
requests which are get post and other
methods it will go to the server and
then the server sends back the response
to the client in the form of a message
to tell what happened to the request
that was sent to the server
now
Express JS get method
get is a method that is used to request
data from the server but mainly this
method is used to read data
to handle get request in Express is
pretty straightforward
get requests are to be cached and
remains in the browser history and
that's why the get method is not used
for sensitive data
to get the data we add parameters in the
URL and get data in response get method
is more efficient and popular than the
post method
now we'll see express.js post method
post method is used to create new or to
edit already existing data this method
is used to communicate with large amount
of data
the post method is secure because the
data is passed in a request body and not
visible in the URL and the user is not
able to bookmark it mostly we use get
method only but when we want to send a
sensitive data we use post method
now we will see how to get the post and
get methods work
now open your Visual Studio code
I have already installed node and
express if you haven't installed it then
you can click on the right corner of
this video to get the setup done
coming back to express get and post
methods
now what I have done here is I have
created a basic express.js app
const app require Express this will
install all our Express modules
now first we will write our gate method
so let's start
first we will write get method
then we will initialize how it will be
called will write get
this Quest
create a constant request parameters
requests and response
then we'll write the fat Arrow function
this
we will send a response
server
hello
this it is
full
okay
that's I have not initialized the
brackets
let's see what I have not done oh
God to write this
now let's just save this file
we will run this file open your terminal
and write node
Dot
and
I think I have done something wrong
let's again open the Domino
right node
Dot so it is showing server is
successfully running on Port 4000.
now we'll open our Chrome and write
localhost
enter
as I have told you earlier this needs a
parameter so we'll initialize here
get request
hello this is successful get request
so a request method is working fine
now
we'll go back to the post method and see
how it Rose
app dot post
request
foreign
just like this only
just
post
hello
this is
successful
first
first
he now will run save this first and then
run it in the terminal
yes node
dot server is running out four thousand
we have to write this so first copy from
here only
open your terminal and here we can write
ghost Quest enter
so what you can see here is it can't get
post request
for this to see we need to have the
postman I'm using Postman here
I will write post method
and here I will write the
localhost 4000 and the post request
method then we'll press send
okay
head
in the body part
we will see hello this is successful
post request
how this is working is because post
method is secure and data is passed in
the request body and it cannot be
fetched in the URL
what is middleware middleware is a
request Handler that has access to the
applications request response cycle it
is a function that contains the request
subjects response object and the next
middleware function
middleware can also send the response to
the server before the request
the next middleware function is commonly
donated by the variable named next
simply middleware is a function that can
only be applied using routers with the
help of middleware we can access and
modify requests and response
now we will see what are the functions
of middleware middleware can execute any
code
it can make changes to the request
response objects
middleware can also end the request
response cycle
it can call the next middleware function
in the stack
we use these functions to modify our
middleware to perform many tasks like if
you want to block our site from some
country or if you want to check the
authentication of a user
Etc choose from over 300 in-demand
skills and get access to 1000 plus hours
of video content for free visit skillup
by simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
now we are going to create a simple
middleware
we can create a middleware in a router
file but the best way is to create a
middleware file separately and then use
it creating and using middleware is very
easy
now we first need to create a basic
express application but before that you
must have all the app packages to run
Express
you can take the help of our video what
is express.js the link will be in the
description
you need to install npm Express to run
this so coming back to our application
first we need
const
express application
so we'll write constant
Express
required
Express
now we'll write constant app
equals to express
function
now to get the data we'll write app Dot
get
request
response
response
function
right response and
welcome to
simpler
now I will copy paste this
to get the home page the better ways to
like
copy pasted
here
here we'll write the extension of the
next page
home will say
and welcome to this villains
this is a very basic middleware
application we are going to create
list
home page
now we'll make it listen to some Port so
we'll write
Dot listen
to Port will say report
four thousand
again that Arrow function
control
log
right listening
this message will be prompting to us on
the control determinant
so we'll close these brackets
foreign
open your terminal
first we need to go to this folder CD
Express
by
run
enter
now we'll write
file name
app called okay Enter
so it's showing
listening to Port 4000
now we'll open our Chrome
local server
type localhost 4000 and
so it is successfully showing us welcome
to Simply learn now we'll go to the next
page we have written their home
enter
so it's successfully showing welcome to
Simply learns homepage
now
we'll create a middleware go back to
that file
we'll write
strength
required filter
request you can write anything here
request object
spawn subject
and next
in the fat Arrow function
foreign
block
app
we have written request
we'll use this
by writing
app dot use
okay
request
filter
once you've displayed
now
we haven't
called our next parameter in Express
framework next is a function
what we'll do is we'll call it in the
bottom of our middleware
will write next
question
save this file
again we'll open a new terminal
where we'll go to the part folder
Express
by simply run
enter
like node the file name I have got here
enter
now I'll open our file go to the
home
right localhost 4000 enter
where it is printing welcome to Simply
learn we'll go to the home page
slash okay welcome to Simply learns
homepage with this we have successfully
reached the end of this video
npm which is called as node package
manager is node.js built in package
manager by default and express.js is a
framework of node.js which is fully
built in JavaScript
it was first made and available for use
in January 12 2010.
let's move on to what is npm
let's take async as an example npm is
incredibly easy to use and all you need
to do is to type npm install async to
install the desired module in the
current directory under node module
folder you may use neat function on them
as they use build-ins once installed in
your node modules folder
the biggest software registry in the
world is npm there are more than 80 lakh
code packages in the registry to share
software open source developers utilize
npm npm is often used by businesses to
control private growth
all of the node.js packages and modules
are managed through npm which also
includes the npm command line client
along with the installation of node.js
it is added to the system npm is used to
install the necessary modules and
packages in the node project
moving ahead let's see what is a package
in node.js a package includes every file
required for a module
you can add module in a JavaScript
libraries to your project
now let's see the functions of node
package manager which is npm
online node.js packages modules
repositories can be searched on
node.js.org
use a command line tool to manage
node.js packages dependencies Version
Control and installation
now let's see how to install npm
to install node package manager we have
to install node.js for that you have to
download node.js and install it in your
system
now we will see the version of node.js
go to terminal new terminal
and search here
for
node hyphen V which is denoted as
version enter and this is my version of
node
now we will verify the npm version to do
that we have to run a command
write npm hyphen hyphen version
and you can clearly see my npm version
is 8.5.3
now we will see how we can install node
modules using npm this is a very simple
Syntax for that we just have to write
npm install and that module name
now we will install the famous web
framework module of node.js we will
simply write a command
npm
install
Express
this is a very simple command you can
write in your console or terminal and
then press enter
you can clearly see
the express is installed in our system
what is error handling
array handling is a process in which
express catches and processes the error
that occurs synchronously and
asynchronously
Express comes with its own default error
handlers
simply in error handling the tasks are
to identify errors report them to the
users and then develop some recovery
strategies and Implement them to handle
the errors
this whole process should not slow the
overall processing time of the program
now
how does error handling Works in
express.js
express.js comes in with a built-in
error Handler this default error
handling middleware function is added at
the end of the middleware function stack
it automatically catches all errors in
router handlers and allow developers to
extend router handling functionalities
by middleware function error handling in
Express is done using middleware this
middleware is defined in the same way as
other middleware functions the error
handling functions have four arguments
error request response and next
we have next function method that
matches us to the next middleware
Handler in middleware
in error handling we have the next error
method this function skips all
middleware and matches us to the next
error Handler for the router now let's
set up our error and Link with Express
open your Visual Studio code choose from
over 300 in-demand skills and get access
to 1000 plus hours of video content for
free visit skillup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to know
more first we will create a new
directory
for that
open your terminal
new terminal
let's try it
make directory
now I will enter the directory name I
will write
simply learn
or you can also write
error
press enter
you can see the errored and Link
directory has been created it's empty
let's go inside that CD
L handling
now we are in the link folder
now let's create a new project here
we'll write npm
in it
hash
by
so as you can see
the Json file has been created in the
error handling folder
now
we will install couple of packages here
okay
first we will install Express right npm
install
s
now we will also install Morgan
which locks the request
uh after that we'll also install HTTP
errors
errors this package makes it very easy
to check the status code
and then last
we will install node dot EnV
press enter
this will take couple of seconds
now in the dependencies
you can see dot EnV Express HTTP errors
and Morgan
now I will create a file in this error
handling folder
right app dot JS enter
now let's install node bond which helps
us not to reset our file again and again
for that we'll write in that
npm
install
is minus sign save
don't come on
enter
this will also take couple of seconds
now
here you can see
the node one has been successfully
installed
now open your package.json files
here
in packet.json file
you can see here
this line
I will rewrite this
you can also remove it let's write
script
and in this
I will write
note
tab dot JS yes
save this file by pressing Ctrl s
yes
now open the file
app.js
here we will be importing some packages
in node.js we use require function right
so we'll write const
Express
required
and
Express
here we need Express packages
now we will be needing Morgan
we will write const
ant
require
D
him
what are you doing
now like this we will need HTTP packages
const
error
create
error
required
history DB
errors
we also need dot EnV packages to import
our environment variables for that we
will simply write required
choir
tactic
Dot
EnV
Dot
and fake
for this command we need a EnV file we
will create a file
dot EMV
entor
and here we have our EnV file where we
can have our environment variables
first we want a port for this
application so we will write the port
four
three thousand
save this file
now again go back to the app.js file
here
first we will be initializing our app
will write cons
app
Express function
now we will start the application for
this we will write
const
port
to which it will be called process
dot EnV Dot
port
3000
foreign
listen to Port 3000 we will write
tab Dot listen
port number
port
it will call the port number
and here
we will call the Callback function
header function
and here we will make a block statement
for this we'll write console
DOT log
tag
server
I mean
on
import
installer sign
and
hold
now let me start the application before
that we'll save this file
now to start the application we'll write
npm
start
enter
here it is showing error let's find out
okay
here
I have wrote script
here we need to write start
save this file
and now clear this screen
enter npm
okay
so as you can see it is successfully
running in the port 3000 rest API are
the standard way to send and receive
data for web services
client sends a request which goes to the
rest API then to the database
to get or put the data after that it
will come back to the rest API and then
to the client
using an API is just like using a
website in a browser but instead
clicking on the buttons we write code to
request data from the server
it is very flexible and can handle
multiple types of requests
restful API is very popular and very
commonly used to create apis for
web-based applications
what is express.js
express.js is a node.js framework
designed to build apis web applications
and cross-platform mobile applications
it is used as a server-side scripting
language
express.js is high performance fast
lightweight and unopeniated
we'll see what is rest API but before
that what is rest and what is API
rest means representational State
transfer rest is a popular architecture
which is used to create web services
Now API is a application programming
interface it is a code that allows two
software programs to communicate with
each other
rest API is a software that allows two
applications to communicate with each
other with the help of internet and
various devices now
we will see the HTTP request types first
one is get it is used to request data
from the server but mainly this method
is used to read data
next one is pack it is used to update
the data or to change or replace it next
is post
method is used to create new or to edit
already existing data after that it is
delete
delete method is used to delete the data
completely from the server
now we will see the complete
architecture of HTTP request type in
this client sends a request in the form
of Json file
and with the help of HTTP request which
are get patch post and delete it will go
to the server
and then sends back the response to the
client in the form of message
to tell what happened to the request
and now we will create a simple restful
API from scratch
choose from over 300 in-demand skills
and get access to 1 000 Plus hours of
video content for free visit skillup by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
first you need to open your editor for
this I'm using vs code
for this
you need to open your folder
created one folder in the
C drive foreign
you need to have node.js installed
first open your terminal by clicking on
Terminal New terminal
first we'll write npm
in it
hyphen y
press enter
this will create a Json file
for us
now let's install express.js
for that
will write in pm
install
Express
press enter
is installing express.js
this will add
all the dependencies
for now we have only one Express
installed
we need a file here
to write our code
so we'll create a file called index
dot JS enter
in this file we will write all our code
when index.js Js
first we'll write cons up
where
Express
in this line we have imported the
Express package
which itself is a function
so we'll write parentheses here
to initialize it
now
we will write
foreign
this will call a variable
which is four thousand
I will write a dot let's see
till now our API hasn't defined any
endpoints
this app Dot listen tells the server to
listen on specific Port which we have
defined already as a variable
4000.
now
in app Dot listen we will write a second
argument as call back to tell us the API
is working or not
then we'll write
port
comma
we'll write the Callback function here
function
console
Dot log
take
it's
running
on
http
closed
localhost
all this time
and
both
which will come under curly red space
now we can run this app by writing the
command on a terminal
so save this file
terminal
now we'll write the command to run this
file
index node
file name index Dot
Js
so it's successfully showing us it's
running on HTTP port
four thousand
Oaks in the world Chrome or anything
I'm using Chrome here I'll write
localhost
4000
enter
closed enter
can't get
now
if you open this URL you will see
this message
can't get this is because we don't have
any API endpoints as of now
but express.js is still responsing with
error message
you can add an API and call it
every application consists of front-end
backend and the database together they
form full start and in this video we
will be talking about react and
express.js
react was created by meta and it is used
to make web application responsive
express.js is unobedientated and it is
used to make apis Express is maintained
by node.js
let's see what is react.js
react is a JavaScript library which is
used to build mobile and web
applications fast and Interactive
it is an open source reusable components
based front-end library of JavaScript
basically with the help of react we can
create a client-side application or user
interface
it is a combination of HTML and
JavaScript
let's see the features of react.js
first jsx
it is a syntax extension of JavaScript
with the help of react.js we can use the
extension to see how the UI should look
like
virtual document object model Dom it
defines how documentar accessed and
manipulated in the web page
performance there are several ways to
speed up your regret application by
using virtual Dom
one-way data binding information Flows
In One Direction react receive
information through arguments and pass
it by returning values
react goes beyond simple UI and has many
extensions for complete application
support extended with flux and Redux
among others
debugging it is a small browser
extension to make debugging easier and
faster let's see what is expressed Js
Express the node.js framework designed
to build apis web applications closed
platform mobile apps quickly and easily
it is very high performance fast
lightweight and unopeniated express.js
is used as a service head scripting
language
let's see the features of express.js
first server side development with the
features of node.js Express saves a lot
of time
middleware middleware is a request
Handler that has access to the
application request response cycle
shouting
this refers to how an applications
endpoint URLs respond to client requests
templating
it provides templating engines to build
Dynamic content on the web pages by
creating HTML templates on the server
debugging Express makes it easier as it
identifies the exact part where bugs are
now we'll see how to connect client-side
to the server side first we need to
create a folder I have created a folder
named react Express
let's see go to your save file
here I have created react Express folder
now we will be using a text editor in
this video I will be using visual studio
code let's open it
then
we will add all the npm packages and
create a react application called client
open Terminal
new terminal
let's write some command nbx
8
react
app
line
enter
this will take some time
until then just wait
yes so it's downloaded
now as you can see the client folder has
been created
foreign
files
in this client folder you will see all
the npm files known modules
Json file also
yeah
now
we'll go to this folder
CB
client
now to get this application running type
npm
that
and
this command will start and compile this
application now it has opened a web page
localhost 3000
this is the first client-side
application startup page
this will be now working as a client
now let's create a backend application
for that first
clean this terminal
let's open a new terminal
type
npx
Express
engine
data
folder name
press enter okay
now this will take some time to install
press yes why
as you can see a API folder has been
created
now we'll go to that API folder see the
API enter
now we are in the API folder
let's install
all the packages in pm
install
press enter
this will again download all the
packages
so npm has installed all the packages
required to run this as you can see in
the packages.json file there are all the
repositories and files that I used
now let's terminate this terminal
terminal
now let's go to the client folder
CD
client
press enter
now we are in the client folder
npm
this command will start and compile this
application
now we'll see the standard express
application that has got installed will
again go to the terminal
delete this terminal
create a new terminal
in this we'll go to the API folder
npm start
we will start the terminal
press enter
now
we'll go to the Chrome
localhost 3000 very fresh and
you will see the standard express
application that has got installed
what is typescript typescript is an
object oriented programming language it
is a strongly typed superset of
JavaScript and all the code of
typescript is compiled with JavaScript
only
it is developed and maintained by
Microsoft
typescript was created to develop large
applications
it is mainly used to simplify the
JavaScript code so that it can be read
and debug easily
what is node J
no chase is an open source cross
platform JavaScript runtime environment
and it runs on a web application outside
the client browser node.js is used by
the developers to build server-side web
application
notice is perfect for data intensive
applications since it uses an
asynchronous event driven model
what is express.js
express.js is a node.js framework
designed to build apis web applications
cross-platform mobile apps quickly and
easily
expressjs is unopeniated
it is high performance fast lightweight
framework of node.js express.js makes
the node.js code easy as it is used as a
server-side scripting language now we'll
see how to set up node with Express and
typescript open your Visual Studio code
new folder which I have created in the C
drive typescript
it's an empty folder I'll show you
open the terminal
I'll show you if it is empty LS
both folder is empty
now
we'll make a project inside it
will simply write npm
in it iPhone y for all the default
values
press enter
so you have seen the package.json file
has been installed in this package
it's clearance
now the first thing you need to install
is typescript type npm
at the end
to D
this will install the typescript
dependencies
now I will install two more dependencies
please write npm
I
test elephant node
I will also install nodemon
enter
this will install all the dependencies
there will be need in this project
let's clear the screen
now
now we have to install Express
npm
install Express
let's wait for a couple of seconds the
npm express has been created
open the package or Json file here you
see
all the dev dependencies
Express
Norman and TS node
has been successfully installed
now we need to create a project inside
this folder for that we need to write
npx
yeah a heaven in it
wait for a couple of seconds here we go
here the screen
now we'll execute npx
ESC hyphen
and it
so it has already been here
you can see
yeah
now we will be creating a source folder
for that
right mpdir
C
enter this would be containing all our
typescript files here
you can see it's empty
let's create a file here
Dot
everything we will going to write is
inside this file only
so you set up for typescript with
Express in node is ready
you can write anything here
the first thing you need is node.js
let's see I have created one for me you
can create it by just entering a command
make directory in the terminal
and entering your folder name it can be
ABC or something you need and like this
it will be created but I don't need it
so I'm going to delete it
and this
I will open the terminal again
I'll write a command
npm
in it what
this will create a Json file for us
like as you can see here
the Json file has been created here
clear the screen
now we will install express.js in this
folder for that write a command in VM
install
Express
and press enter this will install
express.js for us
you can also see here in the
dependencies
Express has been successfully installed
and all the other modules are here
so let's clear this screen now
now we will create a server file here
let's name it app.js
here we'll write all our code
so let's create a simple Express folder
right
const
Express
required
keyword
all over
modules will be here
in this we are requiring express.js
now we will also be meeting
port
Al
processes
dot EnV
dot port number that we'll gonna write
here
I'm using port number 3000 you can write
anything
this will be a port number now
create an app
Express also
we have created an instance for express
now we'll create
to make it listen to our code
let's write app Dot listen
port number it will read by its own
data function
okay
control
but we are gonna see batik
server
started at http
localhost
dollar sign
to get the data of the port
and we'll write the code it will fetch
the number of the board
here it goes
now we have created a front end of this
I repeat now we will create a front end
of this registration form so let's
create it
first here
create a folder
public
in this folder
let's create two files index
dot HTML
and
uh
second one will name as style.css
now in the index folder
we'll write all our front-end code so
open
index.html page
right dog and enter this will create a
HTML template for you
in the title
yes
will write
registration
form
now in the body part
will write
heading for this
H1
right heading you just
have the action will be class
distribution
heading so we can style it afterwards
editing
now we'll create a form
function
okay
glass will be formed
now we'll create an input types first
we'll create input type will be
text
write first name
same
this folder
this username will become inside the
text box this first name
[Music]
now we'll create few more like this for
password
last name age number
let's copy this input
[Music]
first one will be first name second one
will be
last name
thank you
so we'll write the email
for this
this look good
okay we will write that email
will write password
placeholder
will write
bmd so no one will see our password this
will be an empty
let's try to do here
and we'll write
in the placeholder password
let's go to another one
and let's create a first name last name
email password and let's create one more
that will be a
page
for this we have to write here
number
and then we don't need name I guess
let's write this here
page
see inside the box in the front end okay
let's create this submit button
type of the button will this submit
so we can
give it styling
part
[Music]
so our form is ready
uh yeah
we'll write require here so
one will be left empty
this will help us to
to require every field because
everything is important
we cannot
make it empty so we are writing required
so
our HTML page is ready
here let's see how it looks open this
HTML page
yeah
a registration form look like this
let me show you what require is doing
as you can see please fill out this
field this is what required function do
submit
is
now coming back to vs code
will write some CSS code for styling
here we will write
padding for the page
will be zero
we don't have to write percent
margin
will also write 0 for the overall page
now we'll go to the
body part
so the
height will be 100
pH
weight will be
100 BH
display size will be
legs
in the direction of the flex will be
bottom
but
then just if I content will be in Center
alignment
items Center
this is how we will
create a body part
coming to the
form of the speech
from
right
everything will be a single copy this
paste it here
I don't want the height of the poem in
this much
it could be
let's create it for me
40 percent
width will be 100 only
this place legs will be here
direction or this will be column only
justify contents
let's see in the
to our code
let's make it not Center
let's make it as
this let's make it space between
you can style it as your own
as you want
heading
this play will be in line block
foreign
Page look
more pain
perform
okay input
foreign
[Music]
and put it okay
now we'll go to
let's do something with the button
button
it will be
padding will be
10 percent from this
but the other side
yes
it's gonna be
cool
color will look like this
it's not an issue
amazing
the summit button
uh
box
this will look cool
brown color
of the summit button will be flat
and the text which is inside it will be
White
so it looks clean as a
registration form
it's done
foreign
[Music]
look like this
isn't it cool
let's make this a little up
The Heading part will
your operating for
40 percent
your disease inside
go to the form and see yeah it looks
good now
let's see everything is working fine
yeah
coming back to our vs code
now
so our front part is ready if there will
be any changes we'll do it later now
coming back to our backend part
of this registration form we'll make our
first API routes
foreign
request
response
the other function
that's right here the response that the
form will send
we will write the directory name
of this HD
mean is a Java
see
padding will be
10 percent from this
and 25 from the other side
yes
two
people from school
color for this
Pro
color will look like this
it's not an issue
using
the summit button
uh
using the Border
box
this will look cool
Crown color
of the summit button will be flat
and the text which is inside it will be
right
so it looks clean as a
registration form
it's done
you can also
save this file go to through file
a registration form look like this
isn't it cool
let's make this a little up
The Heading fire drill
your operating for 40 percent
Style
go to the form and see yeah it looks
good now
let's see everything is working fine
yeah
coming back to our vs code
now
so our front part is ready if there will
be any changes we'll do it later now
coming back to our backend part
of this registration count will make our
first API routes
here
dot get
um
foreign
request
response
the other function
let's write here the response that the
form will send
in the directory name
on this HTML file
it's right here
let it rename
because
public
x dot game
let's save it
going back to our
68 post method also here
from post
and response
will be here
foreign
here in this part it will face the data
in the body of the HTML page
now
let's create an API middleware
that
effect
news
press dot Json
computation here we are accepting the
data in Json format
after this we will use it again
I've got use
Express
dot URL encoded
function
this is basically to decode the data
sent through HTML form
Dot View again
this will Express
dot we will write static
starting function will be public folder
public
this will use the public folder for us
now
will save this file first
open your HTML file
and write in the form part
itions
here
[Music]
will declare the file name app.js
from
class form
and we'll write method which will be
closed here
everything looks good we forgot to write
inverted commas here
save this file
now open the terminal
and write node
app dot Js
press enter
so our code is running fine let's open
it
yeah
everything looks fine
angular
angular it is written in two HTML
documents enabling interactions with web
pages in many unique ways
so as a relatively easy to learn
language with almost pervasive support
it is exceptionally well suited to
develop modern applications
but the question arises
is Javascript ideal for developing
single page applications that require
modularity testability and other
features perhaps not however we have a
variety of Frameworks and libraries
designed to help us with such thing with
respect to front-end development angular
and JavaScript together bring in
structure and consistency to your web
applications and also provide
scalability and maintainability
angular is specifically developed for
single page applications so now the
question arises what exactly is angular
angle angular is an
old JavaScript framework written
completely in typescript
now it was primarily aimed to develop
single page applications and is
maintained by Google
angular as a framework provides a few
advantages while also providing a
standard structure for Developers
designed for web desktop and mobile
platforms if you have a doubt here as to
what exactly single page applications
are let me help you with that now these
single page applications are basically
applications that get loaded just once
so the main page gets loaded onto your
browser so any further interactions does
not lead to loading of subsequent pages
anything that has to be done further is
just an addition to the already
single page applications are primarily
developed using angular moving ahead
let's look at the features of angular
we have four features that we're going
to be discussing we have the document
object model type script data binding
and testing now let's look at them one
by one
the document object model treats an XML
or an HTML document as a tree structure
now here every node in the tree
structure defines an object representing
a part of your document
angular uses the regular Dom now let's
suppose you've made 10 updates on a
single HTML page so every time you make
a change the corresponding Dom or the
tree structure needs to be updated
angular
of the entire tree structure of HTML
tags moving on to our next feature
we have typescript
now typescript defines a set of types to
JavaScript which helps you write
JavaScript that is easier to understand
now all the typescript code compiles
down to basic JavaScript that can run
smoothly on any platform now typescript
is a mandatory for developing an angular
application but it is highly recommended
the main reason is highly recommended is
that it offers better syntactic
structure while making the code base
easier to understand and maintain now
typescript can be installed as an npm
package now to do that you just have to
run the command npm install hyphen G
typescript on your command prompt now
next up is data binding now data binding
is a process that allows you to
manipulate web page elements using the
web browser now it mainly employs
Dynamic HTML and does not require
complex scripting or programming
it is used in web pages that include
interactive components like calculators
tutorials Games Etc now incremental
display of a web page makes data binding
extremely convenient when Pages contain
a large amount of data when it comes to
angular it uses two-way data binding so
any changes need in the UI element is
reflected in the corresponding model
state
conversely any changes made in the model
state are reflected onto the UI State
this allows the framework to connect to
Tom to the model data via the controller
the last feature we're discussing is
testing
angular uses Jasmine to run its various
tests the draftsman framework allows
various functionalities to write
different kinds of test cases karma is a
task runner for the tests that use a
configuration file to set the startup
reporters and testing framework so with
that we'll cover the features of angular
so let's go ahead and understand
the architecture of angular
angular is a full-fledged MVC framework
it provides a strong opinion on how the
application should be structured and
offers bi-directional data flow and
updates the real Dom MEC short for model
view controller is an architectural
pattern that separates the application
layer into model view and controller the
model here relates to all the data
related logic view on the other hand is
used for UI logic of the application
and controller is the brain of the setup
now it is an interface between the model
and view
moving on let's look at the advantages
of angular
first up we have custom components
I can pack functionality along with
rendering logic into reusable pieces
data binding as discussed angular allows
you to effortlessly move your data from
your JavaScript code to the view and
react to user events without having to
write any code yourself
dependency injection angular allows you
to write modular services and have them
injected wherever they are needed this
greatly improves the testability and
reusability of the same don't worry if
you can't wrap your head around these
topics we're going to discuss them
further in the coming videos
next Advantage is testing angular has
been built from the ground up with
testability in mind
you can literally test every part of
your application
comprehensive angular is a full-fledged
framework and provides out of the box
solutions for Server communication
routing and modeling
lastly we have excellent browser
compatibility angular is cross-platform
and browser compatible an angular
application can typically run on all
browsers with chrome Firefox Safari and
platforms like Windows Mac OS and Linux
now many versions of angular have been
released ever since its Inception all of
these versions have added to the
efficient working of the framework now
here are the different versions released
first up close angular 1. it was built
on JavaScript and completely based on
controllers next release was angular 2.
now this Incorporated the component
based approach wherein the entire UI was
divided into several components and
lastly integrated to give the final
logic next was angular 4 it included
router reputation angular CLI or command
line interface 1.0 was introduced
however not deployed in this release the
angular CLI was optimized and commands
like NG update and NG add were added and
the angular 7 release prompts were
introduced which provided tips in CLI
about the functions being used
in angular 8 IV renderer and bazel were
introduced
and finally the most recent release was
angular 9. now this came with the better
framework and angular material now this
completely switched to the IV renderer
as a default compiler now that we've
learned about the pros of using angular
let's look at some of the limitations of
angle
last up is a steep learning girl now
since angular is a complete full-fledged
framework it becomes difficult for
Learners to begin with you need to be
acquainted with simple topics and then
move on to more advanced topics to
become proficient in this language
next up is limited SEO options
now angular offers limited SEO options
and poor accessibility to search engine
Crawlers
if you were both and complex have a
common issue faced by the angular
Community is the verbosity of the
framework it also poses to be complex
compared to other front-end tools
and lastly migration now one of the
drawbacks of angular is poor migration
now it becomes difficult
to Legacy code
angular style architecture
also with each new release it is painful
to upgrade and a lot of them are not
Backward Compatible
next up let's look at the angular
learning curve
now if you wish to learn angular you
need to be acquainted with basic topics
in angular some of them are directors
modules decorators components Services
dependency injection pipes and templates
now once you've mastered your Basics you
will want to go and understand more
advanced topics such as change detection
zones aot compilation and rx.js however
the learning curve of angular is
clear-cut in the beginning it could be a
little intimidating but once you start
using the tool becomes way more easier
to comprehend and understand what is
going on
and lastly let's look at some of the
companies that use angular today
many top tier companies like Nike Forbes
Google HBO Sony upwork among others
readily deploy angular so moving on
let's look at the prerequisites for
angular first up we have node.js angular
uses node.js as its base for a large
part of its build environment
so as a result to get started with
angular you will need to have node.js
installed on your environment so head to
the official website and download the
latest release for your corresponding
operating system next up is the angular
CLI now this command line interface is a
tool that makes it easier to bootstrap
and develop your angular applications
now to install the latest version run
the command npm install hyphen G at
angular front slash CLI we call it run
this command on your command prompt and
finally to confirm installation check
for its version
now the next thing that you will need is
an IDE or a text editor to type your
code now there are several Ides that you
can choose from but in this series we've
used vs code throughout so it is
available on all platforms so go ahead
and download it if you haven't already
now moving on to the final part is the
demo now that you have a basic
understanding of angular and its
prerequisites I think you're ready to
create your first angular application so
let's head to our vs code and begin here
I've created a folder called angular on
my desktop and opened it on my visual
studio code so to create your app you
need to open the terminal just go here
and
select new terminal
and now type in the command Ng
new
and provide the name for your app so I'm
just gonna say hello world
so now this is going to create
just say yes
so basically what happens is that when
you run the command it will
automatically generate a skeleton
application under the folder that is
Hello World in our case and it includes
a bunch of files and installs all the
necessary dependencies for the angular
application
so this could take a while
so once you've created your application
to run it first change the directory so
let's say CD
hello world
and now use the command NG so
now once it's compiled you need to go to
your browser and type in localhost 4200
and once you do that
you can see your UI
you can see that the application has
been loaded onto your browser and it
says hello world app is running
so this is how you create your
application
so let's go back to our vs code now as
you can see here
there are many files and folders that
are created right so let's look at a few
of them of course we can't explain
everything but I'll brush through a few
of them
so the first mean component is basically
the root component now the root
component here is the index.html
so here if you open the file and see
it's a very small crisp code right but
the most important thing in the file is
this app Root element
so what this does is it's basically the
marker for loading your application code
so this is extremely important so the
next important file is the main.ts now
this is a part of the bootstrapping
piece all right so the index.html file
is responsible for deciding which files
are to be loaded correct the main.ts
file on the other hand identifies which
angular module is to be loaded when the
application starts so this is just a
brief explanation as to what they are
doing
next we have the app folder now here we
have the app dot module.ts file now this
application module file can be thought
of as a core configuration of your
application
so here's where the source code starts
from and moving on we have the
app.component.ts these are all
typescript files hence the extension TS
now this file basically is the root
component of your application and then
we have the HTML file for the same which
defines the appearance of what you can
see on your browser so let me just
change the message that is being
displayed
so I'll say hey
welcome to this
angular
tutorial so let's save this and when we
go back to our browser
we can see the message hey welcome to
this angular tutorial being displayed
so like this we can make a simple change
and then it gets rendered onto your
browser so this was just a brief
explanation of what happens in the
background of your application
first we'll get acquainted to what
exactly angular components are then I'll
help you create an angular component by
showing a quick demo and lastly we'll
learn about component decorator metadata
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our Channel if you love
watching new and interesting technology
videos also hit the Bell icon to never
miss an update so what exactly are
angular components
now I'm sure everybody uses web
applications and one of the most widely
used applications is Gmail correct now
to help you understand what components
are consider them as Lego blocks now
they basically are combined together to
form the final application so in this
case here we have the logo component
then you have a sign in component an
image component and then a create
account component now all of these
components generally don't affect the
working of each other but however when
embedded they Define the UI of your
application
so I hope you understood what components
are so to go ahead let's discuss some of
its common features now firstly they are
the building blocks of an application
generally you have a root component
which is basically the app component and
then it branches out into other
components creating a hierarchy
and these components are a subset of
directives now don't worry about what
deductives are because we'll cover them
later on in the series but to give you
an idea there are three types of
directives you have the structural
directives the attribute directives and
the component directives
only one component can be instantiated
per element in a template now components
are typically custom HTML elements and
each of these elements can instantiate
only one component
now don't worry you'll understand this
better when I show you the demo
nextly a typescript class is used to
create a component now this class is
then decorated with the at component
decorator Now The Decorator accepts a
metadata object that gives information
about the component now a component must
belong to the NG module in order for it
to be usable by another component or
application
and finally components control their
runtime Behavior by implementing life
cycle hooks so this was just a brief
introduction to what annular components
are
now you will only be able to understand
the working of components when I show it
to you practically so let's head over to
a Visual Studio code now here back in my
vs code I've created a folder called
angular demo within which I've created
an angular application called demo
components once executed the browser
looks something like this so if you
haven't watched our previous video on
getting started with angular that is
angular hello world I highly suggest you
go through that video first it helps you
create your first angular application so
um now let's go ahead and create our
first component now the command used to
create our component is NG GC and your
component name once executed it creates
four different files now let's just see
how this works on RVs code now what you
can do is head to your terminal and type
in the command Ng
g c
and provide a name for your component
for example I'm gonna just call my
component text component all right
so what it does is that it creates four
different files you can see you have
four different files that have been
created and finally it updates the file
that is app.module.ts indicating that
this new component has been created so
here in your Source folder within which
is an app folder and again here you can
see that your four different files have
been created first is the HTML file
wherein you can Define all the code that
you want for your component next you
have the CSS file for your styling then
you have the dot TS file which includes
the component decorator and finally you
have spec.ts which is basically a unit
test file all right and then in your
app.module.ts you can observe that the
company that you've created that is text
component has been imported that is what
the message conveys here all right now
let's go back to our
app.component.html now this basically
has all the corefair applications so let
me just get rid of it
and I'm just gonna display a basic
heading saying
hello
welcome all right so let me save it and
if you go ahead and look at your browser
hello welcome messages displayed now
let's go back to our component dot HTML
file and here let me
provide a message
[Music]
let me say h
3 and let me display a message saying
welcome to this tutorial
on angular components all right now in
your text component dot TS file which is
your typescript file
the selector mentioned here is app
hyphen text component now go ahead and
copy this
and in your final
component.html go ahead and create your
custom HTML tag with the selector that
you just copied now this indicates that
the component that you just created that
is the text component is being
Incorporated in the final render so what
happens is that whatever is defined in
the component.html file is also being
rendered in your final output so when I
save this let's go ahead and check
our browser you can see that the message
welcome to this tutorial on angular
components is displayed so this was a
simple creation of a component now for
this let's give it some styling so here
go to your dot CSS file and provide some
styling say for example here I just say
text line
and let me say Center and also in my
app.component.cs I'm going to give the
same thing I'll see each one
text align is Center
all right so let me save this
and there we go
now we can also create multiple
components and Define the tags in the
app component now the components are
executed sequentially so now let's
create another component just to give
you a brief insight into it let's say NG
GC image component
now here I'm going to be adding the
simply learn logo so I'll show you how
that works
now you can see that a new component has
been created with four files again so in
my assets folder here I've added the
logo so what I can do is back in my HTML
file I can go ahead and create an image
tag so first let me just display another
message here
just to avoid any confusion and let me
say this is the image component
and then let me say
image
Source equals so the source is basically
assets
[Music]
slash logo
dot PNG
and class
equals
Center
[Music]
all right so you can also head to your
CSS file and provide any sort of styling
that you need so let me just say
text
align
to be Center
and then let's create a styling for the
image
and here I mentioned the code for the
image so let's save this and from the
dot CS file let's copy the selector
and create a custom HTML tag in our
final component.html file
so there we go let's save this and check
the output
and there we go first the hello welcome
message is displayed next you have the
message displayed from the first
component and then you have the second
component so this is how you can create
your own components and don't forget to
incorporate these selectors into your
final HTML file so moving on to our next
topic component decorator metadata now
as mentioned earlier the at component
decorator accepts a metadata object that
provides information about the component
correct here is a list of properties of
the metadata object first up is the
selector now basically the selector is a
CSS selector that identifies this
particular component in a template now
this corresponds to the HTML tag that is
included in the parent component you can
create your own HTML tag however the
same has to be included in the parent
component so to help you understand that
better let's head back to our vs code
and say for example in our text
component
here
the selector says text component correct
for the time being let's change it to
say n component
all right now when you save it and look
at the browser the message is not
displayed
so what we can do is you can copy this
selector and then include this
here
and now you can see that the same
component has been rendered onto your
output
all right so the selector plays a
crucial role in that
next up we have the template now a
template is an inline defined template
for the view now the template can be
used to provide some particular markup
the markup could typically include some
headings or paragraphs that are
displayed on the UI
next up we have template URL now it is
the URL for the external file containing
the template for The View
so here you can see
this is basically the external file that
contains the template for the view next
up you have Styles now these are also
inline defined styles that can be
applied to the components view so any
code that you provide in the dot CSS
file can also be included here
next you have the style URLs now this is
a list of URLs to your style sheets that
are applied on your components View
next up you have providers now this is
again an array where certain Services
can be registered for your component
lastly we have animations as the name
suggests these are animations that can
be listed for your components
in today's session we're going to learn
all about angular data binding
but before we begin if you haven't
subscribed to our Channel already make
sure to hit the Subscribe button and the
bell icon to never miss an update
so now without further Ado let's begin
so here's what's in store for you
first we'll understand what exactly data
binding is
next
we'll understand the types of data
binding that is interpolation and
property binding event binding and
two-way data binding
so let's begin
what exactly is data binding now I'm
sure you must have heard the term data
binding quite often now data binding is
what is responsible to ensure
consistency between the view and your
component so it allows an internet user
to manipulate all the web page elements
in the web browser
and it employs Dynamic HTML and does not
require any sort of complex scripting or
programming
it is generally used for web pages that
contain interactive components like
calculators tutorials and games
and lastly it ensures incremental
display of a web page now in simple
terms what I'm saying is that data
binding ensures that any change made in
the UI of the application is also
reflected in the component and vice
versa by doing so data binding ensures
consistency throughout the application
so now let's have a look at the
different types of data binding
first up we're going to be learning
about interpolation and property binding
next even binding and then the two-way
data binding
so what exactly is interpolation and
Property Data binding now when it comes
to interpolation binding it ensures that
the values are reflected from the
components to the Dom in this technique
text representing variables and
components are placed between double
curly braces in the template so angular
finds the variable matching the text in
the component and replaces the text with
the actual value assigned to that
particular variable so this could be
numbers strings Etc
so to understand this better let's look
at a simple demo back in my vs code I've
created a simple angular project and
then created a folder called binding all
right and I've displayed the message
welcome on the screen here so now in my
component.ts file I'll create
a variable let's call it
name
is it public
name
equals and I'm going to assign the value
simply learn to it
all right and here in my HTML for
interpolation what I'm going to do is I
as mentioned earlier I'll have to
include the variable name within curly
braces right so I'll say welcome to and
within curly braces I'm just going to
say name
all right and to just beautify the code
I'll just Center align everything
I'll
now here in the browser we can see
welcome to Simply learn being displayed
as you can see this part is being
replaced by the value of the variable
name which is simply on
all right we can also add another one
uh let's just
create another variable
and
saying public
I'm going to say topic
and let me see data binding all right
and in my HTML file
I'll create
and I'm just I'm going to display
another message saying welcome to
the
topic
tutorial
so topic here must be replaced by its
value all right so let's see that so let
me just save this and have a look at the
browser
so here you can see that welcome to the
data binding tutorial is being displayed
so this is a simple example of
interpolation binding
so now moving on to property binding now
again property binding is a one-way
mechanism that lets you set the property
of a view element now it involves
updating the value of a property in the
component and binding it to an element
in the view template
and property binding uses the square
braces Syntax for data binding so now
let's have a look at the simple demo so
now I'm going to be creating an image
variable
and I'm going to provide the path to my
logo.png in my assets folder so let me
just say
slash assets
slash logo dot PNG
all right and now back in my HTML file
I will create a simple image tag
image and then I'm going to use property
binding for the source property and
Source equals image
all right and now just to purify the
code I'm just going to provide some
styling
with some height and width
foreign
for Center so now once once you save the
file and have a look at the browser
you can see that the image is being
displayed with the help of property data
binding now you could argue that instead
of using property binding you could have
just used interpolation binding now
however there is one drawback using
interpolation branding interpolation
binding can only be used for string
values when you want to bind Boolean
values property binding is a better
option next up we have even binding
so this data binding type is used when
information flows from the view to the
component when an event is triggered
so what happens is that
The View sends the data from an event
like the Click of a button to be used to
update the component it is the exact
opposite of property binding where the
data goes from the component to The View
so again the event could be a mouse
click or a key press so now let's head
to vs code so here I'm going to be
creating a button for the click event
all right so let's just create a button
foreign
subscribe to Simply learn on it
all right and the event is going to be a
click event so let me see
click
and I'm gonna pass
a function called on click
all right
so what happens is that when the button
is clicked this particular method is
called so now let's define the method in
our component.ts file
so here I'll see
on click
I'm going to just display a console
message
saying thank you
for subscribing
okay
so what happens is that I'm binding The
Click event to the on click method and
every time the user clicks on this
button the message is displayed so now
let's have a look at the browser let's
just inspect this first
all right in my console
now when I click on the button you can
see the message thank you for
subscribing is displayed so this is how
even binding is achieved and lastly
let's have a look at two-way data
binding now two-way data binding is a
mechanism where data flows from
the component to The View and back
the component and view are always in
sync and the changes made on either ends
will immediately update both ways now
two-way data binding is typically used
when dealing with forms where the user
input is used to update the component's
state and vice versa
so let's have a look at the demo
let me just Center align this first
let's see
tired
okay
all right so first I'm going to be
creating a property
and let's just call it
public
value and I'm gonna just
initialize it to nothing
all right
and back in my HTML I'm going to create
an input tag
of type
text and I'm going to bind the value
using interpolation
all right
so basically what we're doing is that
every time the user provides a value in
the input box that has to be reflected
in the model as well so we're making
sure that the view and the model are in
sync and to make sure this happens we
have to make use of the NG model
director so for that I'm just going to
provide Ng
model now one thing to remember is that
we'll have to make use of banana in a
box styling for it so first I'm going to
make use of parentheses and then square
brackets
and this needs to be initialized to
value
all right so let's save this
so in the browser when I provide a text
in my input box you can see that nothing
below is being displayed whatever in the
text box whatever I provide in the text
box needs to be displayed but although
we've used the NG model directive here
it still does not display the message
that is because NG model directive is a
part of the forms module so you'll have
to go ahead and
import that in your module.ts file so
here just say import forms module form
angular forms and just provide it in
your Imports array
say forms module save this
all right and now let's have a look at
the browser
so when I provide
anything the same is being displayed
down
which means that our model and our view
are in complete sync this is how 2B data
binding is achieved first we'll have a
look at what's in store for us
first you'll understand what exactly
dependency injection is
then we'll understand the demerit or the
drawback of not using dependency
injection
then we'll understand dependency
injection as a design pattern and
finally I'll help you understand the
entire concept with the help of a demo
so let's begin
what exactly is dependency injection so
let's consider this I'm sure you are
aware that angular uses the concept of
componence the entire UI of the
application is divided into several
components now what have all of these
components perform similar tasks be it
accessing the database rendering images
Etc now instead of writing the same
piece of code for every component you
could write the code once and then
perhaps inject the same code into every
component
now this is supported by dependency
injection
now to give you a better example
consider two classes A and B now let's
assume that a uses the objects of Class
B and normally in object oriented
programming an instance of Class B is
created so that a can access its objects
but using dependency injection we move
the creation and binding of dependent
objects outside of the class that depend
on them so dependency injection or di
keeps the core more flexible testable
and mutable also classes can inherit
external logic without having to create
on its own and lastly GI benefits
directives pipes and components
next up let's have a look at the
drawback of not using dependency
injection
now let's consider Class Postal details
that is dependent on the number and the
address class
in the postal details class the
Constructor creates copies of the number
and address
so when you instantiate a new postal
details class the Constructor
instantiates a unique number and address
now although this looks simple there's a
problem with this code let's assume that
the number and address class
Constructors now accept parameters when
we change the numbers class the postal
details class gets broken now to
overcome this what we need to do is we
need to pass parameter to the number
Constructor
so this applies to address as well the
first drawback of using this traditional
method is that the code is not very
flexible anytime the dependencies change
the postal details class needs to be
changed as well
and the second drawback is that the core
is not suitable for testing
once you instantiate the new postal
details class you get the same number
and address even if you change the
number and address classes every time
what if these classes are in turn
dependent on other classes then it's
going to be a chain reaction so to
overcome this we make use of dependency
injection
now let's look at di as a pattern
dependency injection as you all know is
a coding pattern where a class receives
its dependencies from an external Source
rather than creating them on its own so
here in the above example we have moved
the definition of dependencies from
inside the Constructor to the
constructor's parameters so the postal
details class doesn't create the
dependencies anymore
it just consumes them so the postal
dependencies class doesn't create the
dependencies anymore
so with that we overcome the drawbacks
of not using Di
so now that you know what exactly
dependency injection is and how vital it
is let's look at a simple demonstration
to understand the concept better now
services classes modules components all
of these are benefactors of dependency
injection so in the demo I'm going to be
showing how dependency injection can be
used with the help of services and
injecting these Services into classes so
the main thought behind this is normally
components are used to ensure just a
good user experience these components do
not generally execute tasks so to
execute these tasks we make use of
services so a component can delegate
tasks like fetching data from the server
any network related issues ETC to a
particular service and these Services
can be made available to components now
with the same thought what I'm going to
be doing is I'll be creating a service
that performs the task of displaying an
employee list later we're going to
inject the service into the class using
dependency injection
so let's head to our Visual Studio code
for the demonstration
all right so as discussed I'll have to
first create a component that displays a
button for the employee and then I have
to create a service class and inject it
into my component now this service holds
the employee details such as name
employee ID email ID
Etc so first let's go ahead and create a
component
so here let me just type
n g g c
and the name of the component I'm
providing is M info
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
component with four different files all
right so the next thing we have to do is
we have to create a service so to create
that we make use of the command n g g s
you can either give s or service and the
service name I'm providing is records so
let me just say records here
all right here you can see two files are
created there is a spect.ts file and the
dot TS file all right so now the service
contains all the employee data that
needs to be displayed right so let's go
ahead and write the data so first we're
going to make use of three arrays I'm
going to be displaying employee records
for three employees so I'll have to
create three arrays and provide certain
information so let's go ahead and do
that
all right so the area I'm creating is
called info one for the first employee
and I'm going to be passing
information like name employee ID and
the email ID so the arrays of type
string
and within which let me just mention the
details I'm giving random information
I'm just saying Adam Taylor
and some random
employee ID
and let's say 80 at abc.net
all right so I'm going to be creating
three records so I'll just copy the same
thing and paste with rest too
let's just change here
provide a different name here
and same for the last one
yes
and let me change the name of the idea
as well all right so with the agenda to
retrieve this data in our component we
make use of the method for the same
right so this method Returns the
employee data
so let's go ahead and create this method
I'm going to call it get info
and then just say string
and then this will just return
this dot info one
all right I'm going to be calling it get
info one for better understanding
same for the rest two as well
I'm just going to return different
arrays here
all right and lastly info three all
right
now in order to retrieve this
information in our component we need
three more arrays right three more
arrays I will receive this data let's go
back to our component dot TS file here
and then type in the following code
so I've created three arrays again uh
info received one two and three
now what we need to do is we have to
accept the information that is being
sent from the service correct now as I
mentioned services are implemented with
the help of dependency injection so what
we need to do is we'll have to first
import the service into the component.ts
file the key reason behind doing this is
that when angular creates this component
and instance of the service class is
also made to perform the necessary tasks
correct so let's go ahead and just
import it here
so I'll say import
[Music]
records
services
I'm sorry service
from
and let's say records.service
all right and what we have to do next is
that we must also declare this instance
that is being created in the provider's
array of the component
all right so
let's just say providers
and then say records
service
all right now we've created the instance
of this class right however to access
this instance an object is also created
so this object will in turn access the
methods and variables of the service
class so for that we have to create
another object so let's do that here in
our Constructor method let's say
Constructor
private
and the object I'm creating is called
our service you can give a name of your
choice and then I'm gonna just say
records service
all right now this object will help me
retrieve data from the service so let's
go ahead and use this in order to get
the employee details our ads have
created three different methods here get
info from service class 2 1 and 3 and
these methods will retrieve the data and
add it to our array here that is info
received all right and lastly we'll have
to create an unordered list in our HTML
file here we haven't added anything so
let me get rid of this
so now I have to create three different
buttons for three different employees
and when the user clicks on the button
the data is retrieved from the service
and then displayed on the UI right
so as you can see I've created buttons
for three different employees
and then I've made use of a bootstrap
class called list group info and then
I've
interpolated info which displays the
contents
of the info variable all right now in
order to call the methods in the dot TS
file we have to bind them with the
button so since it is bound with the
click event every time you click on the
button the information is displayed
so now the last thing we have to do is
we'll have to create a custom HTML tag
for the component and then add it to the
main component
so let's just do that
let me copy this here
and then in my app component.html let me
get rid of this
and then let me just create this I've
just created the custom HTML tag for my
component
and now just to beautify the code I'll
write a heading
and let's say employee
details
and then I'll also add the simply learn
logo
say image source
[Music]
I've I've added the image here so let me
just say logo dot PNG
I've also added some styling to it all
right so now let me just save this and
have a look at the browser
so here we go we have the logo here and
then employee details heading and then
we have three different buttons created
that is employee one two and three and
when I click on it
the information of the employee is
displayed the name the ID and their
email address
so yeah so this is how you can make use
of dependency injection and inject a
service class into a component
dependency injection plays a crucial
role in angular
I'm sure you all know that an angular
app is divided into several components
for example you have the logo component
you have the sign in component and image
component and say a create account
component
now these components are Standalone and
each of them represents a part of the
user interface
now imagine if all of these components
performed common tasks for example
access in the database or rendering
images on The View
tasks like those now instead of having
to write the code for every component
you can just make use of angular
services
now the service can be written once and
then injected into all of these
components
now a service could be a function it
could be a variable or a feature that an
application needs
so the main use of a service is to write
code once and avoid rewriting of it now
the same code can be injected into
several components that make use of this
particular service
but what are angular services
so normally components are used to
ensure a good user experience now that
is the extent of it components make sure
that whatever is being rendered onto the
screen is right and pristine
but in order to execute tasks we make
use of services and this approach is
ideal
so a component can basically delegate
tasks like fetching data from the server
validating user input or logging
directly to the console to a particular
service
and these tasks can be made available to
any component in the app
so let's talk about a few features of
angular services
now typically an angular service is
simply a typescript class with an at
injectable decorator
this decorator tells Angela that the
class is a service and can be injected
into components that need that service
now they can be used to share the same
piece of code they can also inject other
services as dependencies
now these Services hold valuable
business logic
and can also be used to interact with
the back end now for example if you want
to make Ajax calls you can have methods
to those calls in a service and then use
it as a dependency in files
and as mentioned earlier it can be used
to share data among several components
in angular services are Singleton
meaning that only a single instance of a
service gets created and the same
instance is used by each and every
building block in the application and
finally a service can be registered as a
part of a module or it can be registered
as a part of the component now to
register it as a part of the component
you'll have to specify it in the
provider's array of the module
I'm sure you'll understand the concept
of services better if we look at a
simple demo so in the next section we're
going to look at a demo but before that
let me tell you the use case
so basically in the demo what we'll do
is we'll create an employee details list
say for example you will have employee
information like name employee ID and
their email ID we'll create a database
of say three employees
and on the browser when you click on the
employee button it displays the
information about that particular
employee
and at the end we can also add
information to the employees details so
without delay let's head to our vs code
and start learning angular Services
Hands-On so here first I've created a
folder called demo underscore angular
which in which I've created a file
called hello world so uh this was
previously used for a tutorial so the
name is just hello world so don't get
confused
however when you look at the browser
I've written an initial code here which
is angular services and I have the
simply learn logo so back in my browser
this is what the UI looks like
so uh to
understand the concept of angular
Services first let's go ahead and create
a component
so here I'm going to say NG g c
e info
I'm creating a component for employee
information
so as you can see
inside my app file we have the e-info
component which has these four files so
if you're wondering what exactly
components are and how this is working
then I highly suggest you watch our
components video first
so now let's go ahead and create a
service
so I'm just typing in the command NG G
service
here G stands for Generate and we're
generating a service and the name of the
service that I'm providing is data
so now it creates a service
which is going to be a DOT TS file
so you can observe that dot service is
appended this indicates that it is a
service all right
as mentioned earlier we have to display
the employee details correct so for that
in my component.ts file I'm going to
create an array that displays the
employee information in our case I'm
creating uh three different employee
records so for that I'll have three
different arrays so let me just call the
arrays info
receipt
one indicating this is the information
of first employee and this is going to
be of type string
and I'll just initialize it to null
for now
all right and I'm going to create
two other
arrays
and let me just
change
the name of that is all right
so now uh to retrieve the information
I'll have to create a method again I'm
creating three methods for the three
different employee records
so I'm gonna call the array get info
from service one indicating it's again
for employee one
and
I'm just gonna leave it as it is for now
I'll tell you how the information is
being received
and I'm gonna do the same for the other
two uh employee records so let me just
copy paste and here I'm just going to
change
the name of the methods
all right so uh this is the initial code
for retrieving information however we'll
have to create the employee record in
our service
so back here in my data.ts file
what I'm going to do is
I'll create three different uh Records
for the employees so let me say info one
which is going to be of type string
all right
and let me just give a random names say
for example I say John
Matthew
[Music]
all right
and employee ID say
if 354
and let me just give a random
email ID and say JM abc.net
all right so I'm gonna do the same for
the other two uh Records
so let me just create another one and
call it info 2.
and the name I'm providing is say Rob
Wilson
with a different employee ID says 673
and I'm just gonna make it RW at abc.net
and another record for employee number
three
and I'm just gonna say Rose Adams
[Music]
with
some employee ID
and an email ID all right so now we've
created the employee records so what I
have to do is I have to create a method
that returns these employee records
correct so for that I'm just gonna
create another method called get info
one
which is of type string
and it just returns
this dot info one
all right similarly for the rest of the
two records I'm just gonna retrieve them
let's say info 2 and get info two
and again
I'm just gonna make it get in full three
and this is gonna return info three
all right so I'm sure you've got an idea
as to what I'm doing here so basically
this information is going to be
retrieved in our employee component
correct so for that I'll have to make
use of dependency injection
so here I'll have to import the service
that I've created so let's go ahead and
say import
[Music]
the service was data service
all right
from
[Music]
slash data.service all right
now the main reason we're doing this is
to tell angular that when the component
is created
the service instance is also created and
this instance is being used to perform
particular tasks and for that we'll also
have to include this in our provider's
array so here let me just say providers
[Music]
foreign
service
now to access this instance of service
that is created we make use of a
property
so uh this property basically allows us
to access all the methods that are
defined in the service class
all right so here in my Constructor
method I'm just gonna say
private
and you can give any name for your
property and here I'm just giving the
name d service
all right and which is of type
data service
all right
so now with the help of this property I
can retrieve information from the
service class so here I'm just going to
save
this Dot
info receipt
equals this dot d service
dot get info one
all right so what it basically does is
that it calls the get info one method in
our service which Returns the
information of the first employee
and this information is being stored in
the array that is info received one
so similarly for the next two methods
I'm just gonna use the same piece of
code
let me just change it here
all right
and
same for the third one
all right
so now that we have the logic behind
what is being displayed
let's go ahead and create the UI for it
here in my HTML file
I'm going to create
an unordered list
[Music]
and now I'm going to make use of
the NG
for director
to basically Loop over the record and
display everything so for that I have to
make use of a particular variable so
I'll just say
let info
of info receipt
so
um you can check here in our TS file the
array is info received correct so I'm
going to make it with the same array
here
and since it's displaying the first
employee record I'm just going to
say
info received one
all right and let me just create a Class
A bootstrap class of list
group
item of list group info
and we're just gonna have to interpolate
info
all right that is basically going to
display what the information holds what
the info variable holds
all right and here as well let me create
a bootstrap class
called list
group
all right I hope this was clear to you
so basically here the information is
being retrieved with the help of this
method right let us get info from
service one so in order to call this
method we'll have to bind it with a
button all right so that's what we're
going to do let's just
copy this and here I'm going to create a
button
foreign
and the type
is button
[Music]
with name
button again
all right so I'm going to bind it with
the click event so what happens is that
when I click on it this particular
method gets called
all right I'm just pasting the method
here
and finally let's just provide the name
employee one
for the button all right
so uh similarly we'll have to do the
same for the other two records as well
better all right so uh what I'm going to
do is I'm just gonna paste the same
twice
and here I'm gonna just change the names
I'll say 2 here and this is again for
employee two
and I'm going to change this as well
it's going to be employed I'm sorry it's
going to be in four received two this is
going to be in for receipt 3.
and finally employee 3.
all right uh and lastly we'll have to
include
the selector that is app hyphen e info
in our main
component.html so here
let me just
create a custom tag alright and save
this so now let's go back to our browser
and see what it looks like
so here you can see that uh three
different buttons have been created for
employee one two and three and when you
click on it it retrieves information
that is the name the employee ID and
their email IDs so we've successfully
created an angular service and injected
it into our component to retrieve
information all right so now the last
part of the use case that we discussed
was uh to add another detail that is the
employee detail in the record all right
so for that we'll have to take uh input
from the user and in our case we're
taking the location now we're also
adding the same location for all three
employees
so this is what services do you know
they can be used to update modify alter
anything that happens in the back end so
you can tweak the code a little bit and
you can change the entire uh view of
your application you can add information
you can delete you can retrieve you can
alter
Etc all right so for that what we're
going to do is back in the HTML file
we'll create a form that basically takes
the input
so I'm just going to say um
[Music]
form
all right within which I'm going to be
defining a div glass
[Music]
within which I'm going to be defining a
div tag
inside which I'll have the input tag
of type
text
and uh the name I'm going to be
providing it will be location
all right
[Music]
and we'll have a value and I'll just
leave it blank and finally I'll have NG
model so if you're confused as to what
I'm doing here then I suggest you watch
the angular forms uh video it basically
teaches you uh how to work around with
angular forms
all right and now after this we're gonna
have a button
so let me say button
[Music]
all right
[Music]
and I'm gonna just say add info
okay
all right so now when I'm creating the
form I'll also have to create a template
variable to access all the values within
my form so if I have to access the
location then I need a variable to
access it so here let me just go ahead
and create a template variable let me
call it frm
and I'm gonna make use of the NG form
directive
so this tells angular
that uh this variable can be used to
access all the values within the form
and since I'm using form here I'll have
to import it in my module file
so here I just go ahead
and see
import forms module from angular forms
and here in my imports
I'll just say forms module
okay so I've imported the forms module
so now uh back in my HTML file
what I'm going to do is that I'll have
to make use of this template readable
to update my information correct so I'll
have to create another method that will
update information into the records
so here in my uh component.ts file I'll
have to create another method and I'm
going to call this method update info
method
all right and uh this basically takes in
the template variable that is form
and let me just specify any
okay and what this is going to do is
that it updates
the record correct so I'm gonna say this
Dot
D service
Dot
add info now you must be wondering what
add info is
I'll just let you know in a minute and
and the value that I'm going to be
passing will be the value that you've
provided as an input which is nothing
but form dot value dot location
all right so now what happens is that
I'll have to again specify what add info
is and this method is going to be
defined in the service file correct
so here I'm going to create another uh
method that's add info
and I'm going to pass info as a
parameter
and what this method does is that it
just pushes the information or the data
into the arrays
so since I'm going to be pushing the
same information into all of these
arrays that is info 1 info 2 and info 3.
I'm just gonna say this dot info1 dot
push
of info
all right and the same for
the other two arrays as well
let me just
change these all right
so what exactly I'm doing is that I have
I have a method called add info which
gets information from the component
all right and it basically pushes this
information into the array and also I
have to return it so I'll say return
this dot info
one
all right and I'll save it and here we
have another method called update info
which basically calls uh the ad info
method in our service
and passes the value to it
and in my HTML file also note that the
button type here is submit and not
button so what happens is that now the
value that we've received as an input
has to be passed on to the method that
is update info so here I'll say NG
submit
foreign
update info
and I'm gonna pass
frm as the argument and now let's save
this
and execute
so all right here you can see that we
have an input field and a button saying
add info
so now I can just go ahead and say type
USA
and when I say add info and when I check
on my employee one details USA has been
added to the list
and same goes with employee 2 and
employee 3.
so I hope this simple demo on angular
Services helped you understand the
concept better I highly recommend you
play around and explore other
possibilities
first we'll understand what angular
forms are
then we look at the different types of
form building supported by angular next
up we'll get acquainted with features
like form control and group control
and we learn all of this with the help
of a simple demo
so without further Ado let's begin
so what exactly are angular forms
now I'm sure every application that you
use comes with certain amount of form
filling correct be it your login
credentials or your sign up forms or any
sort of registration forms Etc so forms
are an integral part of a web
application you need forms to update
your profile or to enter sensitive
information or also to perform any sort
of data related tasks so now let's look
at the different types of form building
supported by angular
first up angular supports two types of
form building
first you have the template driven
approach and second you have the
reactive approach
now let's look at them one by one so
talking about template driven approach
in this method the conventional form tag
is used to create forms so angular
automatically interprets and creates a
form object with the help of the
directives
Now controls can be added to the form
using the mg model tag now multiple
controls can be grouped using the NG
control group module so it basically
uses several module classes to provide
controls now if you don't get this don't
worry you'll understand better when I'm
showing you the demo
next up is Json values so form value can
be generated using the form.value object
form data is exported as Json values
when the submit method is called
lastly basic HTML validations can be
used to validate the form fields in the
case of custom validations directives
can be used so arguably this method is
the simplest way to create an angular
form
so moving on to the active approach now
this approach is the programming
Paradigm revolving around data flows and
propagation of change
now with reactor forms the component
directly manages the data flows between
the form controls and the data models
now reactive forms are code driven
unlike template driven approach
reactive forms eliminate the anti-patron
of updating the data model by a two-way
data binding so it does not use two-way
data binding
and typically a reactive form control
creation is synchronous and can be unit
tested with synchronous programming
techniques
so now let's go ahead and look at form
control and form group
so consider a typical form consisting of
fields like name age and location
now a form control is basically a class
that enables validation of these fields
for each input field an instance of this
class is created now these instances
help check the values of the field and
see if they're either touched untouched
dirty pristine valid invalid and so on
so this allows you to check every field
for the value it makes it easier to
understand which Fields value is invalid
or which field has not been entered
Etc
now moving on to form group
so a form group class represents a group
of controls a form can have multiple
group controls the form group returns
true if all the controls are valid and
provides validation errors if there are
any so I hope this was clear
so moving ahead let's look at the demo
to explain all of these features I'm
sure it will become extremely clear once
you look at the demo so for that let's
head to our vs code
so back in my vs code
I've created a component called form
component and I've also included the
simply learn logo just to purify the
appearance so once you execute the code
this is what you're gonna see on your
browser so you just have the logo at the
moment
the first thing we need to do is we'll
have to import the forms module all
right so oh uh but before we begin let
me tell you what the use case is so
we're going to be creating a user
registration form which is going to
include four fields that is the first
name last name email ID and the password
all right so now let me show you how to
import the forms module so in your main
app.module.ts file you'll have to import
forms module from angular forms
all right and then in your Imports
you'll have to just call it here
all right so this is just a simple step
and now once you're done with that let's
go ahead and start our form creation
so here in my component.html let's
enclose the entire form within a div tag
so here let me say div
class
as a container
foreign
within which let me just have one
heading
it says user registration
all right and now let's go ahead and
create our form
so first let me just say form
now I'm going to create a div class for
every field so say div
class
equals form group
I'll explain it to you a little later
now first let's create a label
so label tag
for
basically it's the first name
so let me just say first name
and the tag will basically have
first name again
all right and let me just break the line
next we have the field so let's say
input
type is text
name is
first name
and we have a class which is
the form control class
all right
so this will have to do for all the
other fields so let me just copy this
and
paste it like four times
I'll also add the tag three for spacing
let's do that here
and finally we'll have the button
so let's just add that here
with a type subnet
and let's just say submit on the button
so now let's go ahead and change these
values here
so here let me just change it to last
name
here as well
and here as well
and in this case it is going to be email
so let me just change it here
and finally we have passwords so
let's add that here
all right so let's save this and just
have a look at our browser
so there we go we have our uh user
registration form ready but I would like
to uh align it to the center so let me
just do that
so here in my CSS file I'm just going to
uh align all the div tags in the center
and the label tag to the left so let me
save this and look at the browser now
and there we go we have our registration
form with a logo so this is how you
create a simple form
now we'll have to add a directive called
NG model now this directive when added
into the input tab will provide form
controls to every input field all right
so here let's just go ahead and say NG
model
that is it
so let me just copy this and paste it
for every other field
all right let me save this and back in
my browser
let me inspect
and here you can see different types of
classes like NG untouched NG pristine NG
ballot are added right so this indicates
that angular has recognized the form Tab
and it has added these classes to the
form as well as all the fields
so this is achieved when you add the NG
model directive in your input tag now
back in my vs code now every form has an
output property attached to it called NG
submit all right so this property can be
bound within a method that method called
the submit method
so once submitted this method is called
right so once we click on the submit
button this method has to be called so
to include that
we'll have to just save
form
and G submit
equals
submit
[Music]
all right so now we have to define the
submit method
in our component.ts file so here let me
just go to our component.ts file and let
me
just get rid of unnecessary code here
and let's define a function
or submit
and then here let me just
console log
form submitted
all right so let me just get rid of this
as well it's unnecessary here
let's save this so what it means is that
every time you click on the submit
button
this method is called all right so let's
just have a look at the browser so first
let's go to our console
and when I click on submit it says form
submitted
all right so the next crucial step is to
generate JavaScript representation now
we'll have to make use of another
directive called NG form that is
assigned to a template variable
okay so this JavaScript representation
helps with validating all the fields so
I'll help you understand that better
so back in our HTML file
let's just create a variable first
let's call it login
all right and say Ng
form
okay now the mg form object includes the
JavaScript representation so now while
you're calling the submit method you're
going to pass login as a parameter
so let's just say login here
and in my ts file again let's just say
login
and along with it
I want login to be displayed so
I say login again
so now let's save this and if you have a
look at the browser let's click on
submit
and now here you can see the JavaScript
representation So within form
I can
check for email
or say first name and here for this
field first name you can see different
properties attached you can see invalid
is it invalid or is it untouched
which is true or are there any errors so
this basically gives you all information
about the particular field
so we can make use of this feature to
validate the information so we're going
to learn about that in our next segment
moving on to form validation one way to
ensure that incorrect fields are not
submitted is by disabling the submit
button
correct now apart from this you can also
specify certain properties in your input
tag for the corresponding input field
now um let's say that the fields that
now let's say that the fields can't be
empty and the form only accepts names
with the minimum length of 2 and the
maximum length of seven all right so
here in my input tag I just mentioned a
required meaning this field cannot be
empty
and Min length
2 2
and
max length
to say seven
all right
so to check this
let's go to our browser
and here
let me submit the form without filling
the first name
and evidently there has to be an error
so when I submit it
and I look here
what's in forms and here controls
and my first name you can see that an
error is shown here it says require
equals true that means that there is one
error now you can make use of these form
control objects you can leverage form
control objects to ensure field
validation and display a message
whenever an error occurs
right so to do that you need to access
these objects like errors or invalid or
touched all of these properties or
objects need to be
accessed for that we'll have to create a
template variable
and then this variable is assigned to
this object
so back in our vs code
let's create
a variable let me call it
name
and let's say NG model
all right here the variable name
receives the control object
so here back in my browser when I submit
again without the first name
you can see that the invalid
property is set to True correct so this
helps us use this property to alert the
user with the help of a simple if logic
so back in my
vs code let me create
another div tag
within which I mentioned NG if
within which I'm going to use a simple
if logic so let's say ngf
name which is our template variable name
dot touched
and name dot invalid
is true
right then I'm going to alert
so I'm gonna
make use of an alert
here let's say
alert
Danger
all right so in my CSS file I'll have to
mention the simple styling for alert
so here let me just say
so we're gonna have the background color
red
for danger all right and here I'm gonna
display the message
invalid in bold
foreign
so now let's go back to our browser and
check it
so let me proceed without entering the
last name it says invalid here
so this was a simple demonstration to
show you form validation
of course you can modify the code
depending on your requirement say
suppose the length of the first name is
too short then you can alert the user
with a different message or uh suppose
they have missed out on filling a form
field then you can again alert the user
so you can basically make use of the
nested if condition right now just to
help you understand that better let me
just show it to you
now back in my HTML file
instead of invalid let me have another
tag a paragraph tag within which I make
use of NG if again
now ngf
name dot errors
[Music]
dot required
is true
then I display the message first
name required
all right
and if
the length of the first name is
not 2.
now if the length of the first name is
less than 2 then I'm going to display
another message so let me just say
name dot errors
dot Min length
if this is true then I'm going to say
sorry
short
first name
all right so let's save this and have a
look at the browser
when I proceed without providing the
name it says first name required but
when I type in one character it says
sorry short first name but if I type in
another character it accepts so I hope
this made you understand how form
validation works
so this was just a simple demonstration
again now I highly recommend you explore
these properties and play around with
these objects uh trust me it's really
fun so I hope this tutorial helped you
out let's understand what exactly is
bootstrap
bootstrap is a powerful toolkit
basically a collection of HTML CSS and
JavaScript tools for creating and
building responsive web applications and
Pages it is a free and open source
project based on GitHub and originally
created by Twitter
now to put it more easily bootstrap is a
giant collection of Handy reusable bits
of code written in HTML CSS and
JavaScript it's also a front-end
development framework that enables
developers and beginners to design quick
and responsive websites
now there are several advantages to
using bootstrap
to name a few bootstrap comes with a
responsive grid you don't have to spend
time working on your layouts
bootstrap comes with its own code for
automatically resizing images based on
the current screen size
it also comes with different components
that you can use for your web page these
components could be navigation bars drop
downs progress bars thumbnails
Etc
it also offers excellent documentation
and is customizable
so bootstrap comes in extremely handy to
create responsive user interface
so now before using bootstrap it needs
to be embedded into your application so
let's see how to embed bootstrap into
angular
now there are two ways to do it first up
is by using the bootstrap CDN or the
content delivery Network
now this enables users to load CSS
JavaScript and images remotely from its
servers
the other method is to use bootstrap npm
bootstrap jQuery and other packages and
Frameworks can be installed via the
command prompt
in the tutorial that I am going to be
showing you I have embedded bootstrap
using npm alright so I'm sure you only
understand the concept better when you
look at a demo
so let's go ahead and create an
application with the help of angular
bootstrap so in this tutorial what I'm
going to be showing is the creation of a
blog post so so let me show you what
we're going to be doing
so here I've created a simple blog
for simply learn and I've added the
simply learn logo I've also written a
few lines about simply learn and what
they offer I've also mentioned their
tagline and when you scroll down you can
see that I've mentioned the different
courses they're offering
and when you click on the more info
button
it navigates to the official page that
gives you the overview for that
particular course so this is for lean
sex Sigma the same for full stack web
development
as well
and the same for the last one that is
cyber security
and finally I've added a simple video
here to just make it more uh beautiful
so I've added a simple video
and lastly I've also linked our YouTube
channel so when you click on the YouTube
icon it will navigate to the YouTube
channel
to our YouTube channel here
all right so this is what we're going to
be creating uh using angular bootstrap
so I'm hoping you're all ready for it so
without further delay let's jump in so
first let's find the template that we
want to use for our blog
so for that I'm going to just go ahead
and say
bootstrap
blog template
and I'm just going to click on the first
link that I get
and here
you can choose the template that you
like so I'm just going to look for more
templates here
and the one that we are going to choose
is
oh yeah this one so which is small
businesses so you can go ahead and click
on that you can then click on live
preview
and once you do that
you can just
save view frame source
so here you can see that the HTML code
is available
it has the head section and then the
body section
so the head section consists of a lot of
meta tags and then you have the title
and then you also have the CSS file
references
and then if you look at the body tag you
have different code for different parts
of the UI there's code for navigation
bar and then you have page content code
heading row
call to action and all of that and
lastly you have the photo
so what we're going to be doing is that
we'll take all of the code and then
we'll have to create components for each
of it and then we'll include all the
components in our main
HTML file
so that is the best practice that
angular uses so we're going to make use
of components
and you can also see that when you
scroll down you can see that it has
certain dependencies so here it has the
bootstrap dependency and then you have
jQuery so we'll have to download them
so we'll have to install them and as
mentioned earlier we're going to be
installing them with the help of npm
so for that we'll have to head back to
our vs code here
back in my vs code I've created a
folder called angular demo and then I've
also created a file called demo
components
and here
I'm just going to say CD
demo components
within which I'll say npm install
G query
[Music]
so this could take a while
and once you've installed jQuery go
ahead and type npm install bootstrap
[Music]
all right so we've successfully
installed jQuery and bootstrap so now we
need to add the references to these
JavaScript files to do that go to your
angular.json file
and here we'll have to add them in our
build section so here you can see we
have styles and scripts so now scripts
array we Define the relative path to
these JavaScript files so these files
are generally uh stored in your node
modules so go ahead and
here you can look for bootstrap
here you go and then in your dist file
and then click on Js
and then you can see you have
bootstrap.min.js
oh well I'm sorry we need
bootstrap.bundle.min.js so here
you can just right click and say copy
relative path
and back in my Json file in my scripts
I'm gonna just paste it here
and make sure to uh
make it a path while providing by
providing forward slash
[Music]
all right and then the next thing we
need is the
jquery.min.js files so for that
again in our node modules you will have
to look for jQuery so here there's
jQuery and then click on dist
and then we have jquery.min.js
so again let me just copy the path
and paste it here
[Music]
follow the same procedure for this as
well
[Music]
all right so we've embedded both our
files in our
angular.json file
so now in our code here in the beginning
they've also included the CSS file so
we'll have to embed that as well so
here back in bootstrap
let me just add the CSS file as well
that's
bootstrap.min.css I'm just going to copy
the relative path and just provide it
here
[Music]
let me just change these to forward
slash
[Music]
okay so we have our custom style sheet
so what I'm going to do is I'm just
going to copy this
and just paste it in our
and then you can just paste it here
all right
so I think we've added all the
dependencies and the custom style sheet
and everything so now let me just close
all of these files
what we can do now is that we can go
ahead and take the code from The Source
here so I'm just going to copy the body
tag
all right
so
I'm gonna copy this till the footer
and then I'm just going to paste it in
my
component.html file
[Music]
so as mentioned earlier I will create
components and then place the code for
specific parts of the UI in these
components
so let me just see if I've got
everything here
okay
so I'll be creating four components the
first one will be for the navigation bar
the second will be for the introduction
and then the third one will be uh to
display the courses that we're providing
and then lastly we'll have the footer
component
right so first let's create these
components I've also created a
components folder here in my app folder
so I just have to
tap in the command
nggc first we'll create the component
for the top navigation bar so I'm just
saying NG GC so I'm just gonna say
components
slash nav bar
[Music]
all right so uh the component has been
created so what I'm going to do is I'll
just
copy this
[Music]
here
[Music]
all right and the next component I'm
going to be creating is for the
introduction right so I'll say NG g c
components slash intro
all right so
so I will have to take
this code here I'm also going to be
including the call to action part
so I'll just
copy paste this one in my
intro.html file
[Music]
so let me do that and then I'm gonna
have the main course content
component so for that I'll say NG GC
components slash courses
[Music]
foreign
the next part of the code
[Music]
all right until uh till the footer
[Music]
let me just add it here
and finally we're going to create the
component for the footer so I'll say NG
g c
components slash
photo
foreign
I'm just going to add it there
[Music]
all right
so now we'll have to create the custom
HTML tags for these components and then
place it in our HTML file right so first
one that we created was the navigation
bar so here
head over to the TS file
just copy the selector
[Music]
and then your
and then in our
app.component let me just
create the tags
similarly for intro
[Music]
just gonna copy the selector
[Music]
and then for courses so
and add a hyphen courses
that as well
and then lastly we have the footer
components so let me just copy that
paste it here
all right so we've included all the
components so let's just run this
application and see if everything is
displayed in that so here let me just
say NG serve so when you execute the
command you can see that the template is
being displayed so you have the
navigation bar you have the
intro component and then we have the
courses component and finally we have
the footer component right okay so now
that we have the template ready we can
go ahead and customize it according to
our needs so now I'm going to be making
a few changes to the code we're going to
add the simply learn logo we're going to
change the tagline here we're going to
display something else over here all
right so let's go back to our vs code to
customize
and display the final output
so here
the first thing that I'm going to be
doing is
changing the message here I'm gonna
display simply learn for that
in our nav bar component
let's go to the HTML code
and here instead of start bootstrap let
me just type in simply learn
[Music]
all right so when you save it and when
you look at the browser
you can see that
simply learn is displayed
and the next thing that I want to do is
I want to add the image right or simply
learn logo
so what I've done here is I've already
added the logo uh dot PNG file in my
assets folder
so I'll just go ahead and provide the
path to this so that's going to be in
our intro files so here
image source is going to be
[Music]
assets
slash
[Music]
logo dot PNG
so let me save this
so there we go the logo is displayed
so the next thing is we'll have to
change this part of the UI so the
information that I want to display is
this
I'm gonna be displaying
world's number one online boot camp and
other information so what I'm gonna do
is back in my vs code I'm just gonna
delete
this
and instead of that I'm just gonna
copy this that's world's number one
online boot camp
and then within the paragraph tag I'll
display something else so let me get rid
of this
[Music]
let me just copy the information that I
want to display
paste it here
[Music]
and let me just give a line break
[Music]
let me save this and see if it's
displayed
so yeah we can see that the information
is being displayed
next up here instead of displaying call
to action message I'm going to display a
explore programs message so let's go
back to our vs code
let me just say explore
programs here
and then lastly
instead of this message here
I want to display the message or get
certified get ahead without programs so
back in our vs code
I'm just going to get rid of this
[Music]
and paste this instead
foreign
have a look at the browser
Let me refresh this
you can see it displays the message gets
certified get ahead and all of that
uh well now what I'm going to do is I'm
really not happy with the font size and
everything so I'm just go ahead and add
certain styling you can customize this
and provide your own font size and all
of that
so here I'm just gonna mention Style
and then say font size
and I'm going to make it XX large
all right so let's see
[Music]
yeah all right so it's the font size has
increased so I think I'm happy with this
all right so the next thing we have to
do is add information here for our
courses
so back in RBS code
we'll have to go to the courses
component so here I'm gonna just type in
the code for the different courses so I
already have it here so the first thing
is this message that I want to display
let me just copy that
and for our first tag I'm just gonna say
postgraduate program and lean Six Sigma
and the next information I'm going to be
providing is the duration
so here let me just get rid of this
face that Shield
let me just break the line
to beautify the code and then and here
for our reference link I already have
the link here
so I'm just going to paste that so once
you click on the more info button it
will automatically navigate to this page
all right
so let me see this
next up I'm gonna do the same for the
other two courses as well
foreign
development
and then we're going to mention the
duration and the cohort so
let me paste that
and also provide a line break
and then link I have it here so
I'm just gonna paste that
[Music]
and finally for the third card I have
the third link here
[Music]
let me get rid of this extra core and
paste this instead
[Music]
and then let's also provide the link for
the same
all right
so let me save this
and have a look at the browser
so you can see that the information has
been added you can see it displays
postgraduate program in lean sex Sigma
full step development and cyber security
so once I click on more info it leads
you to that
page
that shows the overview all right
so now the next thing on the agenda was
to display a short video and then the
link to our YouTube channel so let's go
ahead and add that in our
cautious component
so what I'm going to do is I'm just
going to get the code to add a video
from Google and then I'm going to
provide the source uh which is going to
be the video that I would want to
display
so I've received the code I'm just going
to paste it here
so you can get the code uh on Google so
go ahead and just paste that also for
the source I have a video in my assets
folder which I have provided here
so when I save it and look at the
browser here we go you can see the video
here
all right
and once clicked it starts playing
[Music]
all right and lastly we'll have to
provide the logo for YouTube and then
the link to navigate to the YouTube page
so let's go ahead and do that
so here again I've pasted the code
for the YouTube logo so here you can see
that I've added the image that is
YouTube dot PNG in my assets folder and
I've provided the source
and accordingly I've also added
The Styling I've provided a white
background and I've also aligned the
text to the center of the page
all right and I've also displayed the
message saying check out our YouTube
channel for technical videos and
tutorials
and then I provided the link to our
Channel on YouTube so let me just save
this and head back to the browser
and here you can see that
we have the YouTube logo
and we have the message displayed so
once you click on the
logo it navigates to the simply learn
Channel on YouTube
all right so uh if you want you can also
change the message here for the footer
so here in footer.html I can just
remove this and
paste this I say simply learn Solutions
and All Rights Reserved and I save it
and look at the browser
it must get updated
so yeah there we go
so with the help of bootstrap we have
successfully created a website which is
basically a Blog
and we've also added the reference links
and images and logos to customize it
according to our requirements
so yeah this is it this is how you make
use of bootstrap and embed it into your
angular for more responsive and better
user interface let's have a look at the
basics of routing
now I'm sure that you've observed that
the URL changes every time you click on
a particular link or on an icon on the
user interface correct now this
basically indicates that you are
navigating throughout the application
now to achieve this navigation we use a
mechanism called routing routing is
essentially used to navigate through a
website or a web application
but how is it achieved in angular
especially in angular routing plays a
major role it is used to create a single
page applications
now these applications are loaded just
once and new content is added
dynamically applications like Google
Facebook Twitter and Gmail are a few
examples of single page applications the
best part of using single page
applications is that it provides an
excellent user experience and you don't
even have to wait for new pages to load
which by extension makes single page
applications extremely fast but how is
this new content loaded
enter routing now routing is the
mechanism that as discussed earlier that
is used to navigate through the
application and load new content
routing helps angular configure the
route and the component that needs to be
displayed
now I'm sure you're going to understand
the concept of routing better when you
work on it Hands-On
so in the demo we're going to be
navigating to the login and the home
pages of a web application with the help
of routing
so let's head to our Visual Studio code
so basically the objective of our
application is to navigate to home and
the login pages so when I click on the
login icon here it loads the login page
and here you can see the extension
slash login and similarly with home once
you click on it some new information
gets added and the URL changes
with a slash home appended all right so
this is the main objective of our
application so to create it let's head
back to our vs code all right so here
I've created a folder called demo and
underscore angular and I've created a
file called demo routing
now the first thing you want to do is
open the index.html file and make sure
that the base tag is added now although
this is generally added when your app is
created if it is not then add a base tag
with href attribute which is set to a
forward slash
all right now this is generally done to
tell angular to construct the URL while
navigating with a forward slash all
right and the next thing you want to do
is open your app dot module.ts file and
check if the app routing module has been
imported
if not go ahead and import it and then
also mention it in your Imports array
or with that the initial setup is done
Now to create the nav bar the code that
I'm going to be using is already
explained in the previous video that is
angular bootstrap I highly suggest you
go through that video before watching
this
so uh the code is already available I'm
just going to create a component and
write the code for it and paste the code
in it so let's do that
let me say NG g c
NAB bar
[Music]
or as of this component is now created
now here in my HTML file
I'll just get rid of this and paste the
code for the nav bar
so here we go I've pasted the code for
the navigation bar
and back in my
app.component.html file I'll just remove
all The Unwanted code here
and just specify the
custom HTML tag for my nav bar
so let me just create one here
all right let me save this let me just
run the application and see if it's
displaying correctly all right so when I
open the browser uh the navigation bar
has been created
along with these different options
that's home about services and login
all right and we also have the simply
learn icon here all right now the next
step is to generate the components to
display the login page content and the
home page content now again I have used
bootstrap to define the user interface
for these files you can easily find the
code online just search for a bootstrap
login templates and depending on your
requirements you can choose the
appropriate one
so first let's create the components for
by two files that is for the home
component
and the login component
so let's go ahead and do that
[Music]
nggc
I'm just going to call it login for my
login component
all right and then I'm gonna say nggc
home for the home component
all right
so I'm just going to copy the code for
the login component
so back in my login.html
file
I'll just paste the code here
okay
also note that I've added the simply
learn logo in my assets folder
and then just provided the source for it
here in my login component
all right
so next up is the home component
and if you've seen the previous video
that is angular bootstrap you might have
seen that we created three different
components that is intro courses and
footer which included the content for
the intro message for the courses and
the footer message correct so here we're
going to just paste the code for all of
these three
and then just display it when the home
button is clicked
all right so what I'm going to do is
I'll just paste it here
[Music]
so this basically has all the content uh
one thing I want to tell you is that in
the previous video we made sure that the
code was written in three different
components however for this I've just
added all the code in the same component
now I agree that this is not the best
practice so if you want you can go ahead
and create three different components
and separate the code into these three
components and just add the custom HTML
tags in your home component
I'm just hoping you're uh following me
right now and also here in my assets
folder I've added a video and the
YouTube logo that needs to be displayed
uh when the home icon is clicked all
right so now that we've created the home
and the login components the next step
is to configure the routes for the
application right so here you can see
that we have a file called app routing
module.ts file
so here we have the routes and the
router module that is imported and we
also have a constant called routes which
is strongly typed two routes from the
router package
all right now this array is used to
define all the possible routes in the
application now each route is basically
an object with a path so here in my
routes array I'm just going to go ahead
and create the paths that is we have two
different uh routes right one is for
login and one is for home
so I'm just going to create a path
object so let's say path
sorry within curly braces I say path
[Music]
and then the path that I'm going to give
is login
this is basically what will appear uh on
the URL all right and the component that
needs to be
navigated to is nothing but the login
component
so let me just say login
component as you can see the login
component has been automatically
imported
now same with
uh the Home Path so let me just say
but
home
and the component that needs to be
rendered is the home component
[Music]
all right
now the next step is to link these
routes to a button
in the navbar that is the home and the
login button right so we're gonna make
use of the nav tag and an anchor tag for
this
you can see that we have a nav tag
and an anchor tag
which encloses the login and the home
components
all right now we're going to make use of
two directives from the router package
called router link and router link
active now these are specified within
the anchor tag the router link basically
holds the path to the page
and the latter that is the router link
active specifies one or more CSS classes
that will be applied when the router
link is active
all right so to do that let me just add
router
link
all right in our case it is home here
and we're gonna have another director
called router link active
[Music]
and we're just gonna say active here
[Music]
all right
same for the login icon here
and you just copy this
[Music]
and instead of home
the path we created for this was login
[Music]
all right
so this is how you can bind the route to
your specific button on your UI
now despite of all this how are we
specifying where these components are to
be displayed
right the answer to this is using the
router Outlet director now again this
directive is available in the router
package so we have to add that in our
app component.html file
so here just go ahead and type
router Outlet
all right so with that we've created a
simple navigation bar which has
different options that is home about
services and Link and once the user
clicks on the home icon it displays the
content that is in the home
component.html file and once the user
clicks on the login component it
displays the content in the login.html
file
all right it's as simple as that so now
let's go to the browser and see if it
executes correctly
so all right we have the navigation bar
and once I click on the home icon here
all right yes we see that all the
content has been loaded
you can see we have uh the intro section
we have the courses section and the
footer section as discussed
and the most important part is that here
in our URL you can see that slash home
has been appended this shows that a
route has been created that navigates to
the home component so we've successfully
created a route here
and for login component when I click on
this icon you can see that the path
changes here and the login component
gets displayed
all right so this is how routing is
achieved in angular so what exactly is
node.js now consider a scenario where a
user interacts with a web application
the user only interacts with the front
end of the application but there's a lot
of work that goes behind the scenes now
in a web application there's a front end
a server and a database the front end is
developed using JavaScript and
Frameworks like angular and react while
the server is built on Java PHP or
node.js and the backend database that
stores the data usually consists of
MySQL or mongodb so node.js is an open
source cross-platform JavaScript runtime
environment for running server-side
applications it is used to develop i o
intensive web applications like video
streaming sites single page applications
online chatting applications and other
web applications it is used by large
established companies and newly minted
startups node.js was developed by Ryan
Dal in 2009 and at the same time of this
session its latest version is v13 point
3.0 now that we know what node.js is
let's go ahead and look at why it was so
prevalent in the field of web
development here are a few points first
up node.js is extremely fast being built
on Google Chrome's V8 JavaScript engine
its library is extremely fast in code
execution node package manager has
around 50 000 bundles for developers so
whatever functionality is required for
an application can be easily imported
from npm all apis of node.js Library are
asynchronous that is non-blocking it
means a node.js based server never waits
for an API to return data node.js
dramatically reduces the processing time
while uploading video and audio files it
is also an open source platform and is
easy for beginners for web development
the above reasons more than justify the
popularity of node.js platform and why
it is being adopted by large number of
organizations and businesses today so
now moving on let's familiarize
ourselves with the parts of node.js
node.js consists of several components
now let's look at them one by one first
up we have modules now modules are like
JavaScript libraries which are used in a
node.js application to include a set of
functions now we can use required
function with the parenthesis to include
a module in a node.js application
node.js application has many modules to
provide basic functionality needed for a
web application some of them could be
HTTP util FS URL query string stream and
zlip next up we have console the console
module provides a simple debugging
console that is similar to the
JavaScript console mechanism provided by
web browsers now the console can print
messages to STD out that print standard
output messages and SCD air to print the
error messages the next component is
cluster now node.js is built upon the
concept of single threading programming
a single instance of node.js runs in a
single thread to take advantage of
multi-core systems the user will
sometimes want to launch a cluster of
node.js processes to handle the load a
class can be added to an application in
this way here's a small code for you the
next component is global now global
objects in node.js are available in all
modules now these objects are functions
modules strings Etc some node.js Global
objects are mentioned in the table you
have dir name that is a directory name
file name exports module and require the
next component is error handling now
node.js applications experience four
types of Errors we have the standard
JavaScript errors system errors user
specific errors and assertion errors now
errors in node.js are handled through
exceptions now for example let's handle
an error that would occur when we divide
a number by zero now this error would
crash the node.js application and so we
should handle this error here's a small
code for you next up we have streaming a
stream is an abstract interface for
working with streaming data in node.js
streams are objects that let you read
data or write data continuously there
are four types of streams first one is
readable these are the types of streams
from which data can be read writeable
these are the types of streams to which
data can be written duplex these are
both readable and writable streams
lastly we have transformed these streams
can manipulate the data while it is
being read or written moving on to the
next component buffer the JavaScript
language has no mechanism for reading or
manipulating streams of binary data
buffer is a module that allows handling
streams that contain only binary data an
empty buffer of length 10 can be created
by this method next up we have domain
domains provide a way to handle
different i o operations as a single
group domain module intercepts errors
that remain unhandled there are two
types of methods that are used for
intercepting these errors firstly we
have enter internal binding in this case
the error emitter executes its code
inside the arrow method next up is the
external binding now here the error
emitter is explicitly added to a domain
via its add method the next component is
the DNS the DNS module enables name
resolution for example it is used to
look up the IP addresses of host names
DNS module is used to connect to a DNS
server and perform neem resolution by
using the method dns.resolve the DNS
module is also used for performing name
resolution without a network
communication by using the method
dns.lookup the next component is a
debugger node.js includes an out of
process debugging utility accessible via
a V8 inspector and built-in debugging
client this node.js debugger is not
feature packed but supports simple
inspection of code it can be used in the
terminal by using the inspect keyword
before the name of the Javascript file
in order to inspect a file say
myscript.js you can use the following
method now that we are familiar with all
the major parts of node.js let's go
ahead and learn about the node.js
Express framework Express is a flexible
node.js web application framework that
provides a wide set of features to
develop both web and mobile applications
you can assume Express as a layer built
on top of the node.js that helps manage
the server and the routes now let's have
a quick look at some of the core
features of Express framework it is used
to design single page multi-page and
hybrid web applications it allows the
setting up of middleware to respond to
http requests it defines a routing table
that is used to perform different
actions based on the HTTP method and URL
it also allows Dynamic rendering of HTML
Pages based on passing arguments to
templates now moving on let's take a
quick example of a simple hello world
program now this is developed using
Express framework to gain a better
understanding alright first up we have
the WHERE Express now this is used to
import Express framework into our
node.js application now the app.get
method is a callback function with
parameters request and response the
request object represents the HTTP
request and has properties for the
request query string parameters body
HTTP headers Etc the response object
represents the HTTP response that an
Express app sends when it gets an HTTP
request now the application will listen
to the defined Port which in this case
is 8081 and variables host and Port will
contain the address and the port
respectively lastly we have the
console.log which is used to show the
address and port in the command prompt
so this is what the command prompt would
look like and finally the output is
displayed on the web browser Having
learned about the Express framework now
let's move on and look at the node.js
use cases now it is no doubt that node
stands out for its speed and intensive
data exchange so top industry leaders
like NASA PayPal Netflix among others
incorporate node.js first up we have
Netflix the world's leading internet
television network with over 117 million
users is one of the top companies that
trusted their server services to node.js
the reasons why the company chose to use
node.js were application scalability and
data intensive application now you must
be wondering what application
scalability is this basically the
potential of an application to grow in
time being able to efficiently handle
more and more requests per minute and
data intensive application allows
millions of people to stream Netflix
simultaneously next up is Walmart now
Walmart is the world's largest company
by Revenue with around 514 billion US
Dollars according to the fortune Global
500 list in 2019. again the reasons why
the company chose node.js were
asynchronous IO and efficient handling
of concurrent requests now asynchronous
IO which is a form of input output
processing allows other processing to
continue before the transmission has
finished node.js is able to efficiently
handle concurrent requests with the use
of thread pool and event cues Uber Uber
is an American multinational ride
hailing company offering services that
include peer-to-peer ride sharing right
service healing and food delivery the
reasons why the company chose node.js
were asynchronous i o quick iterations
and active open source Community as
mentioned earlier asynchronous IO
permits other processing to continue
before the transmission has finished now
quick iterations now node.js is
continually being updated and added new
features that help in further
Improvement in the performance of web
servers and finally active open source
Community resolves many problems that an
organization May face in a particular
scenario next up we have NASA now NASA
as an independent agency of the United
States federal government responsible
for the civilian space program as well
as Aeronautics and Aerospace research
the reasons why the company chose
node.js were reduced access times
handling of data intensive tasks and the
fact that the servers are active 24 7.
now NASA has lots and lots of data and
using node.js has really helped them in
reducing the access times it is also
continuously handling and working with
large streams of data node.js is highly
stable which helps in keeping the server
active 24 7. next up we have PayPal now
PayPal is an American company operating
a worldwide online payment system that
supports online money transfers as
opposed to traditional methods like
checks and money orders the reasons why
the company chose to use node.js were
the fact that node.js has extremely fast
build times it allows tasks to be
carried out with fewer lines of code
when compared to other server
Technologies like Java and PHP and
node.js being data intensive efficiently
handles a large amount of data next up
is medium medium is a popular online
publishing platform developed by Evan
Williams and launched in August 2012.
the main reasons why the company chose
to use node.js were a data driven
applications now these applications are
ideal for being interfaced with node.js
servers B to run a b tests now A B
testing is essentially an experiment
where two or more variants of a page are
shown to users at random and statistical
analysis is used to determine which
variation performs better lastly node.js
server maintenance is simpler than its
counterparts moving on to the last topic
of this session industry Trends now
node.js developers are in demand across
the globe since many companies are
adopting JavaScript libraries according
to Forbes it is one of the top 10 most
in-demand jobs according to node Source
the total number of node.js downloads
increase by 40 in the last one year the
use of node.js in production has
increased dramatically since its release
in 2010. with early adopters such as
LinkedIn PayPal and Netflix among others
node.js has seen an exponential increase
in its use in web development the
popularity of node.js is also accounted
to JavaScript now since JavaScript is
the most popular language as evident
from a survey conducted by stack
Overflow in 2019 many developers can
start working on node.js library with
not much of a learning curve node.js
developers are being offered better
salary options than another web
technology developers according to pay
scale the average salary of a node.js
developer in India is around 6 lakhs 13
000 rupees per year the average salary
of a node.js developer across the United
States is around 105 000 US dollars per
year in this video we'll help you
install node.js on your Windows system
so without further Ado let's begin the
first thing you need to do is download
node.js from their official website so
go ahead and type download node.js
navigate to their official website and
here
you can see the 64-bit version so go
ahead and download that once the
download is done go ahead and run the
downloaded node.js installer
accept the license agreement keep the
default settings as it is
and then say install
so with that we finish the installation
process
once node has been successfully
installed the next crucial step is
verification now this process ensures
that node has been properly installed to
do so we first open the command prompt
and then type in a few commands to
verify the successful installation we
type in this command
node hyphen V now this command Returns
the version and if it Returns the
version it means it has been
successfully installed
so here we go it Returns the latest
version
now the final step is to update the node
package manager now this npm is bundled
with node.js which consists of all the
repositories and packages required for
development purposes so to do that type
in the command npm
install npm
hyphen hyphen Global now that we're done
with the installation of node let's go
ahead and Implement a small program for
that we make use of a text editor in our
case we've installed vs code so go ahead
and download vs code once you're done
with the installation this is what vs
code looks like so go ahead and click on
file and create a new file it's going to
be a simple program where you're going
to print a hello world message on the
web browser to do that we make use of
HTTP modules so node comes with built-in
HTTP modules to transfer data across it
so for that we make use of a require
method we create a variable first say
where
HTTP equals require
and just say HTTP within single quotes
now the HTTP module can create an HTTP
server that listens to the server ports
and gives a response back to the client
to do that we make use of the create
server method so let's go ahead and type
the code
say http
dot create
server and in turn Elite consists of a
function now the parameters of this
function are request and response now
the response is basically used to write
to the client so we say response dot
write and here we type in the message
say hello world
welcome
to this tutorial
once you're done with that you end the
response
so the server listens to a port number
to display the message by default it
listens to the port number 8080 so we
keep that as it is and we end it save
your file
say demo.js maybe demo1.js and JC now to
run the program you have to open the
command prompt so open your command
prompt
and mention the path to your file so in
our case it's our desktop saved on the
desktop so CD
desktop and now to run it say node
demo one dot JS now we navigate to your
browser
and say localhost 8080 and here we go a
message is successfully displayed so
let's talk about the node.js
architecture and understand why it's so
good
so to begin with uh node.js has what's
called a single threaded event Loop
architecture and this allows you to be
able to handle many many and current
clients at the same time it's just a
very flexible way of being able to scale
up your support for many clients
and then in addition to that we have the
JavaScript event based model along with
the JavaScript callback mechanism that
allows you to have this standard
approach to being able to connect with
and talk and discuss interactions
between the client and the server it's
good to have these kind of Standards
where you're not using something that's
unique to a specific framework or a
specific technology and this just makes
it so it's a more accessible for
everybody
so if we look at the actual node.js
server itself everything centers around
the the concept of the event Loop and
the event Loop has a a an event queue an
operation completed um fire request
threaded pull and then it'll actually do
the actual computation or the file
system interaction
all of this interconnects in a nice
seamless Loop the great thing again with
node.js is that it's not new technology
it's been around for almost a decade
it's very very well tried out many of
the largest websites out there are runny
node.js
so let's now dig into each of the parts
of the node.js architecture so let's
talk about requests
so the way that the request works is
that you have your framework uh such as
angular on the client and that will then
send a request to the web server there's
many ways that those requests can happen
through web workers through forms and
through other interactions but at some
point a request is sent to the server
and so these requests can be for data it
can be for deleting data they can be for
updating data they can be for
interacting with Services as mentioned
before but the goal is to have some kind
of request now once that request
actually hits the server and then we
start actually getting into the queuing
and threading process that centers
around the event Loop and this is where
node.js really excels because it's able
to use that single threaded model to be
able to manage from just even a few
requests to tens of millions of requests
so it receives the actual request and
starts the event here and this is where
a single threading process starts is by
queuing everything up appropriately
and then it then maintains the thread
within a pool so you have the queuing
process as one action and then you have
a threaded pull which manages those
threads as well
and then we have an event Loop which you
know goes through actually receives and
processes those requests
and then finally what we're doing is
we're actually then going to be
interacting with a system and they could
be a database it could be a cloud system
it could be an API file system but we're
interacting with something that's
outside of the node.js server so the
node.js server itself is doing some
actions on the server but then it's also
interact with things outside of its own
server environment
and so this talk a little bit about that
workflow so requests come in they go
into the event queue and they get
spiraled through the event Loop and then
we have a non-blocking operators which
are going to be doing the input output
polling such as KQ e-poll and other
services and from there we're also going
to be then interacting with a threaded
pool and we're using the blocking
operations to manage that threaded pull
and that threaded pool is going to now
then go outside of the server and
interact with something beyond the
server so whether that is a database or
file system or API or microservice these
are things that can be interacted with
so let's go through what npm is so npm
itself stands for the node package
manager
no great shakes there as the name says
it's responsible for all the packages
and modules that are bundled Within
node.js
so the notebook imagine itself really
has two key functionalities now the
first is that reply it is a central
repository for all packages and modules
which you can then search through um
online you can go to
search.nodejs.org and you can find all
of the package of modules that are out
there the second is that it's also a
command line or terminal line utility
that allows you to install those
packages so you can actually go through
and you can see the version management
and dependencies that within those
packages and you actually can control
the packages themselves
so why would you use npm
so npm is really useful for being able
to extend the project you're working on
so when you're building out a project
one of the concepts I like to use is the
concept of Lego bricks
um big fan of Lego and uh what's great
about Lego bricks is that they're all
individually by themselves very small
very specific functionality but if you
actually get a whole collection of Lego
bricks together you can build like crazy
cool things so think of when you're
working with the node package manager
itself is that each of those individual
pieces that you're working with each of
those individual packages are their own
Lego bricks and by themselves you can
then edit and update and maintain that
piece separately from the whole
environment as long as your inputs and
outputs you know really the piece where
you snap the Lego in or when you connect
the Lego to something else are
interacted and open and well documented
then you can actually then use those
modules effectively throughout your
project
um so you can actually then be able to
do that you can do Version Control on
your codes and dependencies you can do
testing very easily
and then once you actually get to the
point where you go yes I want to release
um a new module you can do that
effectively using npm and it will
actually go through and do the actual
deployment for you
so let's go through the npm installation
so the actual package manager itself is
included with the installation of
node.js so if you've installed and
you're running node.js locally then
you've already installed the package
manager but you can also access it
through command line or terminal window
on your data server or in your server or
via the cloud
uh if you haven't now downloaded node.js
uh here's the website where you can go
down to install it and there's Windows
and Mac versions of that code as well
with the installers which allow you to
get up and going very quickly
you want to be able to run the installer
and accept all the default settings uh
just uh you know to begin with you want
to kind of have the standard setup so
that you are most familiar with the
normal settings before you start getting
to the point where you're a master and
you're tweaking things
um there is a way that you can open up
the command window or The Terminal
window and once you've actually
installed node.js to verify that it's
actually installed you can write the
command node dash dash version and
they'll actually then pull out the
version of node.js that you have
installed and then you'll be able to see
that you've got it actually up and
running
and then you can also do the same thing
for npm where you can do npm version and
actually will then show you which
version of the node package manager you
have running so you can actually take it
full advantage of that program and
verify that it's actually up and running
so let's actually look inside of a
package so packages themselves are
actually just Json files if you're new
to this space Json file is a structured
file format that's based on JavaScript
it's a very XML like format for being
able to write instructions for the
actual package itself and so the Json
file forms that you know really kind of
the the heart of each package you create
um it has all of the metadata that you'd
have about a particular object and then
it provides a route directory to any of
the applications or modules that the
package may be referencing
um in addition
um it has any other additional um
information about the project that adds
such as dependencies and other files
that need to be included so here we have
is an example of a package and that
would be created using npm json's um
script
and you can actually take this package
file as it is right here and use the
command npm in it and it'll actually run
this package and so you would actually
then have a demo application up and
running really quickly
uh you can then go ahead if you want so
you can edit any of these parameters so
like for instance if you wanted to
change the description or the version uh
or what is the the main index script
that would be written you know these are
all things that you can edit very
quickly and easily you can just use text
editor to make any of these edits
and so we have the different metadata
that can be updated
and so this is where we go in and do a
full demo of working with npm
so what we're going to do now is we're
actually going to go ahead and actually
run a demo of using npm and to do that
I've got three windows in front of me
right now so I have this window here
which is my terminal window where I'll
be doing all of my instructions uh then
I also have a folder which shows where
I'll be putting all of the files and
then finally I'll actually have a text
editor in this case I'm using vs code
because it's free but you can use any
text edit you like to be able to go in
and show what the code that has been
created by npm in the Json file so you
can actually see what it looks like and
then we'll modify it a little bit so
first thing we want to do is we want to
go ahead and create a new project folder
so I'm going to go in I'm just going to
move into
change directory I'm going to the
project folder and we'll see down here
that we have an empty project folder but
for this one I'm actually going to go
ahead and create a new directory in this
one and I'm going to call this one
simply learn
and there we are we've created a new
simply lamb folder
and we are going to move into the
symphony lab folder
and so we're now in the simply land
folder there's nothing in that right now
um so the first thing we want to do is
we want to take uh go ahead and
initialize this folder as a project
folder for working with npm now to do
this you will have to have already
installed npm if you have node.js npm
comes with it and if you want to see
whether or not you have npm installed so
you can just do npm
version
and that will actually tell you what the
version of npm you have installed is it
also verifies that npm is installed so
I've gone ahead and I've been able to
validate that I have npm installed so
what I'm now going to go ahead and do is
I'm going to initialize this folder so
to do that just do npm init and you'll
see that the path is that we're already
in the simply learn folder and then when
you do that
it's going to ask you some questions so
what is the package name we're going to
go with the defaults for right now and
then I can show you how we can edit
those in a little bit uh we're going to
go with just say yes to all of these
just by hitting return
and you'll see here that we're going to
create a new folder called a
package.json folder this is the
instructions that we have in the folder
do we want to go ahead and create this
we want to and it's going to go ahead
and do that and we can see now in our
folder here that we actually have
package.json so if I go ahead and open
this up with
vs code here we are we can actually see
what all the information is we can go
ahead and we can actually go and update
uh this metadata if we want to I'm going
to leave it as is for right now because
I want to show you a couple of other
things so a lot of times when you're
actually working with npm and the reason
why you're using npm is that you want to
take advantage of packages that are
freely available in the open source
community that are supported by you know
JS and one of those is a package called
Express and express is a lightweight
framework for building out web
applications similar concept to angular
or react.js I like using it and it's
also a great way to be able to show how
we can install this using npm so to
install this you just start with the
command npm and then you type in store
and then we type the name of the package
and we hit
enter and it goes ahead
and what you'll actually see
is a couple of things one is we have a
dependency in our package above we also
have so this is in our Json package that
it's now a dependency it's written in
there we can also go in and under our
node modules we actually see that we
have let me scroll down we should see
Express
there it is Express
now if we decide that we don't want to
use um Express we can actually just come
in and we can write command npm
uninstall
and type
Express
Oops I did a typo there so let's try
that again npm
uninstall
Express
and couple things can happen one is in
our Json file the dependency for the
express file has now been removed
and we can also see that under arm node
modules there are no extensions there
so this is kind of cool this allows us
to be able to see that we can easily add
and remove packages so let's just go
ahead and I'm going to install Express
again so
installed Express
oops npm install Express
all right so it's gone ahead and it's
installed Express
now one of the things that often happen
is that when you're working with a
package the actual Json package so
you'll receive this file and you want to
be able to go ahead and install of the
sub modules that come with it so and you
can go through you can manually install
like this or you can actually run an
install command so you can actually
install all of them at once I could just
show you what that looks like
because we're going to actually go ahead
and simulate as if we're going to
install bootstrap
which is another
popular framework
I'm actually going to go with
and then we'll save that
and what we'll see is under the packages
that bootstrap isn't listed in there we
do have Express there it is right there
so we now come over to our new commands
we can actually write the command
npm install
and now
site typo let's try that again
let's do npm
install
okay it does help to save your file so
let's go ahead and
let's run npm install
and when you do that what we'll now
actually have is not just
Express but we'll also see that
bootstrap has also been added
now I don't recommend that you use the
star symbol which will install the
latest version of bootstrap because you
obviously haven't tested your
application against that but it gives
you an idea of and of what's happened
here now if we want to we can actually
go in here and we can see on in
install
bootstrap
and it will actually remove that from
your Json package so there we are that's
how you work with using npm from getting
started with a setup for a base
initialization of your package going
through to creating the first package
being able to set up and control the
naming convention for each of the items
within the metadata that provides the
instruction for the package how you can
then put in dependencies such as Express
and bootstrap how you can install them
and remove them and actually use do all
of this through command line if you have
any questions please let us know
so let's kind of jump into the
express.js framework
so express.js is a really flexible
node.js and web application framework it
is just something you can spin up very
quickly and build both web and mobile
applications just a really great tool um
you know I use it all the time for
building up my own applications
the thing that's so great about it is
it's really simple and so and it's not
going to be as have all the the
functionality that you'd have in maybe a
larger scale HTTP service but with that
said it does come with a lot of
functionality that allows you to not
only create websites but you can also do
apis and other routing calls very very
nice
so let's go through some of the features
that expressjs have
so as I mentioned before it allows you
to build simple web applications and
they can be either a single page
application or a multi-page application
it also allows you to do middleware
requests and responses so for instance
if you want to do an API and have that
be part of your middleware you can
actually set that up real quickly in
fact in the demo that we'll do later on
we'll actually be building out four
different API calls that you'll be able
to do and you'll be able to see how you
can use express.js for that and that in
then turns allows you to be able to see
how express.js can help manage some of
the routing of the different HTTP
methods and that you'd be using via URL
and then finally it's just a great way
of being able to dynamically test the
work that you are developing so you can
actually build out a solution and test
it right away and express.js have it in
a single packet and then once you get to
a certain point you can then check in
the whole packet and even have it as
part of your container and then check
that into your main project and then if
somebody else wants to then take on the
work they can then just pull that in so
let's kind of go step through a you know
a basic example so here we actually have
a full script for creating a simple
hello world and this includes installing
express.js defining the ports it's going
to run on as well as a basic piece of
code so the first thing you want to do
is actually go ahead and Define how you
want to install express.js and this is
called the very first variable which is
requiring that Express being installed
as part of node packet manager npm will
then pull in the latest version of
Express if you need to define a specific
version of course you can do that in
this example we're just going to pull
the latest one and then we'll go ahead
and with the second line which will then
install Express and when you do it once
you'll see how quickly it stores onto
your local development machine
the next parameters are actually a
callback function so if something
actually happens when you go to the
website where we're going to run our web
application you want something to pop up
and in this instance we'll say hello
world will pop up
the third block is all about where you
would actually go ahead and host your
code and so in this one you'll see that
the server is going to listen and listen
to Port 8081 so that's what that
function actually there defines
and then you can either put in uh the
specific host address in the demo you'll
actually see how we Define that for
localhost but you can actually then
point this to a production host
environment if you want
and then the final line here is a
command that actually sent a script to
your terminal window telling you that
which port and which host that you are
listening to so let's see what that
would look like so here we can see have
our terminal window and we're actually
able to then run the hello world JS
script that we just wrote and then once
we do that it'll actually then post that
we have an example app listening ads and
here we don't have a web domain address
and we do have the the port 8081
and in our browse window it says hello
world
so that's a quick breakdown of
express.js now let's jump over and do a
demo
so the first thing we want to do to get
Express up and running on our system is
we have to have node.json sword so we're
just going to do a Google search to let
you know where you can find node.js it's
actually at
nodejs.org so we select that link
that'll take us to nodejs.org and there
are two types of downloads one is the
current download which has the latest
features and then there's a more stable
version that if you are new to node.js
I'd recommend you to download next we
want to find a text editor and we're
going to go with Visual Studio code or
vs code AS known it's an open source
solution from Microsoft that runs across
all the leading platforms so this will
default to our Windows platform but you
can run it on Mac OS and Linux as well I
really like it it's a great code it
comes a lot of extensions and it's open
source
and next thing you want to do is because
we're going to be developing apis we
want a way to be able to visualize those
apis quickly and a great tool is a
product called Postman again open source
and so you can go out and go to
postman.com top right hand corner you'll
see a bright orange download button
where you can actually go and head and
download and install Postman and that
will allow you to be able to access all
of your apis that we're going to be
creating in Express
you can actually use other tools such as
apigee as well for visualizing your apis
but this one's just great to get you
started so let's go ahead and open up vs
code and we want to go ahead and open a
new folder where we're going to have our
project we're going to just for our
demonstration here we're going to put
this on the desktop you wouldn't
normally do this but it will work fine
here we're going to create a folder
we're going to title the file the node
Express and we'll select that folder and
that now becomes the root folder for our
project in Visual Studio we don't really
need the the welcome screen anymore so
we're going to get rid of that
and one of the things that is great
about working with vs code is you can
actually have the terminal window up and
running as well so let's go ahead and
open that so it's running at the bottom
of our screen and this gives us a little
bit of space
and the first thing we want to do is
actually turn convert the folder we're
in actually into a project running
node.js so we're going to use npm init
and they'll actually initialize the
project we have another video that
explains how to use npm or node package
manager and you can go ahead and find
that um in our library here but as we go
ahead and we do that you'll actually see
that it will create the default package
Json file which has the name of the
folder is the default name of the
package but you can actually go in and
edit any of these documents
we want to create a default file as
called index.js this is what we're going
to write most of our scripts that allow
us to work with node.js
and the first is writing a script that
allows us to install Express and we'll
use the node packet manager to actually
pull and install Express and you can
fault to specific versions of Express if
you want and we're just going to go with
the latest one so we're just going to
put in Express and then we'll go down
into terminal window and say npm install
dash dash save Express and this will
install Express so we can actually test
out the code we're working on
and this is to be just a moment to
install
great thing we're working with node
package manager is that once we've
finished with our package here we can
actually wrap it all up and send it over
to any other developer that we're
working with and then you can actually
run the the package and actually have
exactly the same code installed
and there we are we have everything
installed and ready to go
we can see we actually have all of the
modules installed you'll see that we
actually have Express installed as well
and we also want to then make this an
app
and then we'll do app listen
to Port 3000 so this is by default we're
going to be running from our Local Host
which is uh HTTP server running on this
test machine and we're going to have
Express for this project run on Port
3000.
and in the once we actually run the
script we'll actually post into the
console
um window a piece of text saying server
started on Port 3000
so we're going to go ahead and save this
file a little control s to save these
files
so let's go into localhost in our web
browser so localhost colon sorry uh yeah
it's localhost column 3000 and you'll
see nothing has been reached that's
because we actually haven't done
anything to initialize the script so we
want to come in and we're going to go
node index.js and hit return and as you
can see now we have a message in our
console window that means that yep there
we go we actually have everything up and
running so we can actually see that the
service is running not a very pleasant
message so let's go ahead and change
that
so let's change that to
app get
and
acquire res
and so we've used the get message that's
change what we'll print
and we'll type hello there
exclamation mark
I'm going to save that
and we refresh the screen
oh nothing happened again because we
didn't run the script let's go back in
and we'll run the script node index.js
and now what you'll see is if we refresh
there we are we have our new hello there
message
all right well let's actually start
building some apis in this environment
so to be able to build the apis we want
to be able to pull content so we can
actually create a new file called
users.js and we're going to create
I'm going to go ahead and create a a
user's Json packet and a Json packet is
essentially
a an array and as you consider it like a
small database and in this array we're
going to have four objects each object
is going to have three pieces of
metadata we have an ID name and email
and there'll be ID 1 2 and 3 and then
you'll see that the names will be John
Smith and we'll make up a couple of
others I'm just kind of giving them
arbitrary email addresses
it's just for our demo here
let me grab this copy it and kind of
speed up
the script writing time
there we go
and let's just change what we need and
one of the things that's nice with
working with the visual studio code vs
code is there's lots of plugins and so
one of the default features is that if
you select a variable it'll actually
look for the same variable in the script
so you can if you need to you can
actually change them all in once
but we don't need to worry about that
right now we're just creating a Json
packet so we have four items
ID one two three and four for John Smith
and Jack and Chris
all right so that's our
erased string and we're going to then
make sure that we can export that as
users so we can actually now whenever we
select the term users in our scripts
you'll actually pull in this packet
all right looking good
now let's go over to our main index.js
file and we're actually going to go
ahead and we want to like Store where
the the API is going to be so we're
going to create a photocore route and
then a subfolder called API
and then we'll call a file in there
called users.js so as we're updating our
scripts we know where to
pull the data from
it's just a standard way of being able
to pull out the values so in here we're
going to say in this instance Express is
required
for our Scripts
and we're going to also say that from
router
within Express router
correct naming convention
and the script is case sensitive we'll
also want to create a value later on
that will have a unique ID so we're
actually going to pull in a uuid
package that will actually then allow us
to install unique identifiers so we use
node package manager to install uuid
again this is a great example of how you
can go from nothing to something very
quickly with Express
node.js because we've installed Express
we installed uuid and we're off to races
so that's have users require the path
for where our API is going to be located
all right so let's do a basic get which
will be to pull the records and we're
going to have it pull all the records so
router.get and we're going to require it
to pull all of the records in the Json
packet that we created
so there should be four items to come
back
save that
looks good
make sure that users is consistent
there's our Json packet
and yep everything's looking pretty good
all right let's go back to index
and we're going to switch out this
function here from just a generic get
with a generic statement to actually
being able to pull in the users so
we have to go app
use express.json
dot use
URL encoded
extended
false
NP dot use
API uses so
we're going to be pulling them all from
the same location
require
and where we have our API
Scripts
okay
and then let's go ahead and open up
Postman because we can actually use
Postman to actually show us what the
results look like because right now the
results
won't show up appropriately
um in our browser window
so placement again is just a API
management tool if you used apigee or
other similar tools that are on the
market mulesoft
you'll see it's very consistent again
this is open source and what you want to
be able to do is you can actually go and
actually go to the path where the API is
stored and then you can use all the
different types of commands within your
environment to be able to you know test
out the scripts so let's go ahead and
create a new project new request and
we're going to go with the default get
but there's actually quite a lot of
different commands we can use
and these are just HTTP commands
and we're going to type in the request
and in this instance
it's going to be
let's run our script first
into our script
let's make sure we're exporting the data
correctly
okay so we want to run our script so
let's do a node index.js and that will
run the changes that we just created so
we can now come over to get we select
API um localhost colon 3000
slash API uses when we do that brings
back the Json package with that for
entry points
never there's all four of them
so that's your
first action
now let's kind of get this a little bit
tinier let's actually go in and see if
we can filter by ID
so we're going to go in and we're going
to modify our script so it's going to be
a round and then we're going to put in
the filter and in this instance it's
going to be ID
which would allow us to be able to just
put a backslash against the end of the
URL string we just had and put in a
number or a unique identifier and then
that will actually then allow us to pull
in that unique record
foreign
Community
pass the data
okay so it found
I'm going to
take adjacent and
printed
so we're going to filter here against
user ID
and then publish the results
else if it doesn't work and we'll just
have a generic error message
we should see this though in the demos
we're creating this is just good
practice
to save that
and let's go ahead and rerun our node
index file against that folder
and now we can actually come in here and
we do backslash one and that will give
us just one record and we could change
that to 2 or 100 in this instance and if
it's 100
we'll just get a bad request error
message
there's two
all right
so that's get so we'll be able to pull
all the records we've been able to
filter against one specific record
against a specific parameter in this
instance it was ID so let's go ahead and
create a new user so that what we can do
for this is we're going to use the post
command from HTTP to actually push and
post data into the data source the data
source is our Json packet which means
that we'll have to then push a new
record into the Json package using our
array statements
because Jason's just essentially in an
array
and so we're going to post and when we
do this we have to create a unique ID so
this is where we have to reference the
euid
I'm going to do a V4 unique ID
which will be
four groups of four so these 16
characters
and then
we'll have
name
and email will post
okay looks good
Okay so
if
new user
and then put dot name
and
new user dot email
and I want to return
the results
okay
okay and so he uses Dot
push so we posted which is a HTTP
statement and then pushing into the
the Json packet array
okay
okay that's looking good
all right so I think we're good
let's go ahead and rerun our script
node index.js
now allows us to do that so let's go
over to postman so we can actually
connect to the URL and we're going to
change an HTTP statement to post
and get rid of that we'll go back to
users now if we just do this nothing's
gonna happen so we actually have to go
in and we have to update the body and
this would be the content that would be
passed through and we're going to go
through with a raw
statement here and we do Json is B
that's the packet we're sending so let's
go ahead and the records we wanted to
update we only have to update two which
is one is name and the second is email
we don't have to do an ID because we're
using uuid to generate an automatic one
for us
and we're going to create records for
Steph and and her email address is Steph
gmail.com
yep looking good
okay so let's go ahead and send that
we sent it
and if we look at the bottom we can
actually now see that we have five
records so a new one's been added we
have our unique ID at the top and then
we have name and email which are the
ones that we just created for Steph and
staff at gmail.com
all right
so that's posting now the next thing we
want to do is to update a record so that
means we need to select an ID and then
be able to update the content and for
that we're going to use the HTTP put
command
so we'll use ID as a way to be able to
filter
and then we'll be able to update against
that filter
so construct found
equals users
and then
we'll have it going into
user's ID so we know how to get the
correct record and then pass the record
back
onto the screen so we know what we're
editing
so if
so I found
I want to update the user
and I'm going to go ahead and pull
information from the body for what will
be updated
and for each
diffuser ID
and pass the integer
okay
so this is our values to Ponce against
the ID
and in this instance we'll make sure
that we're obtaining the values of
username
so if we are updating user
and we're just taking the username we
want to
make sure that that's the value that
gets updated
and then we also want to do user email
we don't want to update the ID because
it's going to remain unique and
consistent
okay then we're gonna make sure that
everything is pushed to the Json package
and then we'll also have a message
saying that
the field has been updated in the Json
package
okay
all right so run that script again
and looks good so let's go to our folder
let's change the HTTP post let's put it
as get just so we can see that we have
uh all of their values in the array from
the Json packet
and now we want to say put which allows
us to update just one record
so let's go ahead and select one record
we'll save it1 so we have one record we
can go ahead and for name we can change
this
so let's go ahead and change these
so now you see that the email has
changed so we have staff as the new
account
all right our final API that we're going
to create is to delete an account and in
many ways it's actually a very basic API
because what we're doing is we're
grabbing the ID and then we're saying
that all the associated records with
that ID
within that row as it were in the table
just to delete the whole row
and so we want to use again our ID as
the unique value that we
pulling against
so we're going to if he uses a found and
we're going to
filter those users
I'm going to do that filter against user
ID
pass that
and
and they go and
post a message to our Json packet saying
user deleted
in our generic message of things fail
okay save that and we'll
so we go ahead and we're using we're
just deleting the record now
I'm going to do it by filtering against
the unique ID
and then you will then just eliminate
that record
I will pass the message that has been
the your account has been deleted
okay let's save that let's go run our
script
node index.js
we good okay let's come over here and
we're going to
show that we can put any of the accounts
so let's just take one of them
one I think that's good
so let's go ahead and we're going to
change
the HTTP command to delete
and we actually have to
select an account so we just do one when
we do that it'll actually delete that
record and here we are um it says that
the user has been deleted and we now
only have three records in the Json
packet
and we can pull all the records
and you'll see that there's only three
so being able to pull all the records
from a Json package we've been able to
create a record update a record and
delete a record
and we can just step through so here's
our Json package that we created
originally again this is just an array
it's just a different way of setting up
the array and then we have our index
files which um identifies what are the
apps that need to be installed and where
the API is going to be serviced out of
and that we're going to be doing this on
uh the port 3000
um again these are additional tools that
we need to make sure that we have up and
running um in our script and so the
first script was to get all the um the
records taken to filter against a user
ID for just a specific record and then
for creating a record we actually went
in and we used the uid tool to create a
unique identifier and then we posted in
the data for the new records we did
something similar with updating the
record we didn't have to update the user
ID we just had to update the values in
the two fields that we needed to be
updated
in this case name and email
and the final step was to go ahead and
delete a record so these are all apis
that you can now pull into your own
application so you can use them in web
applications or you can actually go
ahead and use them in other applications
such as mobile applications
local applications and other scripts and
this really allows your application to
become more scalable and more useful
hello and we're going to go through and
do our demo of building a restful API
with node.js so the first thing we want
to do is go ahead and install all the
correct pieces of software we're going
to start with node.js so let's do a
Google search on node.js and you'll find
that node.js is at
nodejs.org so we select that link
and that's going to take us to the
node.js website and there are two
versions of node.js you can download
There's the stable version and then
there's the latest version I'd go with
the stable version you'll find it
available in Windows Mac OS and Linux as
well
and if we go to the next piece of
software we want to go ahead and install
the text editor of your choice I'm going
to use Visual Studio code vs code it's
an open source solution it works on all
leading platforms uh works really well I
like the large Microsoft did a good job
of this I also really like it that it's
open source but there's lots of
extensions you can get for vs code so
it's a great text editor and we'll also
need Postman Postman is a tool that
allows us to be able to view the apis
that we're going to create so let's go
ahead to postman.com and again it's
another solution you can download for
free and so we're going to go ahead and
select the download button and it will
automatically detect which OS you're on
so in this case it's going to be windows
but you can also get Mac and Linux as
well so we'll go ahead and download
those
and once we have everything installed
what we're going to do is we're going to
create a project in vs code and that's
actually really easy to do all you have
to do is create a folder
and we'll do this right off our desktop
and we're going to call the folder node
rest API and we'll select that folder
and you'll see on the left hand column
that we have the new folder that we
created we still have the vs code
welcome screen we'll get rid of that we
don't need that anymore so let's go
ahead and one of the things I like with
vs code is you can actually toggle the
terminal window so let's go ahead and
open up the terminal window so we can
actually run that at the same time and
so we're going to move our cursor to the
folder we just created and there we are
you can see that
and what we can do now is we're going to
initialize this with no package manager
to make this a package
and it's going to go ahead I'm going to
ask for a name we're just going to go
with the default so we're just going to
say yes yes to a couple of these yep
enter enter enter
enter enter
and is this okay
yep enter
all right so now we have a new file and
this is our Json package it has all the
defaults in it we can go in and modify
these if we want to uh no need to for
this exercise but you may want to for
the solution that you're putting
together
and we're going to create a new file
called index.js and this is going to be
the reference file that's in the Json
package for npm
and here we're going to put in our
solutions that we absolutely have to
have for this to run so we're going to
install Express and express is a web
service application but it's very
flexible and one of the things that
we're going to use it for today is build
apis
so in our terminal window we're going to
type npm install dash dash save Express
this will install Express locally on our
machine
and takes a few minutes but it's going
to go and download all the latest
features this is going to be the latest
version of Express you can if you want
to
specify a specific version of software
for these examples there's no need to do
that
so you'll see that everything has been
installed we expanded the node module we
can scroll down and indeed yep there we
are we see Express has been installed
along with some other
um pieces that are useful
all right so that's our first piece and
the next
is we're going to Define our amp and our
app is going to use Express
and we want Express as a local host on
our local machine on Port 3000 so we've
identified Port 3000 as the default port
for our application
and
we are going to now create a an array
for some movies
I'm going to have ID title director and
release date
such a great movie
and director Christopher Nolan
and I was released
in 2010 yes 10 years ago
okay so we're gonna do an a couple of
items here and just so that we have some
more than one entry in our array and
array is a JavaScript uh you can think
of it as a very simple uh table now it
allows us to have structured data you
can also do a Json file you can also
connect to a database mongodb or
something like that
2019
okay so we have two movies in our little
array
would be more than enough for right now
the key part is that we have a
consistent structure for the array of
Ida title director and release date
and so we're going to create uh two apis
one's going to be a get API where we'll
get the list of the items in our API and
the second will be a post where we'll be
actually pushing in a new item so let's
go ahead and start with the get and what
we want to do is we want to select get
slash movie and
we are going to
have this run as an API and so what
we'll do is we will test this in a
moment so we'll be running from our web
browser and actually we'll probably open
up Postman and run it through Postman so
okay
that pulls all the movies
and we'll do a another
um getting we'll filter by movie ID but
let's just get them all for right now
and we are going to listen
on a server port in this instance it's
going to be four three thousand
and we already had to find the port as a
variable earlier and which so we're just
referencing the variable and the port
number is listed at the top in line four
it's just a text string that's going to
get put to the terminal window
and it is going to dynamically
grab the port the value from the
variable from 3000
and place it in our text string easy
and we want to save the file
and now we're going to go ahead and run
it so we're going to do node index touch
Js
that runs the script
and it tells us that we're listing on
Port 3000 that's great
that means now that we should be able to
go into Postman
and
grab the data from an API
so here's Postman if you've not used it
before it's a great tool for being able
to manage apis strongly encourage you to
have a go with this so we're going to
get the get command
done in the applications web
applications you you probably use get
and post for the data and that you're
pulling and pushing from forms online
same principle so we want to go ahead
and we're going to go and look at get
I'm going to type in localhost
and it's going to be colon
3000 slash movies because that's the the
name of the file and we're going to hit
send and
what we get as a response
is the
data in our query
sorry in our array here we go so there's
our array and the data values have been
pulled back by Postman
that's great
so now we want to go ahead and add a
movie to our array
and we're going to do that we're going
to use the post
command and I get imposed our HTTP
commands
and so we're going to use movies
and in this instance we're going to push
the value
into
our list
so construction movie requires we need a
structure here and that structure is
going to be
the information that's in the the body
and then we're going to push to the log
our terminal window
and I'm going to push so here we're
using push and that's a term in for
arrays within JavaScript where we push
the data into the actual array itself
there are lots of ways of being able to
control data within an array and if
you're new to arrays with JavaScript I
strongly encourage you to learn more
about them there's just an awful lot you
can do with them
and then we want to have a validation
message come up on the screen saying yes
movie has been added to the list so
we'll save what we've just created
and if you don't save it it won't show
up and then we're going to re-run
the node index.js file
you can see this is what we've created
here already
a an API that allows us to pull and push
data
in and out of a variable
okay so let's go back and we're going to
change the header from being guest to
being push
so we're going to use sorry not push our
post so we're going to select post and
then what we want to do is the value
inside of the body and so that's GoPro
and we want to select a body
and I'm going to play in text
and select Json so it's going to be
structured and so here we will
essentially copy the structure we have
here so let's go ahead and just
copy these elements
and we have to give it an ID because we
don't have an auto generator ID so we're
going to make this ID
three
and then
it's going to be a number three
and then you want to put in
title
new movie and we'll put in director
and we'll have this as
I don't know new director
I'm very creative here today
and then
we need to put in a date
so release underscore dates
and let's just put
a date
uh
um just so you know that we're not
formatting the date con as
so let's go ahead and we'll select send
and this will actually go and we can see
Hello boom movie's been added to our
list
and we can go back and let's go ahead
and validate that so we're going to
change from post to get
use the same
and now we go to below
oh looks like we put an arrow in
our formatting
so let's go
to
pass the Json
and we'll pause it using Express
and this will
clear up any formatting issues
so
app.use Express Json
Express
URL encoded
extended false
and that should help us pass our
value
and then we'll rerun that script make
sure you save the previous file
otherwise it won't run the new script
all right click okay so let's go back
and
let's go back to our
localhost 3000 slash movies
and there's only two values here so what
we need to do now is change when we get
to post
we'll go to body
and what we're going to do is we want to
have
raw Json and
what we want to do is capture the values
that we have below
and insert
this
file into this new
Json packet into our array
let me actually just copy that
it's a little bit cheating but it's the
main same so let's go ahead and
get everything consistent
and I'm going to change the number to
three
and creating a unique title patching
sorry new typo doesn't need to be unique
just the ID needs to be unique
so title new movie new director and
change it to New director
I'm going to change the date
I'm not doing any formatting on the date
so it can be any any date any number
really
hit save
maybe it's been added to our list so
it's been added but now let's go back to
get and let's see if we can actually see
the third entry and scroll down and
there we are we've actually pushed that
Json package into our array
so we now have three items in and
they're hoping added via our API
okay
so
now let's go ahead and search our Movie
Database I guess we only have three
entries but you know we want to be able
to so we can do that by using the get
command and what we'll be doing is we'll
be validating against
a specific ID number so we have three
and we're going to
validate against just the ID number in
this instance
um the way to do it is through the URL
so beforehand we have localhost colon
3000 slash movie now we're adding in a
slash movie slash and then whatever
number of that will actually filter
against the ID and
that's essentially what we're doing here
right now
so we're going to go into f movies
dot ID again we're using the ID menu to
actually pull from our arraylist
with my variables and arrays mixed up
here today
and then once we actually have the value
we'll actually post back as a Json
packet
and here we have any errors then what
we'll do is we'll throw up message maybe
not found so there we are we're going to
plug in some ID
and we should be able to then pull that
up through Postman into our terminal
window
again the reason why we're using Postman
is that this is actually just showing
the values going back and forth we're
not having to render a whole web page uh
it's extremely fast very efficient
all right
so we saved and rerun our script all
right let's go back and what we're going
to do is we're going to change the value
so we're going to hit send here we are
we see all of our movies using the get
command now what we're going to do is
we're going to use a look filtering just
id2 which is the Irishman so to Slash 2
and there we are we have just the
information on the Irishman
so now you can see how you can create a
simple search
all right
so the final action we want to do is to
delete a record
in our array and so we can go ahead and
do that
and we're going to use the uh Delete
commands to actually do that so we'll be
able to push
um in a record we've been able to view
records filtered audience records now
we're going to go ahead and do delete
and so you can do app delete and then
we're going to filter by specific ID
number
and when we do this we'll actually then
we'll be put in the URL path which will
be localhost coding 3000 slash movie
slash and then the ID number so this is
inside that 102 probably use two that
will then uh delete from our array
the record for the Irishman
that's it
I do a shortcut and the keyboard
shortcut of Control Plus s to save files
on Windows or command processing my Mac
and
once we've deleted a record we want to
send a message saying that b maybe has
been deleted
all right so we want to go ahead
and let's just check our code looking
good save our file
and we want to rerun
the index.js file
yep
rerun okay let's go to placement
and grab
the delete
so again we're filtering against the
movie ID and then we'll delete that ID
okay so we went against the Ashman and
we hit send
and there it is now we're going to
change
the command to delete
so we hit
one we'll actually delete conception the
movie has been deleted this parade and
now let's go ahead and grab uh use get
to pull in all the movies that are
listed and it's not going to find movie
number with the id1 that's not there
anymore
and if we get all the movies
we see we only have one movie and that's
the Irishman and so our delete function
has worked
there we are so we've installed Express
we're using Express to build all of our
applications we have our app running on
Port 3000 we are using Express to pass
the Json effectively back and forth we
have a simple array that array is then
being used to create an API to pull the
details then we're being able to add a
movie then search for a movie itself
reading against an ID
and then we can actually finally go
ahead and delete a movie
all this using express.js
today we're going to be covering node.js
authentication using JWT or Json web
tokens so let's get started so why are
we going to go down this path so let's
cover the key things that you need to be
asking yourself such as what is a Json
web token what is the value of using a
Json web token and then what is the
actual structure of the GWT look like
and then let's go through some use cases
of where you'd actually use jwts both in
Enterprise and in the real world
and then finally we're actually going to
go through a demo on how you can
actually install a JWT and using Express
and node.js
so let's dive into what actually is a
Json web token
so a Json web token is actually based on
an open standard and it's one that you
can actually go ahead and research and
it allows a definition of a compact
self-contained way of being able to
securely transmit information between
parties using adjacent object an
adjacent object is a JavaScript array
and it's very compact it's a very a
tight way of being able to send data
back and forth
the thing that's great about using a
Json web token is that the information
itself is encrypted and it can only be
verified and trusted through a public
private key pair and we'll get into that
about how you can actually get to those
so you know why would you actually want
to go ahead and use a Json web token are
there other formats that you can use
well yes there are other formats you can
use but what's great about a JWT is that
it is a great way to be able to pass
data from a HTTP servers so if you're
building a web application and you have
a web vacation where you need to pass
authentication over using a jw2 is a
great way to be able to do that so for
instance you may have a number of
Enterprise applications that run across
your Cloud environments you may have
some Enterprise applications that run in
your data center and you want to have
people come in such as your employees or
your customers authenticate once and
then be able to have their ID transition
from one to the next and JWT is a great
way to do that the content is extremely
secure and we'll get more into that in a
moment but it is the highest level of
security you can have right now
and the final great thing about working
with JWT is that the actual tokens
themselves are very well documented and
so there's actually a lot of passes that
you can use so being able to add in JWT
into your application is very very easy
to do which makes it very easy for you
to actually Implement and a large scale
authentication and authorization and so
authorization is a key word there that's
something that you're probably coming
across a lot instead of just being able
to identify who you are we want to be
able to authorize what you have access
to
so let's have a look at the structure of
a JWT there are several key elements and
the first is the header and that's
actually going to break down what I kind
of token It Is by default is going to be
a GWT token and what is the signing
algorithm so sha512 is a very complex
and secure algorithm and certainly the
one that I would recommend that you use
you can even go higher than that but
shar512 is a great place to start
and then you have the payload and the
payload is the information that's been
actually encrypted within the web token
so in this instance we have a name the
admin time type sub name
um just really you can put whatever kind
of information you want in there as long
as it's applicable
um to the uh service that you're passing
the data into
and then you have your signature which
is
um encoded header um and payload with
the algorithm that you've sent so in
this instance it's sha512 algorithm
so let's look at some of the use cases
that you'd have for JWT
so a couple of use cases would be
authorization so say for instance you
have a application and you want to be
able to authorize somebody to have
access to different parts of that
application and a JWT is a great way to
be able to encrypt that data and be able
to pass that data back and forth uh
examples would be jumping from different
parts Office 365 and being able to have
access to different features within the
system
and then another area would be if you're
doing information exchange so
information is being securely exchanged
from one person to another so a
blockchain scenario a multi-distributed
environment where you want to be able to
have a way to be able to securely
transmit data back and forth and know
that that data is being encrypted is
another good example
so with that let's take a pivot and
we'll go ahead and we'll look at
creating a demo using our standard stack
of node.js and we'll use express and
Postman and these are tools that you may
already be familiar with if you've seen
other videos that we've created in this
series and we'll go ahead and create a
JWT token
so let's go into our demo of how to
create a JWT Json web token there's
going to be some tools that we need to
get started with node.js is the first so
let's go ahead and find node.js at
nodejs.org and you can either download
Windows Mac or Linux code obviously
you'd install the one that would be for
your operating system the next tool that
we want to install is a those installed
and up and running
so we're going to go ahead and let's
open up visual studio code
and we're going to start by creating our
project
Let's Go full screen on this get rid of
the welcome screen
and that's going to open up a folder
where we'll actually have our project
I'm going to put this on our desktop for
right now let's go create a new folder
and we'll call this node JWT
[Music]
uh Json web token select that folder
and we're going to want to go ahead and
use npm to initialize this folder for
for node and so let's get rid of the
welcome screen again and let's go ahead
and one of the things I love about vs
code is you can actually run the
terminal window right from in here so
let's go ahead and select npm in it
already knows to pull from the folder
that we're in and we're just going to
select yes here in a second for
um
yep let's go ahead and create that and
you'll see that the package has been
created and there is a Json packet with
just default information about the npm
package that we created for node and
we're going to go ahead and create an
index.js file that's what we've been
pulling from the package and the
index.js files we're going to actually
write all of our code and what we want
to do right now is install Express
and express is going to be used to
create the apis that will be able to
test our JWT against and then we'll also
want to install
a JWT
um file so let's call this Json web
token
and from our terminal window we'll just
go ahead and install both of those and
do that by typing npm install Dash save
and then we're going to put Express
and Json web token
Express and Json web token
and we'll just go ahead and let those
install
it only takes a moment for those to get
installed
all right we're up and running okay
so let's go ahead and start bringing in
some of our apps so we're going to
create an Express amp
and we're going to use the
get HTTP header to have everything go
from the we're going to actually have
everything running on our local host and
we're going to run everything off Port
3000 we'll do that in a moment here but
we'll have everything running off a sub
folder called apis where our web
applications can be running from
and we'll put in a message that hey
there to show that everything's up and
running
okay
and
save that
and say if you can do Control Plus s to
save your files and as you can with a
lot of Windows applications and I
encourage you to do that a lot so let's
go ahead and open up Postman we know
when we go to our web browser on this
one and open up Postman
takes a moment to run the first time
and it comes
and Postman again is a tool for being
able to manage API calls
um so you don't have to write a script
so here we are
and we can go in here and we can
that's where we're going to write our
script but we have to
do a couple things first let's let's get
everything running so we want to listen
on for Port 3000 that's we're going to
run everything off of
and in the console log we'll actually
throw in a message to confirm that we
are running on uh everything is up and
running we'll just say okay uh server
started on Port 3000 again we're going
to be running everything off localhost
so you'll be able to see this
um and this is as you imagine just a
test environment so let's go down into
our console we'll run this script node
index.js to run the script it runs
really fast not a whole lot going on
there and we're having everything
running off the API file so let's go and
we'll type in under our get localhost
colon 3000
API
and we hit the there's lots of different
HTTP headers um we can use we're going
to use get for right now send that
and
hey there welcome to the API service
so typically this is just an API we're
creating right now this is not JWT we'll
get into that right now
all right
so we wouldn't be able to post data
and post is actually pushing data in so
we're going to go into going to create a
login screen it's okay again again this
is all API so it's not real but uh okay
you get the point
and then you can construct a user
and let's go ahead and what we're doing
here is we're creating a
an array of a random user and that they
can have a name of id1 that we have the
users can have ID value which is one
um a username value which is going to be
John and then email value of John
gmail.com
and then we'll make this a
Json web token JWT signing and they'll
have to sign with their user
and this is going to use a secret key
which will be our hash
512 token
and
respond to the Json with the token
okay so let's see now okay we're going
to
Hamp Dot and this will be our post
API
posts
thank you
and what we're going to be able to do is
we're going to jump from one app to
another app and you'll be able to see
how we can move the token over there
and the message will read
post
created
all right
so let's just run that script index.js
runs real quick okay
so if we come over here and we go to
posts
and hit send
and say message posts created
good
so let's go ahead and try that again
and we want to go to the
login
so again from one app to another app
select post
and here the login
we should be able to request the token
this will be our GWT token
and we hit send we should get our token
and here you can see the the whole token
is encrypted
it's that huge long line
it's very unique
and
now we want to be able to go in and say
okay let's verify
the token so we've gone ahead and we
created the token but now we need to as
we go from app to app we need to
actually verify the token so we're going
to get an error message if we don't
verify the token correctly
so I'm going to put in a function to
verify the token
and
we're going to create a bearer header
value
which will be
the headers and the authorization for
that
and if type of error header
I'm gonna either have it if it's not
correct it'll be undefined
otherwise the spirit token
it will be split
and we're going to require the token
for a bearer token
else
send status
403 okay so Bearer token is what we're
going to be calling against to verify
our token I'll show you how that works
in just a moment
and this will be to authorize
and to authorize we'll need to actually
go ahead and
use the token so we can actually
put in here
all right so I think
everything's looking pretty good
oh and
if things if we get the error message
means that it's we'll see the message
forbidden if we don't put in the code
correctly so it's
double check everything's looking good
we'll be verifying that the token is
required
okay
so if it is then JWT dot foreign
and this will
connect our token appropriately
and you will be able to
put that in as a part of our secret key
and if it is successful
let me put it in
and that message there
and we're also going to play in the
authorization data
yep looking good
as you can see a lot of the work is just
making sure that everything is aligned
up correctly
okay so let's run our code node index.js
there we go nice and fast
and
we go in and localhost
API posts
I'm going to change this to post
so this one API which is the API posts
which is up here
I'm going to hit send
now you can see that we have the error
code forbidden has come up which is what
we're expecting because we haven't been
able to put in a secret key
and put in the comment there
forbidden
so it's as we're stepping through the
code
but now what we can actually do is we
can go back and we can grab the token
and here is our token below and we just
want the token cell we don't need the
wrappers
and copy that
come over here
and if we write again it's going to say
forbidden but if we go into author into
our headers
we can put in authorization
and then the value
we do Bearer and then the key
and once we do this
we now get all of the data that we were
asking for pulled back
which is exactly what we wanted
so you can see here how we can actually
securely use a JWT to pass values back
and forth across the application
okay
and we hit authorization we select that
and prove it yep we keep authorizing so
if you don't authorize and you don't get
the data
okay so we have everything against the
API and then we have one application
which we call Api post we have another
application called API login and we're
able to move the data back and forth
using our secret key in our JWT token
and we have everything running on Port
3000 of our Local Host server
and that's our demo
so first of all let's cover why you'd
want to go through this tutorial so
we're going to cover what my sequel is
we're also going to tell you how we're
going to connect with node.js and why
you'd want to do that with my SQL and
then finally we're going to do a demo
taking you through all the steps on how
you can actually do that kind of
connection
so what is my SQL well basically MySQL
is probably the world's most popular
relational database so if you think of
relational databases that are table
driven MySQL is arguably the most
popular database out there for rdbs
systems it is by far the most popular
open source relational database
the entire database is written in C and
C plus plus it's been around for a
really long time and again it's open
source which is great which means that
there are no licenses or costs for
actually using MySQL and you'll find
that companies of all sizes from small
mom and pop shops all the way up to
massive Enterprise Global Enterprises
are all using MySQL so you know why
would you want to then take that next
step of connecting node.js with my SQL
what fundamentally comes down to the
basics of the differences between the
two products MySQL is a database and
node.js is a architecture framework for
building out web applications again with
mySQL it's open source it's free to use
you don't have to pay anything there are
no licenses which if you compare it with
other Solutions out there is a big deal
my sequel even though it is open source
it's incredibly powerful it's one of the
more mature open source programs out
there I think Apache is probably
arguably more perpetually a web server
is probably more mature but uh my sequel
is very close behind it so it has had a
huge amount of investment this is not a
solution that's only a couple years old
we're talking about a solution that's
more than 15 years old very very
structured very powerful and you can do
a lot of really good things with it
um you can actually then build Solutions
with it and using PHP Java really any
kind of database even other systems and
other Frameworks will allow you to
interact with mySQL and it just allows
you to work with just huge amounts of
data very very quickly
so let's go through a demo of how you'd
actually use node.js and MySQL
so I'm going to go ahead and we're going
to get started by putting our road
environment together so let's start by
selecting node.js and downloading it so
we'll get to knowjs.org
and there you have your options for
Windows Mac or if you want to go for the
source code you can go ahead and
download and install that
the next is to install Zam and so we're
going to go to zap installs for a quick
search and that's on our Apache
friends.org site and here we have
example Windows Linux and Mac OS 10.
and then finally we want to go ahead
and install visual studio so visual
studio is going to be our idea
integrated development environment in
this instance we're going to use Visual
Studio code if you're not used to just
do code it's a great free open source
solution for being able to build
applications I'm a big fan of it so I
encourage you to use it
and go ahead and download install that
and we have visual studio
um code up and running so go ahead and
we're going to open up a new folder and
let's go ahead and create a new folder
and just put it straightf5 desktop here
and it's just for uh kicks and Giggles
so we're just going to type in node
MySQL or our source code and open up
that folder and select that
and so we now have this folder selected
in uh Visual Studio code editor and what
we want to do is we want to get rid of
the welcome page and we don't really
need that anymore
and we're going to terminal window so we
can actually see the script that we're
writing we're going to be using terminal
quite a bit
um in this so for instance we're just
going to test that we have npm installed
we did so that's great
and we're going to go npm in it and
that's actually going to set up our own
node package module and we can actually
see that the Json file for the package
has been created so we go in there we
can see that all the defaults selected
now you'll see that index.js is the
default file that will be created so
we're actually going to go ahead and
we're actually going to create our own
index.js file and we're going to add in
some instructions into that file to
actually install the correct software
from the npn package
and the first thing we want to do is
install Express
which is a package that's great for
building a lightweight web applications
not mobile applications I suppose if
you're doing a responsive design
mobile but in this it's really it's a
web application environment so we're
going to put in the requirements for
that and then we're going to also go and
require that MySQL gets installed and
you'll see that for both of them we're
just going to use npms default commands
for creating it and we'll go down to the
channel window and we'll do npm install
and it's going to install the express
and my SQL environment
an asset installs you actually see on
the left hand side under the folder you
actually see
the files starting to be installed so
for instance we have the node modules
and underneath that will get all the
subsequent files that we need
and there we are everything is installed
all right so let's go ahead and validate
some of these commands make sure
everything is installed so we're going
to open up xampp which allows us to go
in and
View and see everything installed so we
have my sequencer we have a patch
installed we can start and stop and the
services
with zamp go ahead and do that you can
do this through terminal window as well
but
the UI interface is really nice so let's
go into
my SQL interface and you'll see that we
don't have any databases
these are all just the the standard test
databases and so we have to go ahead and
create one
and so that's
get our
SQL database connection created
so we're going to write
const DB equals MySQL
create connection
and we want to create and connect to the
localhost in this instance
and users just going to be a root user
account
which is the standard user account that
comes from MySQL there is no password
for the root user when you're running it
locally but I encourage you to change
that as quickly as you can because you
don't really want to have a
password-free environment
and now we want to be able to then
connect to the MySQL
environment
so do royalright DB dot connect
parentheses error and we want to throw
an error message if the connection isn't
good so if we do error
foreign
message to the log window
and if we don't
write my super connected
all right
and then we want to connect that to our
Express app
the next step we want to do after we
meet our connection is to go ahead and
create a database so we're going to do
both steps are the same one so we're
running the script right now and then
we'll run the commands uh in the
terminal window so we can actually
create a database
and so we're going to go ahead and we
want to create
a database
and that's right let's SQL equals
create
database
I'm going to call the database node
MySQL you could call it whatever you
want
um but this is just a no I know my SQL
script
the DP
query
SQL
error
through error message
rest of sand
database created
so we'll throw a message saying that
database has been created let's go save
that
to demonstrate that we've connected and
we create database so let's go ahead
and we'll do node index.js
let's run that and we connect it to my
SQL that's great
good first step and then we'll go to the
window
I will go to localhost
3000 which is
the default
connection but what you'll see is that
we've actually created the name of the
databases and changed to node by SQL so
we've got an error message which we
expected and so what we're going to do
is we're actually going to go ahead and
we're going to say we want to listen
and if the main error message if comes
up to three thousand
then
in the console window we want to
put a message of server started on
quarters 3000.
so let's try that again
go to index.js
yep and server has started with 40 000.
Let me refresh that
I'm still getting an error message
and what we want to see is
let's go ahead and see how database
hasn't been created
so let's go and connect to
database
database let's go ahead and click
create DB on Port 3000 all right so by
doing that we write my command and that
function and that goes and creates our
database and we'll let you see that we
have now node MySQL has been created
great first start
now we have to go in and create some
tables because we have no tables in
there
all right so let's go down let's go
ahead and create a table
so what you're seeing right now is that
we're using
the index.js environment within a
package on node.js to actually create
and control everything that we want to
see in our windows so all of the work
that we're doing for creating a table
for creating the database
for initializing the core files it's all
being done through Js and so here we are
going to create a new table we call it
create import it's going to be called
the employee table and so once we run
the command create complete it's going
to create a table has the employee
fields which is going to have an ID
which will be an integer there or into a
auto increment it'll have a name field
and we'll also put in a designation
field
and
I will have a primary key as well
keep it very simple for right now
and let's just
put our DB connection so that everything
connects effectively
okay so everything goes correctly then
we'll have the message employee table
created
so let's test this out
and note total index.js
make sure that the data we have now
actually a database field that we can
connect to so we've got node my SQL so
we're connecting to the correct database
obviously we get an error
and then we'll try that again
thanks to database
database has the name
and let's put load my SQL there's no
fields in there yet so let's go ahead
and
put in create employees and Fields and
let's run the budget that creates a new
table
and then
voila we have a new table and so the
next action we want to do is actually
populate the table with a record
so this starts becoming familiar so
we're having to
put in a single record we will call it
employee one for right now and
we'll write the
the function in our employee one and
then when we run that function
uh it'll actually go ahead and
create the it'll actually insert the
record into my SQL
and then the name will be Jake Smith
and the designation will be
a chief executive officer
certainly encourage you to put your own
self name your own name into this make
yourself your own CEO because why not
and we're going to make this as an
insert record
s it into the employee table
and we're just using some basic SQL
scores you can
and what you'll see actually with Visual
Studio code is that it's actually
providing a lot of prompts to make it
easier to write your code
Microsoft is looking to actually add
some AI
to visual studio code to actually start
Auto completing scripts which will make
it even easier
to write your code
all right so let's go run node index.js
we've seen that I've been connected and
we'll grab the function employee one and
let's go over to our Express site
let's just go and we'll insert the
command completely E1
employee has been added and we were just
fine to take this by going back to my
SQL and we'll refresh it and you'll see
if we click on the employee table which
we should now have an employee in there
yep there we did Jake Smith
put on Jake first record
right so you want to be able to now is
select the employee
so let's go ahead and do that
and we want to be able to easily get the
employee list
and so let's use our SQL command and we
want to do select start which is
everything from the employee table so
we're actually playing everything from
the employee table
I'm going to query the database
let's throw a message to confirm that
the query is successful
we'll put everything in the console log
results
all right let's give this a well
okay so let's go and run our Command
or localhost 3000
you know but get employee
and it says employee details fetch now
we go over to the console we do in the
visual studio yeah there we go we have
now all the packet information including
the ID about Jake Smith
okay so let's go ahead and see if we can
actually update the employee information
so as you can see now we're starting to
run into just our standard SQL commands
and so we want to be able to update the
employee from a browser
and as you can tell we're not using any
forms or any other types of Records but
just simply interacting
um with between the the uh the browser
the server and the database
and the new name will be updated name
the information yeah from your record
and we'll show that we're matching
against 18 one
all right so that's wrong
and
I think Jake Smith is there
now go and select
Ed
come on SO slash one we've now gone
ahead and updated
the object and Jake Smith's information
just click on complete table
and we now see he says date again I know
not very clearly but it allows you to
see a change
and finally we go ahead and delete the
record as well
so it's going to be similar to update
but I'm deleting instead
I'm going to delete
the record on the employee table
where the theme equals the ID equals
sorry
and
[Music]
then we want to be able to
show that the record has been deleted
[Music]
I'll just say delete employee
oops I deleted and we go to uh
database we can actually see
in the employee table
but there are no entries
they want to record that was their hands
being deleted
and so this shows you how you can very
easily control everything
from
using your connection into MySQL right
from node package manager
you can create table
you can select your records
you can then update any record that you
selected
and finally you can delete any record
books
you want to be able to delete
so what we're going to do is so what's
in it for you so in this presentation
we're going to go through three key
things you know what is mongodb how do
you connect to mongodb with node.js and
mongodb is part of the merge stack so
we're going to cover what the merge
stack is and how it applies to node.js
so what is mongodb so mongodb is a it's
a probably the most popular nosql
database out there it's cross-platform
and very easy to scale it's available on
all Cloud systems you can also run it
locally which is what we'll be doing
later on in our demo but it's just a
very flexible database environment for
modern applications
it works on the concept of collection
and documents
um what you'll find is uh mongodb was
originally written in C plus plus and it
is what's referred to as a nosql
database so this is different to a
relational database which is built up of
tables with rows and columns this is a
nosql database as simply a lot faster
and more powerful for the work that
you're doing
and you're able to use mongodb very easy
you can actually go ahead and download
it we'll actually do that as part of our
demo so you know why connect node.js
with mongodb
well the reason why you want to do this
is that mongodb is a modern database
it's not restricted by the the the
challenges of scalability that ordered
relational databases have
um it's really designed for building
mobile applications of websites that
scale into the millions and millions of
users
so mongodb probably the most important
feature is scalability the performance
of the database is phenomenal
and it is extremely highly available for
the solutions that you'll be creating so
when you push it out your solution to
the cloud you can almost guarantee it's
always going to be running
you also have the ability to be able to
scale to very large complex
multi-site Solutions we've had one of
the very first mongodb applications I
built was a multi-tenant environment and
it just worked really well
and you'll be able to easily deploy your
surgeons across Microsoft Azure AWS
Google Cloud
Etc so yeah why do you want to keep
connecting to mongodb um I think
probably
um one of the other areas that probably
is often forgotten with manga it's just
the concept around big data and you can
I mean when you talk about big data and
you're talking about absolutely massive
massive databases and mongodb is front
and center for all of that
you can do your effective content
management and delivery
um it has an effective mobile and social
infrastructure so
um by that it allows you to be able to
build out solutions that can go to all
modern day types of applications and the
data is actually very easy to manage
through your central data hub
and then finally being able to connect
to mongodb is very easy particularly as
there's a client called Mongoose that
makes the connection extremely easy so
you know finally um let's kind of look
into how [ __ ] DB is part of the Moon
Stag
so Moon stack is a JavaScript stack and
it's of JavaScript solutions that are
built for modern single page
applications and there are four key
Solutions in the merge stack there's
mongodb which is your database Express
which is your server side HTTP
environment react which is the solution
for being able to create your Solutions
on the client and the node.js which
actually manages the whole environment
it's really an environment that's
designed to make it very easy to be able
to build out modern day Solutions so
mongodb is the am in Moon Express is the
E react is the r and node js is the n so
again as you start working with some of
our other videos that we have here
you'll be able to see how all of these
tools really complement each other so
we've done an introduction on [ __ ] DB
really the best thing now is to get you
out you know your hands dirty by
actually doing a demo so we're going to
go through a demo what I would strongly
encourage you however though is that
this demo really does build on a lot of
the other videos that we've done in this
series so you really do want to spend
some time on the node.js video the
node.js for Express video the node.js
for apis video really all of those
videos help complement the work that
you'll be doing with this video here
you'll see some real strong correlations
plus a lot of new content as well so
with that we're going to jump into the
demo
so let's give our demonstration on how
to use mongodb with node.js first thing
we want to do is go ahead and install
node.js so you're going to go and do
Google Search node.js and that should
bring up a result of going to nodejs.org
and here you can download node.js for
multiple platforms so Windows Linux Mac
OS they're all supported you can also
get the original source code and
recompile your version of node.js if you
want to
now we're just going to install the
windows version
and the next thing you want to do is
install your favorite uh text editor I'm
going to install Visual Studio code vs
code it runs on all leading platforms
Mac OS windows and Linux it is open
source you can edit it and I like it
because you can do an awful lot with it
just a lot of extensions it's just a
great tool all around
so that's the next thing you want to
install
and then we want to go ahead and we want
to go to
mongodb.com so we can install the
mongodb database
so you want to go to Software
Community server
and you want to then select
the
mongodb community server
uh which platform you want
and where it's going to connect with
and you want to select the download to
install that
and that'll take a moment or two for you
to download and get that up and running
once you've done that we want to go
ahead and we're going to open up vs code
so we can start editing and the code
that we need for our new solution
so let's go ahead and create a folder of
our desktop that we'll use for mongodb
so I already have a folder created
called demo I'm just going to select
that and then inside there I'm going to
put in a node mongodb
and select that folder
and that's going to open up vs code it's
going to have our folder in here so
we're going to get rid of the welcome
screen we don't need that
um we do want to however open up our
terminal window so we're going to run
that that's one of the things that I
really like about vs code is you can
actually have your terminal window or
command line window actually inside the
development environment you're working
at so you don't have to be jumping from
one solution to another and then we're
going to initialize our package so npm
in it for the folder that we're in it's
going to create our uh no package
manager it's going to create our default
package and we're going to hit return
that's going to go ahead and start the
process
and we're just going to go with the
default
um uh settings
that npm is going to give so just hit
return return a few times and that will
get up and running for you
and our entry point for the application
is going to be index.js
oh yeah that's uh
JS package and there we have everything
this is just the uh the the Json package
that provides the instructions that npm
would use to pass the um the program now
you notice that we have index.js as our
leading file so we actually have to add
a new file here and we're just going to
Tool this one index.js so we actually
have a file that can be referenced
and now we're going to go ahead and
we're going to actually put in our
default application so Express is going
to be required so we're going to make
sure that that is included in our first
line of our instructions
and then we're also going to have a path
that's required
and
we're going to require handlebars
completely
and these are all part of our Express
environment
and don't forget to save your file as
you're going along
and we're also going to have
Express pH BS
and this is going to be our Express
handlebars
and we're all going to
hello
insecure
prototype
you would normally do this but because
we're running everything locally it just
makes it easier for you to actually get
all the code in
and then we're also going to add in
uh body parser
and these are all the required solutions
that we need to be installed when you're
running this
package
and so let's save the file and then
let's go ahead and run it so we're going
to do npn install
and we do dash dash save and this will
install Express
and we're also going to have an install
path
uh handlebars
Express handlebars
um
and this is where we'll install the
prototyping
and we'll also have the body parser
installed and we're just going to run
that
this will just take a moment or two to
install
all right there we go
so we have everything installed which
allows us to now start working with our
Scripts
so we're going to create an app in
Express
and we're going to listen on Port 3000
and
we're going to have a message then go to
our console log
and we have everything running of our
local port on localhost on Port 3000 so
let's go and we're going to select node
index.js and shows us everything's
running
which is good you can actually test this
in our web browser if we wanted to
okay so let's start working on our app
so our app is going to
use body parsa
and we're going to encode
our request
and the goal here is we're going to
create a file that's going to go back
and forth
to mongos among uh to mongodb
so body parts is going to use Json to
encrypt
the content
and we're going to do a get command to
get our results
and if we worked if you've seen the API
video then we did that here in fact it's
probably a good idea to actually sit
down and look through some of the other
videos that we've created such as the
Json sorry the node.js node.js for
Express node.js for apis and node.js for
authentication before doing this video
uh we're going to create a default page
and it's going to say welcome to the
students database
the principles that we're putting down
here you'll be able to apply to any
solution that you're creating with
mongodb
and so we want to have a simple action
that we're going to
put on here which is going to be
click to gain access
foreign
[Music]
okay
all right so here is our basic web page
that we're creating
nothing fancy
but it's going to take you to a place
where you can actually get all the
content now what we're going to do is
we're actually going to go and pull the
content from manga
so run this and we're going to put our
web browser you'll see what it looks
like let's just go to localhost
close out these other tabs don't need
them we've got the host three pounds and
and there we see welcome to the student
database click on the database and you
click on if you click on it now nothing
will happen so yeah nothing there
so let's make something happen
okay
all right so
again extending our app so what we're
going to do is we want to
set
the views
and I'm going to do a join
our directory name
and app
engine
so let's go for our views we don't have
engine yet but let's go ahead and create
a new folder
we can call that one views and let's
expand that
should be okay
HPS
Express handlebars
and we're going to allow prototype
access for our Express Enterprise
so with Express handlebars if this is
new to you it allows you to separate
your content from your layout
which if you have developed with swift
for a mobile application on the Mac
using xcode is the same principle there
but for a web application
so we're just putting out here
some of our
default environment settings
and we're going to set our view engine
for handlebars
and
through our code it's looking good
okay so that provides
that so let's create a new folder under
our views and this one we're going to
call layouts so again this is where we
are splitting our layouts
and we're going to have a photo called
models at the root of our application
and under models we're going to put in
db.js so the dbjs file is going to be
where we put our instructions for our
database and so here we're going to go
ahead and we're going to require to
import Mongoose and Mongoose is a tool
in node.js that allows you to connect to
mongodb
so we're going to require the use of
mongoose and so we're going to do npm
install Dash say save mongoose
and that's going to run and install on
our local machine so we can actually
test this out
and once we've got this installed what
we're going to do is we're going to
start connecting to a database that
we're going to call student DB
okay we're already already installed so
let's go Mongoose dot connect
and
we're going to call it mongodb
and
we're going to run this off our Local
Host
so we installed the community version
that I was just trying to follow the
host and it's going to run from the port
27017 I'm going to call this one student
DB
so again with our application we're
splitting out all the functionality so
if you want to reuse elements you can
so we're going to have a new user URL
parser
and we'll make sure we capture
everything correctly
okay so if Arrow then we'll send a
message to the console log
and we have either connection is
successful or things go wrong
error in connection
and then if there is an error then what
we'll do is we'll have the error message
posted
okay
and then we'll do require
[Music]
student
dot model so this will actually call the
model we're going to create
and so what we're going to do now is
creating
under models we're going to create
student of model
.js
and this is where we're going to
our instructions for our student model
so first thing you want to do is we want
to import
Mongoose Express and the student model
so I've gotta let's make sure we have
everything let's capture that
so let's go over to
our student model
all right so let's make sure that we
have everything so we want to have
mongoose
and
we'll create a new variable called
student schema this will allow us to
structure what our model will look like
and this will be a
a new
new schema
in using mongoose
and our new schema is going to be full
name
now we're going to break down
our
Jason's package so we're going to put in
the instructions for what the scheme we
would look like so
we have the type we have no required
this field is required
and
second value is going to be email
type string
this field is required
there's the message error message you
want to send if
the field isn't filled out
mobile phone number so Peterson number
and we're going to have City
and subtype will be
let's just make this a string we're just
going to try and keep this simple for
right now
and the field is required
all right so here's our schema
looking pretty good
right mongoose dot model
and connect this to our
student model
so we want to go ahead and save that
thank you
create a new folder and this new folder
is going to be called controllers
and we have a new file under controllers
and that new file is going to be called
student controller
.js
let's go in and
see what we're going to add here
so we want to import uh make sure we're
running Express
so Express is required for our
controller
we also want to set up a variable for
router
so rather express.rowder
and we want to make sure we're also
connecting with mongoose
so we have our connection to our mongodb
and we also want to make sure that we
have
connection to our student model
so Mungus Mongoose dot model
shoot model
and this allows us to make sure that we
have
this student model
pulled over effectively for our
controller for our student controller
okay so let's go to router
get
I'm gonna render this
and student slash add or edit
we'll come into that in just a moment
so we want to be able to
View Title and this will pull in
the insert
student
I'm going to use under our views
we're going to create a new folder
and this one's going to be called
student
and we're going to create a new file and
this one will be add or edit
.js oh HPS sorry for our handlebar
so you notice we don't have to put the
file extension
node.js manages all that for us
so router touch post
so this will be
our we're going to get our content and
then we're also going to post content so
the post will go back and it's part of
our body and there'll be an ID
so we want to then insert insert the
record that we'll be creating
all right
so again if you've been if you've worked
through the node.js API
video then you'll start seeing if
there's some commonalities here of being
able to insert or update a record
and we actually cover that using just a
sample Json package this really takes it
to that next level
okay
okay so we want to put in a new student
record and so be student
and we're going to have that full name
it's going to come from our body
and we're going to also capture the
email
essentially we're going to follow the
model that we created
and our mobile phone
finally with a student City
[Music]
um
and then we want to save the record that
we create
okay
all right so we're going to manage our
error message
[Music]
similar messages that we've put in
before
so we want to redirect to our student
list
now we're going to go ahead and create
that in a moment
so let's create a new files student
list.hbs
so list.hbs
and here
so what we do is with student list
that's actually going to manage then the
uh controls for being able to display
the records in the database
and then we'll put
um um message if there's an error then
you know we'll put an error message
there and ask you to report the error
message
I'm going to try and not do that
all right so
now the next step we need to go through
is we want to call a function to update
the record
and let's go in ahead and we're going to
update the records and we do the
student.find1 and update client
okay
okay so we will redirect to our student
list as needed if not we'll throw an
error message to our console log
foreign
[Music]
and again this is just an example but
something that you'll be able to do
yourself
whether your own solution
and
then we want to like go back to our list
to then render
the records
all right
and here we want to put student and then
how we're going to find the record
and
we'll throw a error message to our
console log
so as you can see we always throw an
error message to the console log
error messages are really useful
okay all right looks good
save that
okay let's do another router and this is
two
we're gonna do the router against ID
so allow us to get the content
so I'll be able to get information by ID
of the student
what you can see is there's a lot of the
work we're doing here
is very repetitive
um and
you'll find as you create more modular
code that it makes it easier for you to
write your code and update and manage
your code
okay so we're going to
get out View Title we're going to put
into our document
okay
all right so our next router
is
we want to be able to delete our record
by ID
and so we're going to do is we're going
to find our records last stream record
and we just find it by ID
and then we'll just find by find ID and
remove
thank you
okay so we're gonna
to once we've removed your record we're
going to redirect to our list so we can
show our student list
will send an error message to our
console log
okay
so I think we have what we need
maybe just maybe there's one more thing
I think we need to do
I think this is good
okay so let's go to our layouts add a
new file there we're going to call this
one main layout
dot HBS
and here we're going to put the skeleton
of our web page together
it's
write this out so we've been HTML
code
and
we're just going to keep this real
simple
and a header
you want to title
and this is going to be students
nice
nice maybe we just got students
so
we now go to
[Music]
try and find out bootstrap four we're
going to just grab that
and we're going to use
bootstrap to get started and there are a
couple components there's a CSS
component and then there's the
JavaScript component so let's just go
copy the CSS component
and then we're going to just link that
into the header section of us
web page
so
and then
here's an example of different
components you can create
if you're not used if you haven't used
bootstrap before it's an open source
framework which you developed by Twitter
great tool so in a header we want to
put in the link to the CSS
there's that
and
now I need to also
in our own styles
so we've got here some styles that we
created earlier on for
the work that we're doing you can just
paste those in
so we have a box style that we want to
use that will extend the Box style that
you get
with bootstrap
all right so we're going to start
working on our body content
plus BG info so this is actually BG info
is
a CSS class file from bootstrap that you
can use
the ID of box
thank you
and again we're going to do
another class
which allows us for our table structure
so a little bit of knowledge of
bootstrap is great here
so what we're going to do now is going
to put in
the content which we're going to call
Body missile show up on the screen
so again for pulling from records within
bootstrap dig through bootstraps lots of
content there for you to be able to take
advantage of
okay
so now we want to be able to add or edit
our record
View Title
and the
um
the the uh the the French brackets allow
you to be able to pull records and
content directly from the code that
we're writing
so playing title from insert record on
this part of our router
command
and then we'll put in our form
which will be student post
I'm just going to do a basic form here
nothing fancy
we will put in the first
record will be a hidden field this will
be for ID
so we want to generate the ID we don't
want to assembly put that in and then we
will put in
r
form elements
so we'll have first will be the label
that'll be full name
and be an input field
so be texting the input field
and again we're using form Dash control
which is from
bootstrap CSS and then we'll have
a full name
and placehold before name so if where we
have name there
um will actually match up with
the value that we're putting in our
model
so here we have student for name
so we're matching everything up to the
model that we created
okay so let's do this for our remaining
form elements
and again as you see we can put this
together really quickly
so I'm going to put in four as well the
email
and then we'll do mobile
and City
and
here we keep going
we put in form group
foreign
[Music]
type of
tool for putting in Mobile
foreign
just standard HTML here you can actually
reference external libraries such as
JavaScript libraries for formatting the
field that you're in regular Expressions
things like them
and let's put in a final value
which will be for City
and normally when I'd be writing this by
hand I would actually be copy and
pasting and sections of code and just
changing the values as necessary
just to make it easier on myself but
here I'm just typing out everything for
you so you can see the
the whole process
okay
all right so there are our values
of course remember save your files as
you're going along
everything looks good
and we're matching up our values
with uh
records
and we want to have a button that allows
you to submit
we also want to have a button to select
view or if you want to be able to view
all the records okay
looking good
okay let's go back over to list now we
want to be able to pull our records so
this will display
the
list of students
in a table
and right
let's go ahead and format that table
so we're going to put together our
format here but then we're also going to
add buttons at the bottom so we can
actually add a record to the database or
if we want to edit or delete a
particular record from the database
foreign
list
I'm just going to type all this in for
you
thank you
and you'll see how we put placeholders
for the values as we put them in
these are our table headers
okay
body content
and what we're going to do here is we're
going to add in
an element that allows you to create a
row for each item listed
so if you have two or more items they'll
appear as an individual row
on here
and again what we're doing is we're
pulling in the values to be able to
pull it from the model that we created
earlier on so this being the data that's
been submitted so we have it pull in the
value for the email full name
and mobile and City
we're not going to show ID
so I was playing out all of this data
that we created earlier on
so we have everything posted into our
list
as documents
so let's go into a HBS file
and it's our list
let's put in our
file entry here
this will be for City
man
this is just a placeholder
at the end
of the list
oh yeah you know what we're going to do
is we can add in
reference for the ID
so we want to edit the document we can
and then we want to do the same thing if
we want to delete the document
so href because
student
and then
just delete
now delete based on the ID
there we go
passing match instruction over
so click
to
[Music]
simple
I'm gonna ask him are you sure you want
to
delete that somebody clicks on the
record they hit cancel then it won't get
deleted over here it's okay then it will
get deleted
this is where you can actually write
JS in my
okay
and then we want to close out where the
row will end so have each opens and
closes the record
just tying up some of the HTML there
save that
okay looking good
back to our root index file
so let's see now
we want to also require
our model
and then
we'll have a
student controller
also be
a require
of where it's going to pull the student
controller from
okay
and this is just the instructions on
where we can actually find
content
okay it looks good so let's do node xjs
everything saved we're going to rerun
everything
and we got an error
let's go check out where our error came
from
so let's go and to our files
this is one that we created
so
error is in
true controller see where's the error
oh we need to
have our Munch we need to export our
module to our router
all right let's go open up [ __ ]
database
and we can just start
seeing where the records are
it's just installing the latest updates
here
so we need to go ahead and in our
connection string so it's on localhost
that's the port
let's just double check that make sure
we're
completely aligned so here's our
database connection
and
there's a report and student database
and we did this with mongod Mongoose for
connecting to manga
so I'm going to connect
and here are where our records are being
stored
so we're going to create a database and
we're going to call this database
it's going to be called student DB
student DB has to be case sensitive
and the picture name is students
let's go ahead and create a database so
there we are there's our database
and
let's go we run our index.js file
and everything was successful
this is good
all right
so everything should have passed
successfully good good good
database connection is good
so let's go to localhost
and here we are so we can start achieve
now we're going through our application
so we see we have our setup we have no
records
so let's go ahead and create one
and we go through you can actually start
stepping through the different layouts
that you've created so here's our layers
a separate to our code so there's some
spacing we probably need to add that so
let's go ahead and just add that
and let's rerun our code
this is the fun bits where you know
everything is
just tidying up okay so you know it puts
in one one space because we didn't put
in the actual HTML code for getting
multiple spaces
so we're going to go in and select
insert so let's put in
uh Smith and we'll do Smith at gmail.com
[Music]
and let's just put in I know random
phone number
there we are we don't have any
formatting so we could put anything in
there and the city uh I don't know where
am I
um this I'm in Delhi so split that hit
submit and it takes us to a list and
voila
we actually have a list with a record in
and if we go back to our database we can
actually refresh it and now we actually
start seeing our records being created
and we see the ID is automatically
created and there's our records
okay let's go back
and now we can select edit we can edit
the record
so let's change our city to
Bangalore hit submit
all right city is now Bangalore
and if we want to we can
edit again
and so this is pulling in
you know if we do a delete It's Gonna
ask us do we want to delete
okay
a little bit of formatting apply there
and the records are all good so we had
to make that Smith change
but because we need to hit submit to an
update record
so we hit submit I've teach the record
we hit delete it's going to say are you
sure we say yes we are
and ah
it has
grab that record okay so let's go back
look at my code
and
because we have everything separated and
actually now just go to our student
controller
and we'll find out Delete and you guys
delete now we had a
now we had a couple of minor errors
there this is where it's good to test
out your code
okay let's run that again
and refresh everything
so we go to our database we're gonna go
create a new entry
let's call this one with some John John
gmail.com
we will put in the phone number
you see that the formatting is just
playing from
um
our bootstrap so there we have there's
John do we want to delete they say yes
easy there we go also
and we have refresh the record should be
gone yep it is
and so we've created an application
where we can update applications
we can create an application we can list
all the items and we did all of this
using uh just open source Solutions
through node.js and that was with using
express some of the components come with
Express
mongodb for our database and then
Mongoose to connect to our database
so let's get started with typescript
with node.js but before we begin make
sure you have subscribed to our YouTube
channel and clicked on the Bell icon so
you never miss an update from Simply
learn
so we'll first look at what is
typescript
typescript is an object oriented and
strongly typed programming language
which is a superset of JavaScript
typescript was designed by Anders
hijelsberg at Microsoft
the limitations of JavaScript for
developing large-scale applications at
Microsoft and among its external
customers led to the creation of
typescript
due to the difficulty of working with
complicated JavaScript code there was a
demand for custom tooling to make
development of JavaScript components
easier
typescript code is converted to
JavaScript which can be executed
anywhere JavaScript is supported in a
browser on node.js or any other
application
typescript is a JavaScript with some
additional features to support a more
robust interaction with your editor
typescript adds additional syntax to
JavaScript
typescript is a scripting language that
understands JavaScript and uses type
inference to provide powerful
capabilities with additional code
foreign
Js
node.js is an open source server-side
execution platform for JavaScript code
node.js is a JavaScript runtime based on
the version 8 JavaScript engine from
chrome
node is an asynchronous event driven
JavaScript runtime for building scalable
Network applications
although node.js is excellent for
developing server side apps it lacks
several current features such as type
checking it can also be difficult to
manage a node.js code base
node is commonly used for real-time
applications like chat news feeds and
web push notifications because it allows
for a persistent connection from the
browser to the server
the current coding methods such as
static typing and type checking are
supported by typescript
it's designed to create complex and high
level applications that's why having
typescript as a primary language for
supporting node.js capabilities would be
idle
this also allows us to develop
server-side apps with rigorous type
checking avoiding run type errors and
other typescript benefits while
maximizing node.js capabilities
now let us see how to set up the
development environment for typescript
with node.js
the prerequisites are we need to have
typescript installed in our device and
node.js
to install node.js go to the official
website
go to node.js.org and go to downloads so
here you can see
we have node.js for different browsers
for Windows Mac OS and source code
so go to Windows if you have Windows PC
and click on install
click on Windows and here you can see it
is getting installed since I have
already installed in my device I'll
cancel it
so once you have installed go to the
command prompt
and just enter
node.v to check if node is installed
properly
so here you can see the node is
installed in my system
to install typescript just run the
command npm
node package manager
install
globally
typescript
run this command and typescript will be
installed since I have already installed
typescript in my device
to cancel this so once you have
installed typescript to check if
typescript is installed or not to see if
the compiler is installed just run the
command
typescript compiler space
version
here you can see it will show the
version of typescript compiler
so now that we have installed both
typescript and node.js let's see
example program for typescript with
node.js
so let's jump into Visual Studio code
one more prerequisite is we need to have
Visual Studio code installed
so create a new folder and create a new
project
so we'll run an example program we'll
create a function
we'll write a program to add two numbers
so sum
number one
comma number two
will return number one and number two
console.log
will call the function sum and will
provide the arguments
so we'll provide the value
9 comma
5.
so let's say if
and run this program
first we'll run
typescript.cmd type.ts command
oh
then we'll hit our then we'll run node
and the file name
here you can see it's showing the value
showing the output as 49 plus 5 the sum
of 9 plus 5 is 40. so we'll delete this
and
write another program
to show a Hello message or a welcome
message
so we'll create a function
we'll name the function as welcome
message
and will return
that user
is equal to
simply learn
console log
will call the function
welcome
and pass
so here we go we'll save this and check
whether we have an error
foreign
welcome to Simply learn we're going to
be going through some of the simple
questions that you would be asked during
a node.js interview let's just get
started so the first question you're
probably going to be asked is you know
what is node.js you know do you know
what it's for and essentially node.js is
and one of the most popular if not the
most popular open source cross-platform
JavaScript programs um it allows you to
build out web applications that run on
the server it's extremely flexible it
allows you how to implement a lot of
solutions outside of just the the core
programming runtime and it allows you to
build Solutions extremely quickly in an
open source mindset for devops
it is used essentially for creating
client-sized web applications we'll see
this later on and you may want to talk a
little bit about using express.js and
how you can build out apis uh to work
with node.js and connecting to databases
such as mongodb
and that is also really good for being
able to store a data intensive
applications that are asynchronous and
event driven in their model and this is
important when you're talking about
creating applications that can scale
rapidly
so you can then ask be asked you know
how does node.js work well node.js
itself is actually built on the V8
engine and the V8 JavaScript engine is
the same engine that runs JavaScript in
your Chrome web browser extremely fast
it allows for high output and
non-blocking uh through your i o input
outputs and is is single threaded event
Loop
so you're going to be a van asked you
know where can you use node.js and and
the reality is the applications for
node.js keep expanding but there are
some core applications that you can work
with node.js right now so such as web
applications distributed system and
network applications uh probably
referencing the web applications is a
really good starting point because here
you can actually talk about maybe some
examples that you've done where you're
building out some of these web
applications indeed one of the things
that you want to be consistently doing
and peppering your answers with is
examples of work that you have done now
it doesn't matter if those examples are
purely experimental or training examples
that you've done the fact that you've
actually worked with node.js and created
a distributed system or a web
application is really valuable because
it shows that the person that you're
meeting with that you have knowledge and
understanding and practical experience
of applying the theory of working with
new Js with the practice of working with
node.js
so we asked about you know essentially
the io refers to the transfer of data in
and out of a system and that's really it
you know there's a reason why Google
calls that conference i o it's the
transfer of data in and out of our
brains at that conference the
application is same here it's about
moving data in and out of systems
through using node.js
and that every um event can be tracked
and whether it's on a physical device a
network or files within a system again
it's input and output
so let's go through and you know you're
going to be asked you know can you
explain the difference between front end
and back-end development and this is a
question that I can ask a lot when I'm
meeting with clients um you know people
get really confused about what is the
difference between front-end and
back-end development bottom line front
end is what gets resolved inside of your
web browser or the app on your mobile
device backend is what gets resolved
essentially what we call the the back
office or server-side applications but
that's becoming more and more synonymous
for what gets running the cloud
so web applications
um really get a lot of the functionality
of web application gets run in the front
end and I think with CSS HTML5 uh
client-side JavaScript so we can get
right in the front end everything else
such as connecting to a database gets
run behind the scenes in the back end
and so you know anything that's going to
have like Graphics is going to be on the
front end uh apis are going to be run on
the back end and then just finally some
of the scripting languages are using on
the front end so HTML CSS JavaScript
those are all Common Core scripting
languages that you would use you can use
Frameworks such as angularjs and
react.js or view those would be a
front-end Frameworks uh back-end
Frameworks would include Java PHP Python
and node.js are some of the back-end
Technologies you could also throw in
their dot net as well and it's just the
whole you know Litany of front-end and
back-end Technologies and Frameworks
that you can use and this is a actually
a good point to kind of explain the
experience you have outside of just
working with node.js but other
technologies that you've been working
with that potentially that the client is
also using
so another question you're going to be
asked when you're looking at node.js is
you know can you tell me about npm and
so when somebody asks you what is npm
the first thing you're going to respond
is do you mean node package manager and
the reason why you want to respond like
that is that you want to qualify that
question with understanding that you
know what they're talking about but you
want them to verify that and so node
packet manager is npm
and it's responsible for packaging all
of your modules that you're working with
in node.js and we have a whole series of
videos that we've done on node.js and
every single one of them includes
references to npm
so you're going to be asked you know so
okay you tell me um what it is you know
can you go into a little bit more um
details you know so you can provide two
main functionalities and so one of them
is being able to manage online
repositories of modules and packages
um so you can go to like
search.nodejs.org and you can find a
packages that you can install Into Your
solution such as express.js and it also
provides a command line utility that
allows you to manage uh your packages
very quickly through terminal window or
command line
I use vs code a lot Visual Studio code
and it has a command line utility built
right into it that allows me to interact
with npm
so what are some of the modules in
node.js and so you know modules um in
node.js they're essentially like
JavaScript libraries so you can think of
some of the JavaScript libraries that
you may have used the functionality is
somewhat the same but they're designed
for node.js and to run on the server and
there are ways in which you can go ahead
and create some of those modules so for
instance if we're creating a web server
you can actually use the require
commands to be able to require that the
server be there so the example we have
on the right hand side shows that we
really do need to have HTTP which is a
web server and we require that to be
installed and so that if you're running
that npm package it will actually
install the HTTP server and then you can
actually write some code to actually
then listen on the localhost port 2000
for where you'll be running your app
education
and there are just you know there's a
whole bunch of modules that I come with
node.js now right out of the gate and
here are some of the modules that you
have and we also referenced that just
tell everyone HTTP is a core module for
uh running a web server uh you have a
utility function that is useful for
developers to assess features within
your node.js project you have a URL
module for any URL passing you'd be
doing
and you also have a stream which allows
you to be able to stream data in and out
of your system and be able to manage how
that's been worked and then zlib which
allows you to compress and decompress
files so that you can keep your storage
of files
um to a minimum
so a question you're going to be asked
is you know why is node.js being
preferred over backend Technologies such
as Java and PHP and particularly gyro
it's a very mature stable language it's
been around for more than 20 years you
know PHP runs some of them the most
powerful and largest websites out there
such as Facebook so why would you use
node.js well the first response is kind
of a gimme but it is really fast and if
you watched any of the videos that we've
done on node.js building out Solutions
and developing the solutions you'll see
just how fast it is the second is the
really kind of the secret sauce with
node.js is the node package manager and
no package manager allows you to install
additional functionality such as Express
or [ __ ] as a database into your
solution really quick clean and there's
over 50 000 bundles available for node
package manager
if you're building out a real-time
application that's data intensive and
you need to have apis quickly developed
then node.js is another great it's
really the great solution for you it
allows you to build out these Solutions
really quickly
and there is a easy synchronization
between the server and the client due to
the code base
and then finally because the structure
of node.js is Javascript if you are
making the pivot from being a front-end
web developer to node.js it's just going
to make it a lot easier for you to pick
up node.js because you have that common
language of JavaScript and on top of
that JavaScript is the world's most
popular scripting language
so let's talk about some of the
differences between angular node.js and
so and the reason why this question may
come up is the person interviewing you
is seeing whether or not you do know the
difference between a front-end framework
and a back-end framework and this is one
of those questions where you can go well
there are differences but the
differences are because they complement
each other so angular is a front-end
development framework whereas node.js is
a server side and framework are the
difference is though between the actual
Frameworks themselves is that angular is
written in typescript which is a
modification of JavaScript node.js is
written in C and C plus plus
anger is used for building out single
play client-side web applications and so
that's a keyword there is client-side
whereas node.js is about building out
fast and scalable server-side Network
applications uh so uh again the two
complement each other
uh angular splits web applications into
the MVC and model view control
components whereas node.js generates a
lot of database crazy it does more than
that as well but you can think of
node.js as that glued to your database
so let's talk a little bit about when
you're connecting to a database with
node.js and so
um you're going to probably be asking
what is
um the most popular database used with
node.js and there are a couple um
mongodb is largely the most popular
nosql cross-platform database MySQL is
also very popular and that's a more
traditional relational database
you would go with mongodb for a really
more modern solutions when you're
looking at creating an application
that's going to really scale into just
managing masses and masses of data that
has to be created read updated and
deleted very very quickly
for some of the other popular libraries
that you use for node.js Express JS is a
very popular one and I really like
working with express.js allows me to
build out web applications really
quickly more importantly it allows me to
build out apis very quickly and which
you know apis are essentially web
applications themselves but being able
to do that very quickly with a framework
like express.js is very useful uh
Mongoose is an application that makes
connecting to a [ __ ] database really
easy so here is an example of express.js
which is a in itself really a flexible
but a solution that you can do lots with
and Mongoose which is a more focused
solution which allows you know to you
make it easier to connect to your
databases
so you know what are the pros and cons
of working with node.js there's lots of
ways we explain this earlier on that you
can actually build out applications that
run on the cloud why would you you know
what's are the pros and cons so a pro is
that node.js is extremely faster
processing thing and event based model
uh it really is fast I can't is if you
have something that is a very heavy
computational task it's not so good at
that now I will caveat that this is that
node.js is getting better all the time
and so you might have to be provide an
example of what a very heavy
computational task is and that may be uh
calculating a risk on an insurance
application against many many variables
that maybe something that's seen as
computationally very heavy but what you
can do in that example is you can then
offload the task to another other
solution that's designed for it and use
apis to pass the data back and forth Pro
JavaScript is used for building out your
applications with node.js great lots of
people know
JavaScript a restriction and again this
is evolving as JavaScript itself evolves
is that when you do a callback you may
end up doing lots of nested callbacks if
you're doing something that's very
complicated again another way around the
con and so this is one of the things
that I always look for is if you have a
blocker or a barrier how do you get
around that barrier and so for instance
when you're talking uh to your recruiter
you can say look the reason why I use
node.js is that it's fast it's event but
it's driven I can use JavaScript there
are some challenges and but what I do to
get around those challenges are and
that's where you can say that you know
you may run the complex script off and
you may write that in net or Java or PHP
and then use an API to do the response
back into node.js so you get the
benefits of Both Worlds but minimize the
investment in having to manage a complex
environment such as Java versus a
relatively simple environment with
node.js the node package manager makes
it extremely easy to access just an
awful lot of functionality with over 50
000 packages there's a package for that
so from being able to have a a tool that
creates unique identifiers that you
might need to have for generating
content that gets posted into a database
through to to being able to connect to
databases through you know to running so
many different solutions and the npm
package manager with its access to so
many different packages makes it great
for getting access to all that content
now Khan is working with relational
databases with node.js isn't as easy as
a nosql database now you can do it and
there are ways around that and what I
would do when this question comes up is
always kind of pivot to say hey this is
how you can actually then get around
building out that application
Pro for node.js designed for streaming
huge amounts of data in and out a con is
that node.js is single threaded and so
it can be CPU intensive but again there
are ways around that and a good way
around that is scaling Your solution and
elastic environments such as the cloud
so what is the command used to import an
external library and so to import an
external Library the command is the
require command so an example we have
here is uh you can assign a variable and
the variable is going to be for HTTP and
you're going to then require the HTTP
service and that means that the
application itself won't run unless the
external Library the HTTP library is
installed
okay so those were our introductory uh
questions for node.js this kind of pivot
and take a look at the intermediate
questions that you would be asked
so what does event driven programming
mean so event driven programming means
that if something happens something else
will happen in response so for instance
if you click a mouse that Mouse click is
an event that means something has to
respond to that event just think of it
as cause and effect it's just the basic
motion of physics so that's what event
driven programming means
you also look at it as a callback
function so that when an element is
executed something will happen in
response
so what is an event Loop in node.js so
an event Loop in node.js is when you do
an asynchronous call and what that
essentially means is that you are
sending out data and then a non-blocking
input output from node.js is pulling
data back in
what is an event emitter in node.js so
an event emitter has really two areas of
focus one is that it manages the classes
that hold all the objects within your
event and we have an example of this on
the right hand side and then whenever an
event actually is thrown the functions
are then called on that event
synchronously so for instance we have in
our example on the right hand side we
create an event and then we have the
functions and the executed in a series
from that event
so let's talk about the API functions in
node.js so there's two times uh one is
an asynchronous non-blocking function
and the second is a synchronous blocking
function and the difference between the
two of them is asynchronous is that
there is no structure to the order
if I have the API is resolved
synchronous means that when the feedback
from the API is received you have to
execute the response in a series for how
the response is sent to you
so what is a package Json file so the
package Json file is at the heart of our
node.js package when we actually will
initialize a solution a folder to be in
node.js package
you'll find that the package itself
holds all of the metadata that's
particular to the project you're working
on such as project name version
requirements it is you have to have it
installed in the root of the directory
for the project and again look at any of
the videos that we have on node.js we do
have demonstrations within those videos
that actually then go through and break
out how to create that root package and
you'll see how you can actually then go
ahead and update the instructions or the
metadata within the package so here we
have an example of what that metadata
looks like so again this kind of
continues that question of what is a
packet Json file and you maybe ask you
know what is the metadata and why is it
important and the metadata is a basic
Json collection of pairing of key
details such as name version description
and then and the custom version that you
put so for instance under name you could
create a name for your project there
can't be any spaces what is the version
and the description and what is the main
or starting path and for the solution
typically that would be index.js but it
could be anything.js but index.js is
typical simply because
index.html is the starting point for a
typical web application
so how would you use a URL module in
node.js
so with the URL module what it allows
you to do is really two things one is
that it provides the resolution passing
of a URL for Utilities in your
application and then it allows you to
extend your module with built-in
Solutions and split up the web address
into a readable format
so in this example we have the URL and
the response it would would give for
that URL which would then be a year and
month and it'd be in a readable format
so it would read out as 2020 and then
the month
so what is express.js and you've heard
me mentioned this a couple of times in
the video and we actually have a
separate video on express.js
um I would express.js is a web
application framework that allows you to
build out Web Solutions for both mobile
and traditional desktop right inside of
node.js so it's very easy to use
and being able to install and web.js is
as simple as requiring Express to be
installed in the example that we have
here on the screen it's a full solution
of showing how to actually build out a
solution with web.js so in this example
you start off the first two lines
required Express to be installed and the
store comes from node package manager
then we have a simple application that
will then send to the browser window a
hello world message confirming that
Express is up and running and then the
third block of content starting with
virus server actually will Define the
port where your application is going to
run so in this instance the port is
going to run on localhost and the port
will be Port 8081 and so you can
actually go to localhost colon 8081 and
when you do that that will trigger the
Apple education that will forward up the
message hello world and it's all coming
from express.js
so what are streams in node.js so
streams are objects that allow you to
read and write data continuously back
and forth within your application and
there's really four different types of
streams there's readable writable duplex
and transform
the readable one strength for which data
can be read
uh the writable streams that you can
actually write to a duplex is a stream
where it is both readable and writable
and transform our streams that can be
manipulated the data while it is being
read or written
so how do you update and delete a
dependency so say for instance we want
to install uh something like Express so
if you wanted to install Express what
you would do is you would just write
them inside of your project you want to
go to terminal window and write in the
command npm install Express
if you want to update the dependencies
within your node package manager to
update all of them all you have to do is
write the command npm update all
dependencies
and then if you want to explicitly
uninstall a dependency such as
express.js that's using the uninstall
command and so that would again be going
to terminal window and you would type
npm uninstall Express
and again it's really easy to create a
simple server in node.js that will run a
simple command the HTTP service is
actually built into node.js you don't
need to use express.js I typically use
express.js when I want to do a web
server because typically what I find is
that I will want to go and do something
more complicated but if you want to do
something that illustrates just the core
functionality within node.js you can
actually just require the core HTTP
service that actually comes as part of
node.js and then you can actually then
go ahead and tell it to create a service
and then to write in plain text I
command or text string such as this case
it'll be hello world and that would pop
out and then the final line is to then
listen that if you go to a web browser
that's on
port127.0.01 or localhost and go to Port
colon 8080 once you actually go to that
that will trigger this application and
you'll get the text hello world pop up
on your screen
so explain synchronous and non-blocking
apis in node.js
so all the apis in node.js are
asynchronous which means that they are
non-blocking which means you can run
them continuously and scale around that
which is just fantastic it's one of the
reasons why node.js can scale so fast
and the eighth means that the apis can
return data send data after it's been
called and really increase the
efficiency of events as they are
triggered Within node.js
so how do you implement async and
node.js and so the example that we have
on the left hand side allows us to
trigger async and it's using the async
function and as you can see in this
example it's actually something that can
be done very quickly in this example
we're actually making a command to
localhost and an app that's running on
Port 3000 and then depending on what we
get if there's an error message and then
we'll have error message go to the
console log which is the terminal window
and if we get a response to an
application then we'll actually get a
positive response which would be fetched
response so again very quick and easy
that you use the async function to be
able to build out and you to get your
asynchronous code
so what is the purpose of module exports
so a module export is a way to
encapsulate your the entire code for a
solution in a single package and a
single file and then you can then share
that with other developers so you're all
working from the same environment
so what is a callback function in
node.js a callback function is
essentially that once you run and you've
triggered events and the response has
been given you want to be able to then
have a callback to validate that the
task is complete
all right let's move on to the final set
of questions which is Advanced node.js
questions
so what is repel in node.js so Rebel
stands for read eval print and loop and
this is a reference to the Unix and
Linux background that node.js has
so Rebel will form the following tasks
the read will be actually passing the
JavaScript it'll read that and store it
in memory eval takes and evaluates the
data structure print will then print the
results often on the console window or
onto a web page and then Loop Loops the
above command until the user presses
Ctrl C twice
what is the control flow function so the
control flow function is a piece of code
that runs between several of
asynchronous functions and that's it it
actually controls how those functions
execute
so how control flow controls the
function calls and it does it through
four ways one is it controls the order
of execution it collects the data it
limits the concurrency and then it also
calls the next step in a program again
this is a management tool for how your
functions are called Within node.js
so what is the difference between fork
and spawn methods in node.js
so the essential difference between the
two of them is that if you use the fork
method it will actually trigger and
create a new instance of the V8 engine
the engine running node.js and we'll
then run the application in that new
instance with spawn it's somewhat
similar it doesn't actually generate a
new V8 instance so it's actually
creating a new process but it's within
the same V8 instance as the previous
application that it was spawned from
explain to me what is the use of buffer
class in node.js
so with the butter class what you're
looking at doing is you're actually
controlling the raw data of a set of
arrays and integers and the memory
allocation outside of the V8 Heap both
the class is used because pure
JavaScript is not compatible with binary
data
what is piping in node.js so piping is
the ability to connect the output of one
stream to another stream that could be a
data stream it could be any stream that
you're working with but it does normally
get used to pass data from one stream to
another
so what are some of the facts used in
the rewrite operation files so our Dash
is used for read W's for opening a file
for writing a dash that is opening a
file for appending so the collection
that you have here you don't have to
really memorize all of them but to have
a few of them in the back of your mind
is always a good reference point
so how would you open a file using
node.js
so the syntax you would use would be the
fs dot open and that would then open up
a file
explain to me what callback hell is so
callback helps known as the Pyramid of
Doom is when you have too many nested
unreadable and unmanageable callbacks
intensively cycle within each other and
they're constantly reading to each other
and they're not able to resolve the
solution
and this is a you know it's a big
problem and this is what why it's called
callback how because you're not able to
finalize the the app you're working on
what is a reactive pattern in node.js
and so a reactive pattern is a concept
of non-blocking i o operations
can you explain to me the test pyramid
for node.js so the test pyramid and this
is standard for testing uh for all
devops is really split into three key
areas you have unit tests integration
tests and then end-to-end or e2e tests
uh the unit tests are tests that you're
actually doing your raw code that you're
working on and the goal there is to be
able to validate that the code you're
writing is consistently working
integration allows you to
um have tests that integrate your raw
code that you're working with in your
application with other areas of an
application and then end to end is the
whole system the whole interface as it
were for your solution
describe the exit codes of node.js
so an exit code is a specific code that
identifies the end of a specific process
and examples of exit codes are unused
and called fatal exception fatal error
internal JavaScript evaluation area
these are all good examples of exit
codes
so what is a middleware can you explain
the concept of middleware in node.js so
with middleware it is the ability to be
able to connect to a system and get data
from it that's outside of node.js so
this may be executing a type of code or
updating a modifying request in response
to a specific type of object
finishing the request response cycle
can you explain to me what other types
of HTTP requests that you may use when
working with node.js there are actually
quite a lot but four of them that you
might use would be get post head and
delete and these are if you've done any
web application before particularly
worked with forms inside of a web
application you're probably very
familiar certainly with get and post
again it's the request to retrieve data
post is generally used for changing
stating and data ahead is similar to get
but also asks for response if there's no
body content so if you're using if
you're developing an API this would be a
good one to use and delete is used to
delete the predetermined source
so how will you connect to mongodb
database and with node.js and you use
that using the [ __ ] client and the
example we have on the left hand side
illustrates that
what is the use of node underscore EMV
and so the node underscore Envy is an
environmental variable that stands for
node environment in Express server so
the example we have on the right hand
side allows you to illustrate how you
would do that for say a production
environment
so what are some of the various timing
features in node.js so the timing
functions that you could use here set
timeout and then clear timeout and you
to schedule code execution that you'd
have inside of your application
you also have set interval and clear
interval to execute a block of code up
multiple times in your application
set intermediate and clear intermediate
to execute code that is at the end of
your application
and with that we come to the end of this
full course tutorial if you enjoyed
watching the video do gives it a thumbs
up comment your doubts below and our
experts will answer them for you thank
you so much for being here watch out for
more videos from us until then keep
coding and stay tuned to simpler
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign